foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
always go away yes
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Champs five finals everybody uh I've
lost so much of the value of this trophy
uh here's a little feedback by the way
the broadcast we are here live in Los
Angeles with three Championship matches
that are gonna happen today
today
we are here anyway uh chat I hope you
guys are all having a good day today a
lot of great chess is going to be
happening uh and we're going to start
things off with the constellation
bracket uh which is a a uh and can they
hear it
it's like it's like a loop which is a a
row row row your boat
it's like it's like I'm gonna wait a
second I'm gonna wait a second we'll be
back we'll be back soon Trophy and
starintelli into the camera of the
trophy yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to pog Champs 5
finals I'm joined by a cast of people
who are good at chess and me your host
today Ludwig uh this is Twitter name two
this is Twitter name three and Twitter
name four hello how are you doing botez
is in Hess I'm excited to be here I want
to watch streamers have to actually try
over the board chess for once and what
about you hes what are your thoughts
it's good to see you again
don't pretend we didn't we we hang me
and as hang out it's not a big deal it's
a cool thing about me
and on pump though the players are
really into it I feel like there are
going to be some people forgetting to
press their clock and things like that
but they're in for a good time yeah that
probably will happen Andre do you
remember your first tournament I was
sick so no I do not that's abuse can I
say it because the parent brings you to
a match when you're six years old that
should count as child abuse that's not
that's not that could not be fun it was
like I was just trying to score a free
vacation because winner would get to
Greece to complete in the World Chess
Championship and mom told me there was
free food and spaghetti so I just wanted
to go I was excited I was like free
vacation if I win this game of chess
let's go win and go to Greece did you
get to go uh I got last place the first
year I won first place the second so I
went the second year okay we went out
sisters
used to be really competitive and at one
point he would track our ratings side by
side at each age it was a little crazy
yes
and there was one year slightly
surpassed my sister and then all
downhill from there but there was a time
no I was real nervous that year that
shoot just because I started training
really hard since then well lucky for
you but you you both are are a lot
better the competitors are watching
today because
they're all creators uh so let's
actually take a look at the format uh
and our first first match is going to be
a consolation bracket we got both the
finals today consolation and
Championship it's four games of ten five
best of four they call it
yeah that's what the Grandmasters call
it yes do you call it that you call it
something different
[Laughter]
uh one point for uh per win half a point
per draw first to 2.5 is what Pros do
has
like would you do this I would love to
do this yeah we've had terms just like
this that's a normal format very normal
best of four and it's a tie breaker if
it's 2-2 how does a tiebreaker work Hess
well you know if the case of the tied
they got three minutes with five seconds
added per move it is sudden death and
play continues until someone wins I
don't think we'll see too many draws but
stalemates do happen
yeah I don't think people of this skill
level know maybe how to draw and even
when to draw uh that seems like a skill
of its own but sometimes it happens
accidentally I've been there it's called
stalemate it's it's cool
it's a stupid role I remember your
stalemate yeah
I think cutie knows very well how to
draw anything
I'll never forget it that's one of my
great skills which is why I'm not going
to be on this next uh slide here which
is past champions
boy boy it's hafu sardosh in Fundy I
can't believe fun did that you know I
mean let me say it podcast 4 is a joke
my chance four is a who who's the
strongest here
sardosh he's gonna go for hafu but yeah
yeah I'm glad you guys said that because
I beat sardosh in a game once so wow not
a big deal not a big deal awesome next
yeah let's take a look at the
consolation bracket uh that led us to
our current finals constellation bracket
oftentimes the more viewed match that's
where I think the the Charlie verse most
critical match was had 17 million views
that's a lot yeah right for a chess
match
uh and we have cutie versus virtual
anyone surprised by our finals here
I am a little surprised that virtual is
in the consolation bracket it seems a
little bit crazy since he was one of the
highest rated players going in that
being said he has he had the most
difficult bracket before so all I can
say is good luck cutie we believe in you
wow
wow okay well let's take a look at the
championship brag and the people that
place over virtual uh what about this
one any surprises Andrea what do you
think
you know I like that honestly I've been
cheering for Frank since day one he is
Gotham student but Frank is a great
personality from chess and although he
has a mighty 200 Blitz rating his
rapid's actually been greatly improving
I like both of our competitors see dog
came all the way from Japan Frank from
the UK they traveled a long distance for
this match and I'm expecting it to be
very hype
yeah I think Frank lucked out about I
mean he beat Gastly which was a very
impressive win but the xqc win of course
is the infamous playing game uh and I've
played several ranked chess matches on
chess.com on a plane it sucks you get
about one move every 10 seconds and then
it just has this loading bubble and you
just have to wait for it there's nothing
you can do
uh so Frank got that W and we'll see how
he does against Connor uh but we have a
bit of a schedule that that will be the
last match of the day we have three
total matches we're watching uh the
first one is the consolation finals
virtual vs cutie uh and then in between
that is a salty sweet match which we'll
talk about in a second and then around 4
30 we'll have Sea Dog versus Frank
the big Championship Racket and this is
the salty sweet we've got to have a
better picture of Iran yeah why who did
this yes
the picture shopped on his face so this
is better than what I've been looking at
all day uh tyler1 versus e-rob it's the
rematch of the brothers uh we'll talk
about that when that comes up that's
after consolation but there's a lot of
money on the line today uh that's that's
you know what Conor told me he said this
is why he came out
because he flew from Japan he was like I
would have thrown my game against I did
a thing but I guarantee you get twelve
thousand dollars and he was like it's
worth it for twelve thousand to fly from
Japan to LA and then back to Japan in
the span of like 36 hours uh which I
would agree 20K for first place and then
uh the the consolation 7K for first 5k
for second how
maybe it's a dumb question how is there
so much money in chess
there's a lot of money in creators
playing chess but Robert how does this
compare to competitive chess you know
competitive chess thrives in Longford
thanks to these Creator events more
people who watch the better is for the
ecosystem NPR training yeah I didn't I
just said this on the flight what's the
most money you've won at a tournament uh
over 20 grand damn yeah
yeah first place uh no the US
Championship a month two years ago so
okay yeah all right uh we're gonna take
a look at the Players
that we're going to see here the first
constellation cutie Cinderella
and virtual or whoever I don't give a
or the second guy the second
guy I'm not biased I'm an unbiased
commentator
dude I thought we were gonna take a look
at you oh I was saying how much I love
you virtual have a seat uh have a seat
here I think there you go
how you guys doing oh my God this is so
stressful I was saying how much I love
you and respect you I don't know a lot
of wiggas are I've been following the
stream
oh sounded a little different what came
through my my ears but well either way
congratulations to both of you for
making this far and making five thousand
dollars minimum not bad uh how are you
feeling about today cutie how do you
feel you go first I feel fine I feel
fine
that's it you feel fine okay cool that's
all I've got listen I'm here for a good
time not a win time okay how I feel
about it uh virtually it seems like
everyone in this room including your
opponent that's what I was talking about
they almost uh in addition to hating you
expect you to win
yeah there I do have the favorite label
going in it's something I tend to do
well with being a favorite performing
Under Pressure I'm kind of known for
that yeah I'm kind of known for that
wait to be clear virtual is a track
Mania Creator and always an underdog
because you're kind of fraudulent like
you're a Creator you're not like a pro
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this is in if
anything the opposite it is the opposite
and once I got into the consolation
bracket I was like oh you know I would
want to be in the Champions but I've
been practicing a lot so I hope I can
make this trip worth it and you know
tell me about your practice regimen what
have you been doing over the past week
and a half two weeks uh I've been
studying The Stonewall because cutie
Cinderella has about 700 games on
chess.com and 680 are like one opening
so
she does grinds putting it out there
she's a good player and what did you do
to warm up for this
[Music]
four or five fake chess accounts
um I've also been sending hate mail to
every email he has trying to get in his
head I've said some awful things to his
mother
I know and I meant it okay all right
well sorry Mom I'll beat her for you
okay a lot of tension in this match uh
any any final words between you two
anything you want to say to each other
um
hey
if I don't win a match today I don't
know if I'll see you at the stream
rewards that's all I'm saying
you're a Believer or a dollar you might
want to doubt one game because I got a
flag
You Gotta Throw one virtual all right
we'll see uh best of four you guys can
go on up uh and play your match I'll
take that from you God speak to you both
good luck good luck good luck and we're
gonna talk about predictions while
you're gone don't look don't don't look
at the broadcast
win
so how much do you think he'll win by
uh I think there's a real chance she
does win
and I want you to explain why I think
that because I don't know why I think
that I just believe it irrationally is
this your stand-up comic bit because we
watched cutie do that last night okay
what do you actually have no faith no I
do have faith I went over and was trying
to help her prepare I think sometimes
Kitty gets in her own head she's
definitely a better chess player than
she gives herself credit for and I think
for newer players sometimes they rely on
memorization rather than on just
figuring out the why behind each move
like why did my opponent do that and how
should I respond in kind she's not a
newer player she's still a relatively
new player I guess in terms of her
overall chess hours but she's been
playing for years now yeah but also
sometimes when you just play without
getting consistent coaching that still
makes you like a new report you're just
playing and playing and playing it's
hard to learn from just playing without
understanding what went wrong and what
you can do differently like stop playing
the Stonewall I've been a thousand for
four years I will be a thousand rated
for the next 40 years can I still keep
the title of newer players you know took
lessons more you know maybe you know
yeah
uh all right let's go around predictions
Andrea who do you think wins and by how
much what's the score okay well it
depends on my first question is cutie
actually gonna play The Stonewall yes
literally prep that's true I'm not one
to tell you I'm a little nervous because
it's so easy for virtual to prep but I
okay my prediction is that kitty will
score at least a draw
oh half a point how generous Rachel's
terrifying okay I've seen him training
he comes in early he was playing like
odds game versus Gotham it was nearly
even I'm kind of terrified and I I would
like cutie to score at least to draw and
I'd be happy he's a terrifying opponent
thoughts
you know what somebody has to be rooting
for Cutie here I'm gonna say that
they're gonna go to tie break
Judy is gonna surprise us all she might
be the underdog but she does have the
POG Champs experience and again she
threatened him it might work so your
your big prediction rooting for Cutie is
not that she will win but that she'll
just make it to tie break who knows what
will happen in time like my prediction
only goes
so far Hess which one section I'm going
3-1 virtual I think that kitty will get
a win we've seen zero draws in the
entire consolation bracket yep I don't
think we're seeing one now uh I think
I'm with you except the opposite 3-1 in
favor of cutie Cinderella all right why
are you laughing I believe this it will
happen we can speak it into existence uh
I I think virtual he's weaker than he
seems I think if he gets cracked if he
get if he does a blunder he can lose
virtual's mom is down voting this twitch
like the stream please please uh all
right let's take a look we got a little
video uh of these two and then we'll hop
right into the match
and I think that gives me a big upper
hand in chess a big advantage of having
his cutie might be tactics spotting
patterns that can give me an advantage
in a couple of moves if she's not
careful every Thanksgiving I play
against my eight-year-old nephew he
sucks
but that is over the board and I I'll
whip him I think where she has an
advantage is experience as she has over
600 games with one opening on on
chess.com so that's going to be very
difficult to face I'm gonna try to get
in virtual's head because I think that's
my only benefit I'm gonna threaten not
to invite him to the streamer Awards if
he wins I'm gonna bring up his mother I
want to do whatever I can I've been
watching cuties games before the finals
she has had some really really great
tactics that she spotted I think he will
win and if he doesn't then that's a
shame on Norway cutie if you watch this
I
really appreciate you and I think we're
gonna have a great game but
I traveled all the way out from Norway
and I didn't do that to lose the finals
so I'm gonna play my best chess and I
hope we can have a good game but
I think I will be the one winning in the
up oh virtual I'm sure you were very
nice to me
but I think
I think when we
won I'm the only girl playing come on
please
virtual
all right here it is consolation finals
it's virtual it's cutie is it virtual
you say with the beach is it with a v w
it's a w it's a virtual word it's a w I
don't know if it's like Norwegian you
pronounce it differently like German vs
W's virtual virtual guy's name before ah
it's fine it will do great up there uh
we're gonna jump in it's over the board
this now this is what makes pogchamps 5
a little different from the previous POG
Champs we're in person obviously which
is a lot different than playing online
uh and and I know that because I lose
track of the pieces all the time
in my defense my board is like a Lord of
the Rings board and all the little pawns
have shields which confuses me and I
mistake them as Bishops I did hear that
from Robert he said it was very hard to
help with teaching my channel
my chat's the one that bought it all
right we're into it we're into it is
this the stone wall no it's the caracons
Kitty's black oh we did look at this
yesterday so let's see how soon is she
playing into your wow different opening
let's go wait that seems like a crew
they're playing so fast yes putting the
pressure on this is basically a
transpose Sicilian though with the
elephant defense oh look at you
remembering these allopins so uh this is
actually what we looked at yesterday she
knew that once the Knight develops her
white she put her Bishop on the Square
to pin the Knight so if that knight ever
moves the queen will be lost so this is
exactly what we talked about cutie
remembers it and not just that I think
she understands it pretty well
yeah I think some difficulty I've had
because I've played this sort of
position is is getting the night out so
usually curious will do here unpins the
Knight
I guess that makes sense and we have we
have our little we have our little meter
on the left but you hate when people
look at that right well
well yes but I think also sometimes it's
just beneficial to try to evaluate for
yourself
oh God it's so tense in person is almost
it's more nerve-wracking
and I love that we are filming this in a
similar fashion to where they're playing
online we don't have the full Board of
them but I like it I like it it's way
easier for me to understand what's
happening
wow okay also we got hair
that man is not balding for at least
another 20 years good for him good for
him you got a good crown on you virtual
you got a good Crown heck yeah
uh yeah I this is this is what they see
like fundamentally it is just harder for
me to grasp where the pieces are do you
guys feel that I mean you guys are much
more talented chess players but do you
still see a difference I I don't as much
but when I would be training my coach
would make me do tactics over the board
so that I actually got more realistic
practice and from every newer player who
I talked to they did they do struggle
with seeing tactics and board Vision
yeah what I'm most curious about is most
of our players today I've only played
chess while they're streaming so they're
always used to having some secondary
distraction whether it's chat or music
so maybe some people are going to
perform 10 times better just because
they are fully focused or it could be
the opposite but yeah I've never seen
cutie so focus on something and cutie is
playing exactly what we looked at so she
brings her Knight out to F5 which is a
great decision because she's piling up
all of her pieces these both these
nights and the pawn on C5 against this
Pawn on D4 so that is what she's aiming
for right now we talked about how the
queen can also venture out to B6 to put
even more pressure on she's in exactly
what she learned how deep into this
variation did you guys prepare no it
wasn't about like memorizing a long
series of moves it was just I think
that's what her struggles have meant
that she tries to remember and then when
she feels like she's in a new position
she thinks she made a mistake wait this
sounds like Andrea in the London yeah I
know exactly honestly me and kitty in
the Stonewall I feel that but that's
that goes to show that for players of
all strength that does happen absolutely
even at the highest levels people think
that I don't remember what this position
looks like I haven't seen it before and
look at this virtual has made a mistake
Pawn takes right Pawn takes D4 there are
so many pieces for black aiming there
she developed first she's moving a
little bit too quickly I guess both
players yeah you're nervous playing over
the board that's not a bad move we
should stress that right that was just a
developing move she wants to Castle her
King but she could have won a pawn in
the center it's interesting that 10
moves in she has lost five seconds on
the clock and virtual already down
almost two minutes which is pretty
insane like of a difference yeah they
seem to have to have strengths and
weakness in a virtual 10
to time pressure whereas cutie moves a
little too fast which can cause her to
blunder sometimes but at least it'll be
fun since you know we'll we'll see them
going wrong either way yeah you brought
up a good point Andrea that like there's
no other distractions which I'm curious
how to affect cutie because like I I've
played chess against her a lot I've
watched her play chess a lot and I yell
at my screen like I'm I watch her like I
watch the New England Patriots and she
moves so fast because she gets so bored
is what she says which it looks like
she's still she doesn't know how to
which piece to touch the castle that is
amazing she's always the king first yeah
I know he's really a nice guy he was
helping her castle her gang yeah yeah
this is uh something Conor told me that
he dealt with he played very young a uh
chess tournament over the board he
touched the Rook first and then he went
to Castle and they forfeited him and he
was like there's no slack they'd make
you move the Rook yeah for people at
home we are not going super sweaty so
there was an opportunity to do what's it
called touch touches touch it was that
what you call it you all got goofy terms
touch move which means if you touch the
piece you must move the piece we are not
doing that here we're playing like uh
play against your uncle rules which is
like a piece so
Monday night
no
no she moved too quickly again yeah
that was a I guess just a lack of vision
right because that's like
a blunder she would not normally make no
that this is you know two people have
made it through the finals if you're
blundering a piece just because you
didn't see a rook you would not make it
this far I think this is over the board
Gap yep I would agree with that
and I think it is stems from the fact
that she knew that that pawn on E5 was
loose and those are okay okay that was
there's a little technology Gap yeah
there's a little technology yeah that
was scary though but I I was trying to
explain her mistake that I think you
know she learned that the pawns need to
stay connected for white and once they
were no longer connected that pawn is
weak but that doesn't mean it was loose
so that's why she took the pawn ended up
causing her Knight and I guess you know
we've seen a lot of Pop Champs is this
game over especially over the board and
virtual down two minutes on the clock
certainly not exactly what I wanted to
add cutie is down material but now
virtual has to confront the problem of
his pieces are kind of awkwardly
developed for him to take his night he
has to go to the center and he's not
pushing his pieces yet so his Rook on
a1s cornered his Knight isn't developed
yet and his Rook on E5 is very random in
the center where if he's not careful it
could get trapped so if anything this is
actually a very tricky position for
beginner chess I want to see cutie try
something like Bishop D6 and then Queen
H4 and try to check made him see what
happens
oh you want some killer Vision oh she's
sacking her Bishop in hopes that she can
capture his Rook
which I I guess is better yeah that
would definitely be a good trade for her
but the issue is that Rook which is
under attack can take the Knight first
so you're gonna give up The Rook no
matter what so you give it take a knight
and then take the bishop next you start
getting too many pieces for The Rook I
don't think that Richard will play that
I think he was more likely to move his
work backwards he is up a night for just
the pawn after all but that is an
opportunity for him that's why the
question mark is on that queen move now
we can really see how strong work tools
over the board because what I would do
here in an in-person tournament is you
know one of the props of having it here
in front of you you can recognize when
you're in a tricky moment and you
calculate everything it's much easier to
calculate with in real life pieces let's
see if he's doing it uh wow even better
wow he protects yeah even stronger
keeping the pressure now Alex's plan of
um clean and Bishop battery attacking on
H2 definitely won't happen and the
concern here is that now Cutie's Bishop
is attacked but there's also Discovery
attack of Rook capturing the night and
then attacking the queen at the same
time
too much is hanging yeah too much
virtual he was a recipient of a blunder
Shore but it's how you follow up and
he's following up with Precision yeah I
I feel like she was in an amazing spot
for the first 10 11 moves because it was
clear that virtual was like a bit
nervous uh uh I think in terms of like
how he was playing and how he was moving
but like I feel like if he gets the one
thing he needs which is like a mistake
from a player he develops a lot of
confidence uh and he just starts
steamrolling
Pawn but that was the whole difference
in the two opponents who took their time
what do you do here he found the best
move it's a beautiful tactic
sadly she just has to move her Queen
away and then her Bishop is hanging but
at least he won't be able to take the
bishop right away because she's also
attacking The Rook
right The Rook protects the bishop the
bishop was attacking the queen
no no he can't take the bishop because
it attacks the queen and
I think that might give her one
opportunity though if this bishop is
captured the queen can jump into the
white position that Rook is trapped in
the corner White's pieces are kind of
scattered so that does give her an
opportunity to venture into enemy
territory and you know virtual now down
about five and a half minutes he's
actually just capturing it quickly I
would love to see Queen B2 but another
thing that happens all the time in IRL
chess as soon as you make a couple
blunders you get down on yourself and
instead of looking for counter attacks
similar to how cutie played very fast
you just want to play quickly because
you feel like the game is over but Queen
B2 would have been a very cool try to
see let me tell you cutie gets depressed
yeah oh it's tough uh and she never
quits which I think is good but it's
funny because like if you're a bad
player
and you have played chess before you
know as a fact if you are down a rook or
down excuse me upper Rook or up a bishop
like you've captured it you forked or
whatever you've lost games like that
like you you've lost games with huge
leads yep but you never think about that
when you are in that same deficit how
you could make an equivalent comeback
absolutely that
soon as you're in a losing position and
there'd be so many so many potential
comebacks in the game and that's
something that really anyone trying to
learn chess should always try to be
hyper aware about yeah I think you start
believing that your opponent is better
than you and then you don't expect
mistakes from them but hey you should
expect the same mistakes that you're
making from your opponent I mean you
should really just try to find the Right
Moves of course but you should never
just trust your opponent you need to
find out what the mistakes of their
plans are and right now cutie is down
three minor pieces on a knight and two
Bishops for just a couple pawns that's
not good no she's
she
you know sure but my my bigger worry is
even if cutie loses this game I just
hope that it doesn't affect her
mentality going into the second game
um I think even going into the match
cutie was not super confident in her
abilities and because of that she's also
playing so quickly
yeah she's always played fast uh uh I
think that's like a hard habit to break
to like slow it down intentionally when
I had a kids that I would teach chess I
would make them sit on their hands for
10 seconds before they could make a move
just to what are you like a Russian
coach almost yes
it's a you know good advice for
youngsters but hard to convince an adult
to do that yeah
it would be hilarious you could just
count to 10 in your head first
take a second if it's a couple days of
first for Cutie yesterday she was doing
stand-up comedy today she's playing an
OTB chess match for quite a significant
prize fun it's of course natural to be
nervous and I just feel like virtual
seems really calm
yeah I mean I think he knows he's the
favorite he has done all the prep he can
so it's like you know you kind of just
got to show up to the test and do your
best job uh and that's all you really
can do yeah one thing I actually want to
recognize that I really liked in Virtual
is like even today he was trying to get
chess lessons yesterday he was training
with you know Belen Kaya and even though
he knows he is much higher rated and
he's a favorite one thing that higher
rated opponents often do is they kind of
you know have a big ego big self of
confidence and they don't take the much
seriously and they don't prepare because
they're going against someone weaker but
virtual never stopped preparing for this
took it very seriously and I very much
respect that he has been grinding for
the last month right just straight and
he's gobbling up pawns now and cutie you
know she as you were saying literally
she's played for years she had lessons
with Levy she's learned her openings
that way but then I think she's been
playing a bunch but not studying as much
and virtual study has paid off in the
last month his rating has gone I think
over 1100 now
Wow have you guys heard the never resign
rule until you're a certain rating yeah
what rating is is the is the one
you should never resign until the logic
behind it being you are too low over
rating to properly assess the board I
can give you one answer it's any rating
that's not in pogchamps I think everyone
in pogchamps just never resigned I have
full faith that any stalemate can happen
yeah that was one of the big issues with
daily dose yeah he was actually the only
one who resigned I think yeah literally
the only part and it was a completely
like equal game Robert you made a face
what like you ate an onion no I'm
impressed that's impressive the tears
are just look at that move because the
forced Queen trade yeah because when
you're ahead you're taught to trade he's
threatening Checkmate in one this Pawn
on G7 is threatened by both the queen
and the Rook the queen trade is offered
and if you have to step back that puts
you in a very weak position you're just
playing defensive chess so Queen D7 was
quite a high level move from virtual
he's well ahead but that's good
execution
and she does end up taking it now
there's a there are dreams of back rank
still I think he'll probably squash them
I don't think they exist currently
uh but but that would be all I'm hoping
for this is like I'm opening up a page
in Bobby Fischer's how to play chess
book oh she is offering trades
well maybe she's going for the attempt
to stalemate strategy that would be the
other possibility to get a draw if she
trades off enough pieces and pushes the
pawn so that they can't move anywhere
else
all right you're in a tournament you're
in a game that's like is and you
got to play this person again
when you are playing this game are you
thinking of the next game
you shouldn't be but I mean at this
point when she's down so much okay she
probably knows she's gonna lose but I do
think it's helpful to get your mindset
back so playing lost position sometimes
helpful rather than starting the next
game right away where the you know Taste
of defeat is so fresh
yeah often my tournaments I would go
even if you have like five minutes
before your next game go outside or get
a breath of fresh air I think what's
going to be most important for Cutie is
that she gives herself a little mental
reset before the next match you know
maybe a lot of it could go squeeze in a
pep talk or something I think that would
be critical because once again she had a
great opening position she she was
following her intuition following what
she and Robert went over and then just
played a little too quickly
well I'll keep it a bug I don't think I
would help her like I don't think I'd be
able to
yeah
I guess my pep talks from star never
recap on what I did wrong and then say
well good luck I tried to pep talk well
I don't like being in the middle
you're excited he called it a Robert
sandwich yeah on the boat says brother
the boat yeah along with him too true in
the dance yeah yeah
yeah I kind of feel like the bonus Jonas
right now
y'all three got a thing
well I love that cutie is trying to
attack here regardless I could see a
world where maybe virtual moves his
Bishop so far back that they don't
defend against the back rank anymore
which wouldn't matter because H3 right
you have to have imagination sure like
maybe G4 G3 is also going so you're both
pointing out that the King has this H2
Escape here so if you can get a pawn all
the way up it could stop the king from
getting out but that seems like a pipe
dream and like you ask the question
about rebounding hey you rebounded from
A Loss to Andrea Northern lion right
amen amen hey what happened that
tournament what happened that tournament
I don't remember I think uh you know
Champion chess players couple champ
that's why I'm on the couch yeah
Champions uh
uh no no no
what happened we had a games an
accidental game stoppage it has been
fixed and resolved
now is when cutie should pull out the
Mind Games and start threading his mom
and whispering things
oh yeah are they allowed to Trash Talk
certainly yeah
where you're supposed to be silent yeah
you're not allowed you know would you
like eating classical chess forfeited
first probably yeah but it's a dead
silent room for many hours so it is very
quiet in the chess tournaments no one's
speaking I'm I'm at a chess ornament
it's it's Fabiano caruano across from me
yeah I'm like uh
and then I'd be like I'd be like I want
to tell them no we're just bantering
what does Bobby do to you Bobby all the
players you could have came for you
picked the nicest one yeah
but yeah chess players are too shy to
even make eye contact actually you're
right let me pick the meanest one who do
you think that is
you guys know the Chess World let's go
through it I think we all had a name pop
up and we all chose not to say it I
think a knee should handle it the best
so you're scary he's also a fan of
Ludwig so I do like Anish giri
uh
well I think Cutie's mentality going
into this game
was uh she actually set into the car
was uh I want to go in expecting to lose
I I think that's the problem though I
understand like look I'm the same person
I'd like to not set any expectations and
just expect disappointment because then
you won't get disappointment but in a
competitive game I feel like that's a
huge drawback what mentality did you
have Hess in your and your Champions and
champions and championships you mean the
one that we secured together yeah
um no I you can't go and think you're
gonna lose but I also think it depends
on how competitive you are because some
people they just want to crush their
opponent others they're striving to find
the optimal choice at every turn so it
really depends on like your mindset and
what the tournament is about because if
you're playing in a tournament where
Magnus Carlson and Fabiano hikara and
all them are playing you're likely not
going to win but you get the opportunity
to face off against them and you can't
beat these players in individual games
we see them loose sometimes but uh yeah
if you're really super competitive I
think you can feel like yeah this I mean
this is not good for her either but it
can really hurt to lose every game yeah
I mean I just want to Echo by you giving
your opponent more credit than you're
giving yourself on move like I don't
know 10 or 15. virtual dropped a free
Pawn in the position like someone who of
that rating wouldn't blunder so soon but
because you're giving them so much
credit you're not expecting them to make
any mistakes early in the game and I
really wish like that mindset is so
important
so if you want to win you can't give
that level of respect absolutely you
can't be that down on yourself you have
to focus on your best game any game
where you're an underdog you just focus
completely on your play and don't think
about your opponent
respect them but just don't
don't think they're infallible
yeah I I heard once it's good to be
nervous because you care but not nervous
because you're scared and I think that
for Cutie she came in quite fearful bars
hey thanks man
but I do think she came in scared of
virtual thinking that he was kind of
this player who would just Crush her but
she did have an opportunity so if she
were to review the game she would see I
could have actually won a pawn he made a
mistake and then you slowly realize well
my opponent's not Invincible they do go
wrong from time to time good question
though because that is a thing on the
online games it happens almost every POG
Champs the moment it ends everybody goes
to the analysis board and they say oh I
had a winning spot here I blundered this
many times I had this many missed wins
that doesn't exist here
there is no analysis board right yeah
but yeah usually you write it down with
notation and then go review it after in
a skittles room is what they call it is
this real yeah yeah I always wonder why
there's no Skittles in that room by the
way but that's just what they call it
they call it a skittles room yes this
sounds like something that should be
illegal and children would go to this
room yeah right that's okay all right
great that's good for the truss world
for sure uh and then you go with what
like a coach who tells you or your
opponent yeah sometimes you get the
sense of camaraderie and your opponent's
like hey you want to go analyze in the
Skittles room and maybe
you see what happened yeah
he almost blundered his Bishop but it's
because the pawn was like in between two
squares okay yeah who's gonna play his
Bishops for the fans and clearly no
touch move because that was a grab the
bishop that would have been illegal but
we're doing we're doing Street rules as
they say well cutie only has to lose
another two pawns before she can attempt
to stalemate seems like she's going for
that as well
there we go although he does not have to
take uh well I guess it doesn't matter
if he takes it right yeah it's already
it's already he's going straight for the
queen yes the little square was to be
taken from the King and Cutie's King
stayed in the corner Square she's going
there but if if virtual knows what he's
doing he'll just know he has a Checkmate
in one here yeah
done how do they know
oh he says it wow that was fun
feels so different over the board
how hard do you think we are playing
we're very nice I think we're very nice
and respectful
what do they think what do they think
we're flaming them we wouldn't do that
we walked in when you were just going
down that is true I was mean or hit to
him before the match started uh
what break now or they go straight into
it I believe they have a little break a
little break between the matches uh
we'll be right back with game two game
one goes to Virtual Checkmate in 42
moves we'll see what happens game two
though cutie might bounce back see in a
bit
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
normal
let's go
[Music]
hello hello we are back here at
pogchamps five the finals day of POG
Champs five we watched the first match
of the constellation bracket between
cutie Cinderella and virtual and it was
always a virtual 1-0 it was a virtual
win but there were some opportunities
early on uh virtual made some mistakes
cutie did not capitalize on so she has a
chance game too and we'll actually hear
from her cutie herself uh how she thinks
she'll do with a short little interview
and then we'll go to the match
Oh I thought you meant like hold my face
they said hold and I was like
for a second I was like I can hold on
this for a while uh we'll get that video
guys for you guys in just a second I see
both virtual and Q to getting makeup
done it's actually a team of 17 on
virtual's hair right now it is a lot
apparently they have to spray paint in
the crown he is balding there uh so I
just
got it
his mother must be dancing right now in
their house up 1-0 poised to take this
down and now he gets to play against the
stone wall yeah which he has done so
much prep for he's playing against the
Stonewall is he not well
he did promise that she wouldn't play
The Stonewall does cutie because cutie
plays it with white and black no no she
plays the Carl con with black in the
Stonewall with white yeah oh okay okay
uh and and uh we'll we'll talk about
that in just a bit but first let's watch
that cutie interview
[Music]
that there's gas leaking and it might
explode at any moment uh it's not good
it's not fun but you can't look away I'm
800.
who knows really this is my third POG
Champs
uh they keep inviting me back because I
I show up on time I think which is big I
did much worse against Leslie than I
thought I would I stalemate it a lot I
paid Papa Platt and he beat me
I think that's all I played but I also
feel like I forgot someone which could
be mean I played I did a thing
that's funny I forgot about him so
that's how I got into losers and then I
play Jason daily dose it was a good game
but I didn't stalemate so that was a
bonus here we go
I have coffee that day fun yeah there's
so many ways embarrassing no one tell my
dad oh my dad is gonna watch
[Music]
or we've got game one of the books
come on ironic dab
her photo was Ludwig I was so sick he's
not gonna take it he'll see that I also
kept showering and then just playing
right now I think he's gonna take it or
maybe he'll take F1 first he's gonna
take he's gonna take something for sure
oh I took my why are they freaking out
and they're freaking out oh that's when
they did it oh yeah I want to be right
man I don't want to be right okay she
doesn't see that the queen is hanging
she doesn't see that the queen is
hanging look oh that's I don't have time
to get down there with the queen oh it's
so sad take the queen you dummy I don't
take it I lose this game
no it's daily does I win eventually dude
but he didn't see the queen he's losing
can we take screen we're both bad oh my
God uh it's good when you're both dead
she looks like she's about to take the
pawn yeah okay she does also it's also
pretty good she's getting it
better get checked yeah now Queen H7 is
made by accident
seven is mate by our age
seven Queen H7 is just I didn't go there
Queen G3
that would have been cool if I went
there
dude I can't find checks for the life uh
uh uh he lost it's over he resigned oh
he ran out of time wow yeah I can't find
checks
bro what
yeah I'm screwed
this will be fun
she's not screwed right to Hess no she's
got a chance right she watch the video
there and she was like not remembering
any of the things that happened in her
previous games but I think she's just
hard on herself what are they talking
about
when she was winning she kept thinking
that she didn't see the Checkmate and
she's like oh I did see it there was
something I spent like 40 moves like why
is he so slow yeah dude
up here
it is we were talking about it during
the break much more serious this POG
Champs because normally they talk to
chat right after and they start playing
like you know Taylor Swift and they're
jamming out but now it's like it's quiet
yeah we need a little bit more Trash
Talk have you played over the board in a
tournament yet never I have never once
played I played over the board last
night against Sea Dog who won talk about
that later ask me later because it was
not close
oh
my plan this is drama she
EP a bunch across the fingers well I've
got so I've got baby
well now we'll see how good his prep
really is
all right this is cutie
the original POG Champs she was trained
by Levy Gotham chess she said give me an
opening I can do the same way every time
without thinking she learned the stone
wall she's done it ever since according
to her words the stonewalls at dog
opening unless you are playing people
who are less than a thousand rating I
don't know if that's true is that right
well I don't think you're even supposed
to play The Stonewall with white which
is why I was confused initially so I
think it's not even an opening yeah
well at least for most different players
so the Stonewall is a structure and it
involves white pushing this Pawn up to
F4 so you can get this bind and let's
see if she does it no she trades Bishops
first so she's actually developing but
the point of the Stonewall is that once
you get this Pawn here you completely
clamp down on the center and with the
center unable to be opened up that means
the blacks pieces get restricted so this
is actually a more open position we have
seen some trades and okay here comes the
trash talk what'd she say
[Laughter]
a little itchy your skin
just keep asking him questions
[Laughter]
I don't know this Open Mic Dynamic might
change the whole game yeah I know if
she's allowed to talk I think that might
the clocks stick in she's already up a
minute
she is a brutal trash talker she told me
the story she was uh
she could because she's driving she's
driving and she got into a road rage
incident oh God we're a guy behind her
started like honking at her to like turn
right at a red light and but there's
people crossing the street so she's like
I can't you know turn right at the time
they both turn right he pulls up next to
her she starts yelling at the window
learn how to drive and then she
instantly rolled out the window and with
full League of Legends you know
confidence goes literally kill
and then and then he goes in front of
her and then like slows down to like you
know uh like break in front of her and
then pulls next to her again and and
then just keeps saying learn how to
drive and then she just doubles out she
goes I I hope there's an accident I hope
there's an accident and then she speeds
away and she did that without any
hesitation at all to an LA driver uh
which is a scary situation to be willing
to die to take on the argument La
drivers are scary a cutie is a very
terrifying opponent especially when she
begins trash talking but I feel like
she's still taking it easy on Virtual
she's not going off on him as if he was
a driver in the road rage and look it's
hard to Trash Talk virtual he's a very
nice guy
it's so annoying he said something about
when I was asking about Trek Mania he
says he does like bobsledding or
something so I call him Cool Runnings
and that's my new nickname for him but
he's just a really chilled guy like he
just sits there he's calculating he
wants to make Norway proud of her they
care about Chess there I don't think
it's that big
95 I like this
Cutie's putting her Knight in the middle
of the board if he takes
um she could take with the F Pawn and
open up the f file
put some pressure towards this this is a
beautiful position for Cutie and one
thing I wanted to say about Kitty's
opening is what I've actually noticed as
a trend in POG Champs is people not
playing real openings sometimes gets
their best chess because like what
Robert was mentioning earlier you're
less just being a robot and just
memorizing moves and similar to what I
saw Tyler playing the cow he had a
beautiful opening cutie playing this
reverse Stonewall for the white pieces
which is supposed to be for the black
she's just following her intuition out
playing natural moves like the pawn
break in the center this is great
yeah she's doing very well her King is
casually the tiebreaker game yeah The
Rook is staring down and that's one of
the benefits of playing the stone wall
is you push your Pawn up where your Rook
ends up when you Castle so you gain more
space for the rook and virtual says my
King's been the center too long let's
get out of danger and I think he has a
good sense of that like some players
they don't recognize when they could be
in trouble virtual of all the games
we've seen from him in pogtense
particularly the constellation bracket I
do think that he's done quite well to
avoid some serious Danger
I'm curious who's going to break the
silence first now that they're entering
10 serious lands again yeah the opening
was full of bands and then mid game
quiet yeah and virtual actually he was
speaking to me earlier breakfast and
he's been working on keeping the tension
in chest it's an important concept and
these pawns are staring at each other
and saying look at that move by cutie
she's going right for the kill her oh my
god did she growl at him
look at that smirk she's getting her
clothes give it away yeah true Poker
Face
what like in chess if you make a like a
like a little smirk maybe they know
there's a tactic or something or if you
blunder and react sometimes they don't
see the blunder I've had that happen to
me many times I had a pro tell me once
everything you do on a chessboard
conveys information you can't be all
loosey-goosey eating a sandwich
thank you I got you and oh
virtual you know he saved the pawn but
his King is going to be exposed so it's
a good Moment For Cutie to slow down
she's not talking I think she senses
that she has a good position
I like that she's taking her time she
played very quick moves the last couple
moves but they were luckily good moves
but now is the time to think and this is
different from her first game she's
slowing herself down in the opening
she's got a minute on him and I know
Ludwig you say cutie gets bored easily
but maybe when it gets into the middle
game it's already getting more
interesting so it'll help her slow down
yeah she brought a notebook with her and
generally you're only allowed to write
chest notation I think if you're in a
sweaty chess tournament uh and players
have been punished you were telling me
for for writing other stuff to get
forfeited yep uh but cutie has a
notebook purely to write like notes to
herself like hey remember to do it for
checks yeah believe in yourself I
actually played an opponent in Iceland
this year she was a 11 year old girl and
on her hand it had written you can do it
smiley face thank you yeah did you beat
her I did
but it was very cute Alex what the man
come on you you come off as a nice
person you're a bully
yeah seriously welcome welcome I
remember one time when I was like eight
I was doodling on my notation notebook
and my opponent called The Arbiter and
tattled I mean was like she's not
allowed to Doodle during the games it
can only be chess
why did the eval bar drop 10 pounds it's
a good question and it's because she's
so used to attacking by bringing her
Queen to the age file because in her
stone wall before the bishops get traded
there's often a bishop on the diagonal
that she likes to work with the queen we
actually saw a clip of her beating Ginny
with the Checkmate on the diagonal so I
think she's like recalling that idea but
the queen on 8th Street doesn't threaten
anything in fact the queen on F3 it was
barreling down this open line with the
Rook behind it that was very powerful so
the queen on H3 it does seem to thread
things but there's nothing concrete
just a worse position basically you used
a move to not improve and there's a lot
of Pawn tension in the center so for
virtual it's about time he can take this
Pawn on E5 he did just push his Pawn up
to F6 so he can grab the pawn the center
and that's going to turn the tides
because it's attacked twice and only
defended wines
attack three times well wait what
there's a bishop a knight in a pawn yeah
that Bishop's also a big sniper once
that diagonal is open
but let's see if he's gonna take the
pawn hey cutie looks almost angry as
she's looking down it's interesting
calculator
look I stopped myself okay and he makes
the move
and cutie quickly responded she took a
pawn and she took it back but that's
going to open up the board for Black's
pieces so the stone wall you're trying
to restrain your opponent's pieces now
you see that once that pawn on E5
collapses and I think the Knight should
take it all of Black's pieces including
the sniper as Andrea put on G7 the
bishop has long range I think that black
speed is about to get very active and
we're just gonna steal material
okay that's actually a more sneaky way
to take because now he's not attacking
her Rook right away but he does have
discovery check yes two pieces at once
right now rather than just one
and that response not loved by the
engine this Rook on C8 can likely just
slam down on C2 at any moment and black
is getting active here this queen on H3
is not helping out in the attack or in
the defense it is a misplaced piece
virtual under six minutes now so he's
still healthy on the clock
he got a big ass watch
and a ring
what kind of watch is that do we know I
don't I'm not a watch guy no me neither
anything else on the subject or that's
all I got so quiet the time was wrong
though oh my gosh
yeah what's very impressive is in these
critical positions Rachel is always
taking his time and I mean that's the
reason he's finding some of the best
moves yeah and here the move is tricky
cutie has to take the Knight on E5 first
and then when he recaptures both her
Knight and Rook are going to be under
attack so she's going to need to move
the Rook to D1 to defend the Knight oh
step one there you go and as you said
Rook D1 the good news for Cutie is her
King does feel a bit safer than blacks
like they're not a shell around the
black king The Fortress there so it
feels like if she oh she played so
quickly yep and she didn't see that the
other she saw the night was under attack
she did not see the rook in the corner
was threatened I'm shocked virtual
hasn't snap made this decision is he
worried about an attack
I think so and that's the thing he's an
improving player he is over 1100.
sometimes you learn these big Concepts
like okay does this apply to the
position but no he says I can grab it he
safely does he is up it's going to be a
pawn and a rook for just a night
she can't capture back right with her
Rook
she has to capture back with her Rook
here just to win some material back
right
and she said she forgot about that she
wasn't looking at the look in the corner
the sniper came in
drama talk to me about Chess Grime now
over the board there's some things you
can do right is that just what Grime
what is that sleaziness cheating perhaps
numer terms scamming earlier they taught
me what soaking was in ouch
that is not a Zoomer term I didn't know
what that meant Ludwig's taught me a lot
of words
let's get back to the question at hand
here is it common I mean not in
tournament obviously but in Street
chests to cheat over the board I've seen
the chest Hustlers do it when they think
people aren't paying attention they'll
move to a slightly different square or
take a piece off the side but not
usually it's very rare it feels hard to
get away with yeah it's more like Bad
Manners during a chess tournament like
eating an entire dinner meal at your
board and burping in your opponent's
face those are like the slights
wait so someone burps in your face yeah
there were some some birds the men in
the Portland chess club and I'll never
forget that one who loved Diet Coke
the reason I have Diet Coke sorry go
ahead there's a player in the smash
Community who similarly was theorized to
never shower very cool of you yeah
that's that's a good way to play mind
games on your opponent that it would
just distract maybe cutie shouldn't have
showered uh yeah I'll tell him for next
time
oh now she's explaining Her Moves
count as her chat like is that what's
Happening Here I I don't know what there
is a comfort to
talking out loud while you play chess
exactly yep for sure
some I honestly think sometimes I play
better interesting
it's actually a very clever move he
could have recaptured this Pawn instead
he pushed his Pawn up he wants to push
it one square further there is a pin
along the third rank that's actually
quite a high level play
that's why he played it I think it is I
would be very impressed so she's got to
move her Queen
oh she saw it nice
yeah I wish I could draw the arrows
Clinic you would go here laughs the
arrows do help I'll be like oh crap do
you ever use them to calculate all the
time both looking at the same plan so
yeah well I don't like it could you
change it I thought about that do you
have an alternative uh not one that's
better for you because this looks really
good for me it looks really good for you
yeah it's that blunder that I shared
about um it was unfortunate that I did
that
[Music]
um
okay technically I'm only down by how
much material Judy would make a great
poker player on chess.com it shows you
how many points of material you're down
right now she's doing math so I guess
it's something you have to calculate
yeah sir the things we take for granted
anyone ever call you sire
she should distract him on his time yeah
she's distracting herself yes
she's distracting herself from the Doom
that she has to deal with
I kind of need a check but I don't even
check you because you got that stupid
thing
everything you have is stupid
I'd like you to know I don't like it
um and I hope your mom is watching
and I'm doing annoying things then I'm
doing good Anna he's being annoying okay
so is Hannah his mother's name Anna
Kremlin she's doing a watch party she
coached virtually no one else would ever
think of and there's probably a thing
but
I hope they're watching him in the uh
Chestnut bar in Oslo
that'd be sick yeah they have a very
epic bar where they play chess and watch
events she's sorry go ahead I said he
would be the only like Champion World
podcast in Norway yeah so there is a
real shot that he's the best Norwegian
player to do it perhaps out of you know
there's John Ludwig
John Hammer you know that uh virtual's
middle name is it yeah he told us it
yesterday well he didn't tell me this
yeah but you weren't here don't take it
I know but like we've talked him many
times I was being honest with you maybe
you know didn't want to be it'd be a
competition who's the better Ludwig
that's what I would make at that time
why not what's the best movie you're
here because I'm thinking you just go
Queen H6
well she she moved to Queen into the H6
to H4 I like Queen chicks better because
you could have been followed with Knight
G5 here I would recommend trading while
you're ahead and black has a lot of
extra material you see the bar saying -5
he can keep the Queens on the board and
try to win that way but why not trade
queens and win the ensuing ending
makes a whole lot of sense I like that
cutie stopped talking on his turn the
one Strat it's a good disrespectful I
know she really is she is yeah I don't
think she wants to be rude
well then why she keep asking about his
mother
genuine interest you know
oh the clock is getting a little bit low
under four minutes for each do we know
what virtual's Blitz rating is is it
lower than it's rapid certainly
girl's night
thank you you should take girls night
because they traded Queens yeah girls
night that's awesome
not that far down
there's got to be something
that I'm not seeing
I don't think there is some she's not
seeing no I mean she could try to go for
Forks like reroute her night to F3 G5 E4
F6 but it's just very slow
see you later cutie would make a good
Barbie did that run through anyone
else's like you know Margot Robbie
playing Barbie not like a doll right but
that that's what was running through my
head okay aggressive we did we did uh we
did dress up as Barbie and Ken for
Halloween last year that's true we kind
of beat the trend out because it
predicted that yeah our personality very
much reminds me yeah
again
oh you know I did get that during makeup
today okay
you describe yourself with more of a can
or an Oppenheimer uh more of an Allen
an Allen
okay you haven't seen Barbie
Allen was the one doll who was in a Ken
he he was played by Michael Sarah yeah
then he was a hero yeah he was great
okay the pass Pawn is coming this is she
no that's a Wonder um
well because if I tell you anything else
I think virtual sees this
[Laughter]
swim in an Oscar I hate jazz
what is a Checkers tournament
game I think Cutie's most consistent
quote since Paul Champs won
don't tell your friends about this oh
gosh her dad is watching
okay yeah
interesting it's like another game where
super tight position and then it
collapsed off like the one queen move
and then the center just got destroyed
oh an accuracy I think if she would have
uh played Rook D1 earlier to protect her
Knight she would have still had a pretty
good Fighting Chance because then as
soon as you start being down material
it's easy to spiral right
especially when you missed that like it
wasn't at all intentional she just
didn't see that it was under attack she
started doubting yourself and she put a
good game Virtual as we started off the
show he's a stronger player he's mopping
up quite nicely oh she she resigned she
should have just chucked the king at her
and put it instead she resigned detailed
to the king
he's so upset she broke the pinky
promise oh she did tell me about the
pinky promise but she did cross her
fingers so you know you're allowed to
break it if you cross the fingers that
is a rule
uh and that's 2-0 virtual over QD one
more game and it's over
none of our predictions were right well
there was a 3-1 prediction that could
come true it depends if cutie wins the
next one high break could still happen
that's true fabric Could Happen playing
three it's the best of four ah four ah
yes there's still a chance there's still
a chance uh but
I was gonna say now that cutie has
started using the open mic strategy I
might even change my prediction I like
the energy that she's bringing to these
games right so you're changing your
prediction when we know it's 2-0 well
our prediction is a kid we get a draw no
I'll stick to my prediction I'm just
saying I think Cutie's open my strategy
is gonna it's gonna get better and
better for her
uh it's you're the you're the botes
brother yeah
[Music]
why are you all the brothers
I made this song actually a year ago
before we had a brother so I have put a
lot of thought into it there you go yeah
and now you have a brother yep uh and we
have a break coming up just a few
minutes we'll be right back after the
break to see perhaps the conclusion of
the consolation finals of virtual window
back she's growling she feels herself
oh Rook D1 man would have been nice
be back in just a bit
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we are here joined by the
botez brothers with a new addition we
have more family let's go brother's
going strong I'm good are you happy to
be a bota's brother absolutely not I'm
also not happy that my my uh my student
my second Protege in the finals is
struggling against uh virtual but I feel
like if you're gonna lose to anybody in
this event you can lose the virtual
because I feel like I would lose the
virtual at this point so oh come on but
you almost did didn't you you almost
lost to me once no yes
yes I did we'll talk about that later
but first let's take a look into the
mind of the guy who's beating qd2o who's
one game away from being our consolation
bracket Champion let's take a look at an
interview with virtual
I would say I'm an aggressive chess
player if things are too slow if things
are too theoretical or boring I get
bored I want excitement I want things to
be like hanging I want sacrifices that's
why I don't play the London that's why I
go away from these boring openings I
want things to explode after time moves
so I came into the tournament High
Ambitions of doing really well want to
represent my test country of Norway and
myself forth as a good chess player in
this tournament as well the bracket was
really tough the tournament bracket the
group b played some very tough games
against ghastly and uh and sapnap and so
I got third in the group which okay you
know it's it's a little iffy but there's
also the consolation bracket and once I
got into the constellation bracket I was
like okay well I'm here now I'm perhaps
the highest rated player in this bracket
I want to go all the way I want to go to
La and I want to play
the final over the board and here I am
all right let's take a look
and it wasn't you're always going to
have two squares
yeah so this game is the when I play in
sapna where I pin this queen and then I
was very scared of blundering the uh the
stalemate he was trying to set it up but
I found this to activate It Started With
the Wind things were looking so up here
it was it was very exciting
oh and this is against saikuno oh yeah
when he blundered backrank yeah this was
a tough game Tycoon played so well I got
so surprised
until he uh missed a very obvious tactic
he's about to move that was very
relieved because then I felt like I am
getting to the semifinals after oh no
crazy I'm crazy
it's often in chess when uh when you're
not the best player you can be so
confident to move and then
if your opponent plays the correct move
after you just get completely shattered
hey
so that's that's what brought me
700 euros
spoke to I spoke to Levy up in the pool
today at the hotel and he was saying
like yeah you play way too confidently
sometimes
but again play the same opening that
I've been playing and
it's very good with the white pieces but
then I was losing with the black pieces
and then
in the constellation bracket I felt like
I lost the favorite to win and the
highest rated player
but now I don't know cuties uh has been
studying and she is much higher rated
than two opponents that gave me a big
challenge so
we'll see oh yeah just cool
I do not think it will be easy at all I
think we will have very competitive
games
oh and then this yeah this was something
we prepared I prepared uh three moves
against squeaks one of them was to do
pull-ups after the game to establish
dominance
a little bit of speed one arrivalry
there I think a big instrumental part
for why I even got to the finals is my
coach Anna kremling he even flew out to
Norway on a one day's notice she has
been going one step above every other
coach in the tournament and we're gonna
show why that matters
wow you heard it here anna Kremlin has
been going one step above every other
coach
I mean I'm a coach but you know we have
another coach right here on the couch we
do we do in us
but do you happen to coach
cutie that's not accurate no no no no no
um I'm like uh you know I'm like a this
is like blaming Frank Vogel uh for the
current Lakers troubles you know he's
not the coach so Frank's coach actually
so you're true coach of the day yeah you
know you know cutie Cutie and I we
actually didn't communicate a whole lot
for this pod Champs um and then and then
you know Anna kramling found like the
youth champion of Norway who had retire
for five years basically that's like
what he is he's definitely like multiple
time Junior champion of Norway uh and uh
you know she now she looks you know
really smart but why are you changing
things she just she found a good student
she's not a good coach she's probably a
good coach but did he speak to Anna like
since their first game he just changed
his openings yeah I honestly honestly I
wouldn't even doubt it like I wouldn't
even doubt if if that happened
uh because she she got a great position
in the advanced Karo Khan courtesy of
myself and Robert you know yeah
we had to team up ourselves because he's
such a good coach yeah uh and uh maybe
they did change it though that's
impressive that he adapted so quickly I
don't think they had a break to talk to
any coach he just maybe did it on his
own adapt oh he's the like adapt would
mean that he got some sort of opening
Advantage but for now her position is
completely fine I was just sitting in
the green room with uh Danny wrench and
uh Danny said that if cutie just spent a
little bit more time between moves 10
and 20
she could gain like 400 ELO yeah because
she gets great positions from openings
and she's up on time but she plays too
fast like right now this position is
excellent for black you see the
evaluation bar upside white is slightly
better but the Contours are there this
is a light Square Bishop that only white
has but that Bishop is staring into a
wall of Black's Pond it doesn't have a
good diagonal but she's probably gonna
start speeding up she's trying to use
the time as a weapon and there's not a
familiar position to her you know what's
funny she just said uh Hess is probably
so mad at me I'm not doing anything he
said and you are the opposite you are
fine with her position
but she is under the impression that
somehow she's messed up this opening
Fantasy 3 is a ridiculous move from
virtual like the the fact that I I do
not believe for a second he did not play
chess in his childhood because you in
the weeks that pogchamps happens to
create like a building block for a
Central Pawn advance I mean that's just
that's very very sophisticated stuff and
it's instant yeah instant instant he has
10 minutes and 12 seconds he shut down
the diagonal for her Bishop so her
Bishop probably should go back this way
to D6 that way it stares at least at a
night and she goes back to B6 or to E7
and turns the right way but if she went
to E7 you're staring into nothing so
this is the best response but I have to
be impressed by how virtual is playing
I'll be impressed in the next couple of
moves right like this is one of these
positions with white where you you don't
rush you you play things like Rook to E1
because even the move Bishop H uh Bishop
to G5 just runs into this and then if
you try to keep the pin you actually
lose the game which would be nice for a
cutie fan uh but uh rookie won and just
slow playing let's go Bishop G5
we got the audience there oh that was
that was Ludwig unbiased I'm an unbiased
commentator I'm also unbiased I want
virtual to lose I mean listen I feel
like Charles Barkley when he spent the
whole season being like we're really
going to pretend like the Golden State
Warriors not going to win the whole
thing and uh and right now I'm sort of
like just cheering for the Golden State
Warriors to lose this is what this feels
like because you don't want to pretend
anymore that virtual's just gonna Crush
it's higher rated than Sea Dog
he I think that would be an interesting
matchup can we do that like we're gonna
have a little time maybe we could do a
thug finals between consolation winner
and championship winner I like that we
also have boxing gloves somewhere in the
back here yo chess boxing two just 1.5
yeah 1.5 slap boxing because that's what
Conor has his pedigree in he is a slap
boxing champion yeah uh he did beat me
there that hurt
Knight to E4 yeah that's a
nice move in the center of the board
just trading at at this level Robert
it's really tough to introduce the
concepts to students of how do you
evaluate who wins an exchange
and this is one of those moments where
she's probably going to take because
it's a safe trade they're both kind of
winning you know what I mean like it's
but I think that's a good way of putting
it like sometimes we think that one of
us has to win a trade so what just
happened those nights were fighting for
the same square there was one night
already on F6 now her Knight on D7 which
is dominated by the pawn three squares
away it can't jump forward as far as it
would like it can replace that first in
F6 but this bishop can then slide back
on a more useful diagonal staring
towards black king so both sides I think
won the trade and it looks like she oh
went to F6 instead Andre I mean this
type of position is closed for now
from what you've seen the players like
who do you think it favors yeah yeah I
have a question for you earlier which
was from Cutie's perspective her pieces
were a little bit tied up before that
night was freed up and it's difficult
for black to find a plan to break
through like as a beginner are you
supposed to push a pawn in the center
I'm not sure maybe Cutie's plan is to
attack more towards the king but what
would you even recommend is the best
beginner plan here for the black pieces
I feel like I'm watching like a top
level game like both sides playing very
solidly no mistakes this is one of those
positions you get slightly better for
white yeah prove it and I don't actually
know how white is supposed to follow up
sometimes white stars it's Black's turn
but sometimes whites are pushing Pawns
in the center of the board and for black
I don't like my knight on D7 I would
prefer it's on F6 so at some point I
would like to free up some squares for
that night
what did she play oh that's a great move
oh whoa
fish is like the equivalent of a PhD
candidate showing up to a Kindergarten
class shouldn't this couch be the
equivalent of that we are listen
stockfish is we could live seven
lifetimes and combine our chest ability
and stockfish will still be better the
reason why this is a bad move is because
you don't want to open up the position
for the bishop pair however Pawn takes
Queen takes would have been a fork on
the bishop and a Checkmate uh but
virtual doesn't fall for that and
instead he goes for this but this is a
great move for this level for stockfish
who is a scumbag uh it thinks E5 is a
big mistake because you don't want to
open the position for the Bishops but at
this level E5 is a great move a grid and
I think that virtual's proving what he
said at breakfast he's like I've been
working on uh bettering tension in chess
and there's tension between these two
Pawns in the center a lot of beginners
players and podcasts would have taken
quickly on E5 but as Levy was noting the
queen getting to E5 would be very
dangerous for what to deal with and now
after C5 this bishop on e4 that was bad
I mentioned how the black pawns were
blunting it look at that that pawn
tanking yeah as is that one with check
so
the first move gave a advantage of plus
one but now cutie opened up everything
and she doesn't have a light squared
Bishop her last two moves were on dark
squares so now the light squared Bishop
is a killer that was a bad move so he
missed and he closes the position again
for his Bishops right so he's messed up
as well which means you know he's not a
Flawless player he also miss Bishop
takes Pawn check to the right hand
corner he does have a habit where if he
has an opportunity for his Pawn to take
other pawns he just goes straight
through because a lot of the time that's
a dope stoic move but yeah like this
you're saying is not a dope stoic move I
think he's cautious I think he's not a
reckless player he's someone who doesn't
want to take a big decision without
calculating it through so he's like
let's keep it closed can I ask you a
question can we pull the bar for a
second can I ask you a question because
you keep talking about how the all you
take over here and then it's a to take
with check why can't you just that's
what she should have done multiple times
what should have been played yeah so if
he does this why no excuse me afterwards
why could she not move her Pawn down to
block it he she would be in check oh she
has to respond but then then he needs to
get out yes he needs to get out and
she's missed it losing a pawn like that
guys like it's not the worst thing you
know it's a pawn but you could open up
that side of the board for a counter
attack right but
she's definitely going to lose the bun
uh yeah and he has taken
and uh
by the way of all the moments to not
think this is yeah she only has one
legal movement now he's got to get out
because a lot about your point if black
had a free turn then the pawn push would
trap the bishop in here so for virtual
he should bring his Bishop back F5 looks
like a great Square pinning and hitting
these Knight and Rook on the diagonal so
a sign of a player with a very very very
high ceiling would be Bishop F5 because
he's not just on autopilot returning to
the square he came from many people
would just go oh I want a pawn and I
don't want to get trapped so I'm just
going to return where I was if he adapts
and plays here seeing this pin uh yeah
he he will probably be if he does that
I'm setting up the thug finals him
versus the winner of sea dogs jump in
when he gets out of the room like just
that's off camera you know we're not
gonna I'm gonna appear there uh we said
it on broadcast his mom would know
We're not gonna do that we're not gonna
we're just We're not gonna jump your son
but I can't let I can't let that
Norwegian oil money hit me
I wonder what he's thinking about
maybe he's thinking about Bishop if I
might play Queen F5 no way
yes you're on the bishop yeah Bishop so
you gotta set up now we heard you ah
Thug finals it's it's happening
she's a little bit Rook d8 I guess oh is
he gonna go Queen E4 um how quickly
just understanding the Dynamics why is
she why are we saying wow wow well oh my
God that's a bad move that's a bad move
he's actually lost all his Advantage
with Bishop takes Knight he should have
rotated his Queen over a great spot okay
that was really nice because if she had
taken with a bishop The Rook was under
attack yeah and what Levy was pointing
out is that the Knight was hitting the
queen so actually I can just back this
thing up uh for a second or you can show
on this board the Queen should just be
over here yeah but with a bishop on E3
The Black Queen could never block now
even if this queen could teleport over
here the black queen can interpose I
know you love that word I do love saying
anthropos very sophisticated so the
queen can block a check on them and
she's kicking The Bishop's wrong yes I
wish he would have played that move like
seven moves ago but it's better late
than never you're the coach buddy I I'm
not the player though I am not the
player I'm just the coach hey they say
don't hate the player hit the coach who
who is the coach are we the coach am I
the coach you play chess with her every
day I mean your sparring partners okay
we do play not every day sometimes it's
serious she does not like playing chess
against me because you're a bad loser
because I win and then I do a fortnight
dance
I would also not like to play chess
again it's always a different dance and
it's always really well rehearsed okay
that that's get extra points for a
rehearsal you should teach him the bow
ties brother dance oh yeah yeah well
he's not one of the brothers there's a
finite amount of games you can play on
there a finite amount of fortnite dances
I don't win that much I see do you do
you could make variations we uh we
actually did play we played at like we
went for breakfast we played like two
matches three matches and I won two and
she won one and she won the last one but
she left morose
she was like I have no chance of beating
him I was like you word you won English
major English major yeah but streamer I
mean I I feel like you're the only
streamer that knows the word morose
she's on his own couch for a reason guys
just a really smart uh guy with a person
great big brain that is a that is a
great word Big Brand melancholy
are we just gonna say words that start
with M that are yeah that are long yeah
yeah I feel like we're watching like a
World Cup game right now yeah it's a
tough game Queens Rooks and Bishops
opposite color Josh Tendencies uh
Q did you say she didn't realize
something was protected I think she says
I think she said I don't know what I'm
doing
wait I just realized something yeah she
needs to win yes a draw is equivalent to
a loss I know maybe in her mind she just
wants to get some points on the board
but in terms of the match she needs to
win this game
uh that's a good start she blundered she
blundered yeah he blundered yeah yeah I
keep yes yes because the queen trade
allows Pawn up to F5 hitting the Rook
that replaces the queen and that Bishop
over there so if she treats my God which
is very tempting and it pushes the pawn
up there will be a fork at the end of
the line she could win a piece oh my
goodness this is her biggest advantage
in three games you all are talking about
that's a really hard move to see though
it it's not if you follow the philosophy
of finding forcing moves checks captures
attacks right now the you don't have any
checks with black you take the queen and
then you have F and she's going into the
position instead which is not bad but
she was winning so it is bad she still
has the threat on the position without
five so you might still miss it yeah if
he makes some kind of random move then
your F5 is coming and she is attacking a
pawn over here I think that virtual sees
that this Pawn might be under attack but
also the D5 Pawn so her move is has a
purpose it's quite reasonable it's a
good move but she missed a fork that
would have won her significant material
I find bee pawns to be like sirens in
the old Greek mythology stories
we were talking about Greek mythology
last night you're gonna keep that one
rolling I'm keeping that one rolling
yeah because they call to you and they
sing to you and they're so free and
available and then you do it and then
you just get screwed over most of the
time like it's a waste to capture a bee
Pawn
it's a beautiful metaphor thank you
Ludwig and in this case it's actually a
if you get that beep on you might get
the a pawn and the C Pawn I don't know
is there a Greek mythology uh metaphor
for that uh
robbing a bank
that would be yeah there's that famous
story I'll be looting a Gucci store in
California all right anyway uh current
events reference uh Queen to D2 on the
board yeah I have to say I actually kind
of like this more for Cutie because by
keeping the Queens on the board it's a
little bit trickier we know that virtual
strength is the end game I think as a
strong player he could come back down a
piece but now that there's three threats
on the board it's a little more tricky
keeping the Queens on
and that's what I thought he was going
to do I'm sure you anticipated the same
now does she see Queen takes Bond yeah
hope with the right Pawn because Queen
takes yes yes
the queen queen takes D5 of course is
what Levy was mentioning that just wins
a pawn in the center of the board black
is not worse here we see the evaluation
bar off to the side and she's going she
did not see it but still a completely
realized threats on the board yeah F5 is
still there one thing I like about
keeping everything on the board is that
she has been up on time in almost every
game yeah but it hasn't mattered because
the position was so simplified that
virtual can just move very quickly
it's a little more stressful when
everything's moving so strategy is very
good to keep his time on the clock he's
just non-stop attacking her this is the
best way to catch up on the clock and
the unfortunate thing here is look the
reality is that cutie has unless she's
just a really really good actress like
she I think she legitimately has no
belief that she can win and that is
absolutely not how you like she
absolutely has the ability to win and
she was saying it before the match she's
saying it like during so it's a weird
psychological thing where virtual feels
Invincible like he's just not at any
point expecting to be worse so if she
gets that move F5 on the board it's
gonna change everything because he's
going to get a serious wake-up call and
she's going to go oh wait a minute I
could actually beat this guy and then
she might do it and she might pull off
the comeback is F5 right now good so F5
would be a queen trade yeah after F5
white can take blacks Queen and then
after black takes the queen on e4 white
can just grab that pawn and white to
pawn ahead to begin with that's a great
move that is the best move yeah and I
what something that I'm I don't know if
I'm reading this correctly
she almost seems less dressed up now
that she's down two games like she's
like okay she has it now
high five
oh my goodness oh did you see virtual he
did that little head to the side oh I
did not see that guy you hear what she
said she said I've been trying to do
that for so long yep she's been under it
I like that she didn't tell her opponent
what she was thinking about this time
she's violating the rules by speaking to
Virtual on his journey yeah she's really
she you know she's uh she's pressing and
she's probably kicking him under the
table he's trying to keep it
face he's not happy he's not happy at
all and uh now a major moment here he's
gotta avoid a queen trade he might slide
back one square and then she has to make
sure to take the queen before taking the
bishop but he needs to keep the queen on
the board that's his best chance of
winning if he goes to an end game purely
down a bishop it's probably curtains but
you never know yeah because the white
king will also be under attack if you
keep the Queens on the board so he's
probably looking at this I'm gonna lose
a piece no matter what I think I would
yeah he took with Bishop he took his
Bishop which is really bad now she takes
look at that email take with Rook right
Pawn probably Baruch is probably also
fine
yeah there's just so many ways to attack
once you open that g file you have F4
coming you can bring the Rook to the
file it's going to be beautiful for
Cutie yeah yeah King on G2 just another
world of hurt
the problem is she's winning but her
Rook on the queen side standing on C5
and the bishop on D6 are not
participating whatsoever
so yeah they will be though right
because oh what
is it a slip yeah thank god oh oh okay
it was the most shocking move that could
have been played I think it will open up
right
we do have a live camera she did take
oh there it is there it is she took with
rook and it's updated it's updated yep I
think she stumbled along the way yeah
right so it just got caught on the
Square chess technology has not evolved
so it really hasn't it really hasn't
we'll get there we'll get there maybe I
think to your point this Rook needs to
get on over there right this roof needs
to be on the f file helping in the
attack on C5 it's just attacking a
protected pawn and defending a pawn
that's not really meaningful in the
position so I do think Rook sliding back
bring it over and also freeing up this
bishop at some point to join the party
yeah on C5 and she's gonna struggle
she's gonna try to use what's mobile
whereas yeah eight eight nine times out
of ten going backwards is the wrong
answer in chess but right now you need
to bring that Rook back rotate it to the
file so they team up and then bring in
the bishop to where the Rook is
currently standing I'm worried she's
gonna start with her A and B pawns yeah
and she did make a move and yeah
yeah Pawn to B5 but for virtual the
issue for him is not only is he down
material he doesn't have a clear plan
because he would like to attack cuties
you know reasonably exposed King but the
Rook on F5 it doesn't just attack it
defends so anytime you play H5 this Rook
can also help to capture it yes but he
is preparing Pawn to H5 right so this is
this is the idea and okay that's almost
winning for white because if this
there's this and if this you know you've
got to take with the rook and then
you've got to infiltrate and if he gets
the queen to D7 I think he's gonna win
the game the defense at that point is
way too tricky
to trade Queen and she's doing a lot of
analysis right now she's saying
something about trading the teams that
would be a great move fantastic like
that would be an exceptional move
because she's up material and she's
looking at that H5 Square in her whole
time Advantage has been melted it is
early even this is so tense three
minutes each she's up at peace
the self-belief might be going up
virtual is going how the hell did I
blunder that fork I think he gains
confidence though with the time
Advantage yeah see that's the psychology
of Chess right he he he knows he's the
favorite and he knows his opponent
thinks he's the favorite one of my
favorite MMA uh former Fighters says
like eight nine times out of ten in an
MMA fight both people know who's gonna
win really yeah which is like really
messed up you know and this is one of
those moments and she has to totally
flip that she's got to play confidently
there's the most she's thought in the
three games
right she's spending nearly a minute
Plus on this move and queen H5 a swag
move yeah you just said yeah he's being
tricky and I don't know how he's being
tricky she just assumes that he's doing
good things she stole upon the center
yeah not a bad move she did take a pawn
and the evaluation bar approves it but I
think it opens up more the board so if
virtual brings his Queen back for
example then that Queen's gonna Venture
into enemy territory and that could
spell problems for her King at some
point King is safe they're not enough
attackers that's just what I'm concerned
about yeah the position is completely
lost uh with best play that's the thing
in chess you have this asterisk with
best play it's not going to be best play
it wouldn't even be best Play If I was
playing or Robert was playing like we're
gonna make some slight you know
microscopic inaccuracy here and the
computer's gonna find something but
she's got to be super sharp they have to
start moving faster yeah two they can't
I mean those do the math they just spend
40 seconds right they got five five more
moves of spending 40 seconds Andre can
you go in there and yell at them until
like kick the door yeah no I I mean
Cutie's so focused I've been waiting for
this this entire match I love to see it
oh H5 on the board yeah very curious to
see how they'll perform under time
pressure this is like blunder territory
yeah there's blunder territory there's
for example Rook takes Rook takes takes
check King up and then like check
hitting the king and this he will find
that clever he's going to find that if
that happens uh she's gotta take and
then try to take with the queen or the
pawn or something uh and then maybe when
the queen comes in there's this sorry is
it crazy if you just go Queen G5
oh no what'd you do she
and now and now he's gonna play he's
gonna play Pawn takes pawn and that's it
and and I had a really really bad
feeling when he got the attack going on
the H file well hey don't don't sign
virtual love to finding the best move of
her time because he's he's blundered
Before He'll blunder again he has is he
yeah he's been planning this attack for
many moves did you see that it went down
to zeros for the most ridiculous
sequence that there is no chance that
anyone in podcast will find if they do
find it yeah we might have a problem
Rook takes F2 draws the game
at the end it's deflecting the king away
from the defensive yeah and this is
very tough yeah like at the end of the
day you deflect the king from the
defense of the rook and then you take
the Rook but I think I'm screwed if I
move here
that's the only winning move drawing or
drawing only non-losing movie Yes
regardless I'm just pinned well if
you're always considering you're forcing
moves there's a chance she could see
okay checks it's a check and a capture
exactly but she has a minute to find it
following her coach you know we enforced
it before the game yeah
yeah Robert
um I don't know I'm
she just took a queen she did what she
thought she was supposed to do in this
case but I mean Rook F2 is unfindable
people watching this right now are like
I wouldn't see that no you wouldn't yeah
stop lying to yourself after you get hit
with h takes Pawn you know you think
you're just losing and oh check over
capture I guess it doesn't matter either
way
oh man now it's now it's cooked yep yeah
I wanted to point out earlier in the
game Virtual played Rook H1 so early I
bet you he's been prepping this for like
the last 10 minutes yeah just trying to
get that open file and go for the king
yeah that's an impressive plan the queen
and the King were on the same file yeah
he spotted it immediately
G7 check oh oh my goodness
I'm sorry this is such a good game like
seeing cutie cutie fully focused this
gameplay like it was one small
inaccuracy again
yeah this was the best game for sure
absolutely and I think it's because she
finally felt inner Element no pressure
she was much more confident
forget the bishop is defended I might be
grasping at
straws but I okay there's forks and
a lot of different checks and oh see he
didn't play Rook takes bombs he's gonna
Rook G4 Rook G8 mate yep like that is
classy he doesn't even want the button
he realizes that the Queen by itself
can't deliver Checkmate so he's bringing
his Rook up to knock it out but Rook D6
is a good defensive try but okay we're
being serious it's an extra Queen for
any winning the bishop too it just yeah
matter of technique
no no he definitely definitely did not
like Queen C6
I forget that they're not playing online
you know because then they play online
those mouth slips happen I do love the
fake hats
there's a uh it's curtains oh boy uh
you're supposed to I don't think it
matters
is that illegal oh it is uh
honestly oh they're gonna
oh cutie resigns there it is
a virtual 3-0 and a down position makes
a comeback after blundering the bishop
thing
the POG Champs five
consolation bracket champ he joins the
legions of people like moist critical
and the other ones who I don't remember
that's fine to be fair I only remember
Charlie because he beat me that was a
tough one yeah
and we might have to make it happen
consolation Champion versus uh uh the uh
what's that what's the other one called
champion champion
it could be frank
that's true
I mean there's a good amount if you want
to pay me on the side we can talk about
it if you want to gamble some money
Gotham we could put some side bets uh
we're going to talk to uh the champion
and cutie Cinderella in just a moment uh
and then after that we'll have our salty
sweet match era versus tyler1 the
Brothers match the rematch yeah we
haven't talked much about that one but
it's happening Chad I am very much
looking forward to this I'm hoping e-rob
is finally gonna claim what's his so he
won the last one too in the POG Champs
right he won the uh the head-to-head
they played like a show no just beat
Tyler just beat Tyler yeah so what made
you want to plan the rematch because
Tyler has been grinding non-stop playing
like 50 games a day no it was a shame he
wasn't here like I loved actually
watching Tyler play and progress and I
could see from his very first games to
his last matches versus xqc he made
great improvements also we couldn't get
Jake and Logan Paul to play chess so
working on that one but first let's talk
to our champion let's talk to our
consolation runner-up come sit down you
two hello hello
hello how y'all doing first of all we're
trouble I'm not a cutie but I'm doing
amazing
congratulations
uh why did he get white that makes no
sense higher accuracy I believe or no no
I think it just goes is it higher
accuracy
Caps score seating
he's so much better than me why didn't I
get white would you would you do you
think I would have had a better chance
that was your best game and you didn't
play the stone wall it was a win for
everybody I mean think about it there's
a bright future
I think uh we should start with you
virtual how do you feel you won the
constellation bracket you were supposed
to maybe be in Championship but you're
still a winner yeah I mean I think I
made the most of it even though I was
very uh upset after losing groups and uh
it was really fun to come out here and
play chess over the board really
stressful I don't think people realize
how quiet how eerily quiet it is in that
room
how was that how was dealing with cutie
talking at you it made me want to win
more and maybe kicked in the drive a
little bit like damn no but um that was
it was it was fun and um you know I I
hope I got to prove what I'm capable of
on this Hospital
yeah we think you're the best Norwegian
to ever do it perhaps oh that's uh
but you're the only Norwegian world
champion right now yeah you you are yeah
consolation bracket World Champion yeah
forever there yeah of this year still
number two then yeah uh and cutie you
had an amazing game three you had a huge
lead how to feel being in there not good
not good sir uh it was not fun for me
but I did my best I mean I like virtual
so that made it easier because you know
I can goof around and it was fine
um but that wasn't fun and I did not
like it did it make it easier to talk
to him is that what like made him
feel more comfortable no I mean no I
kind of felt bad because he wasn't
giving anything back and so I was just
like he was pretty nice uh he obviously
deserves the win he was able to grind
way more than me
um however if that is dumb that I didn't
get white if you sold out a stadium last
night for your stand-up so yeah that's
true
it was packed ah I'm mad I didn't get
white that's I'm mad that's the only
thing I'm mad at call it rigged and say
you should have won that's what most
people do that's what I would do I won't
do that I feel bad for levian Hess who
tried their best to teach me things I am
an impossible student and I um you know
POG Champs 10. that's mine totally gonna
win I'm gonna still playing the stone
wall still playing the snowball James
10. it was scary though huh it was
pretty scary and I mean on the note of
coaches as well I want to give a shout
out to my coach Anna for an insane
effort to get in the prepared this so
many things that we looked at that
didn't happen but you know it worked I
would like to take that shout out back
Anna you don't get one what the heck
that should be for the girls Anna
any other shout out to any other people
you want to thank your mom's watching my
mom and dad are watching both of them
staying up pretty late uh Norwegian
hours yeah you're the second most famous
uh Norwegian chess player of all time
now so congratulations behind John Luke
hammer do you think they're doing a
watch party in the good night the Oslo
chest they might be honestly if so then
but yeah now I'm uh just gonna sit back
and enjoy some other chess games there's
one coming up right after this right can
I ask you something yeah would you be
interested in I don't know if we can
make this happen but a thug finals
between you and the winner of the
Champions bracket
we'll see we'll see what we can make
happen where's a quick question what's
your middle name uh it is Ludwig have
you never told me this I think I have it
you haven't we've hung out so much and
talked and chatted but it's like it's
such a bad joke oh Ludwig's my middle
name bro
well hey we'll talk about all the other
lies you're keeping from me but thank
you both for competing uh you you each
get a cash prize seven thousand dollars
and five thousand dollars uh and you get
a nice little title and you get to join
me in the rank of second place in
consolation bracket again we're the same
I'm losing consolation bracket it's been
really good I've also done this I like
it uh my mom and dad were also watching
so apologize to them please I'm sorry
[Music]
so a great job I am a bad loser but
virtual is a very great winner you
didn't rub it in my face one only a few
times well he's in our region he'll
probably do some pull-ups later okay uh
and we'll see that but that's after the
break and we'll come back with the salty
sweet match tyler1 versus e-rob
[Music]
go away
[Applause]
[Music]
better music
yes yes
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
all right we are back at pogchamps five
with the conclusion of the constellation
bracket virtual was Crown Champion but
we have before our Championship bracket
finals a salty sweet match and also a
new commentator with us hello Nemo how
are you doing I'm doing well how are you
guys always have my head right there
just make a funny face
[Laughter]
what you should know about is the
mattress coming up it's tyler1 versus
e-rob and let me give you guys some
context tyler1 and e-rob are brothers
e-rob is the younger brother wow e-rob
has often lost to tyler1 in video game
contest through his life as younger
brothers do of course they recently like
a month ago maybe had a 1v1 variety show
match okay played through a bunch of
different games to find out who the
better gamer is between them okay e-rob
wins okay shocking okay all right he
he's in tears he's talking about first
time he ever beat his brother yada yada
and uh one of the games that they played
that era beat Tyler in was chess
okay wow wow yeah wait I'm impressed and
this kind of kickstarts uh tyler1's
chess Arc which he has been on and and I
think of the people in POG Champs he
might have played the most games and
arguably made the most maybe outside of
virtual but second most Improvement he
improved a lot uh even making it to the
championship bracket and I think he
started with like a like a like a 46
rating
yeah his rating was double digits yes
you can't have double digits he found a
way yeah and and he challenged me to a
ten thousand dollar uh chess match he he
challenged Hikaru and Magnus and he he
knew he had to back up the trash talk
and he's gained some hundreds of points
yeah or do you feel threatened mildly
but it's good that we're far apart you
know yeah it's also good it's chess like
I don't fear the muscles in chess unless
he picks up a piece that has been
captured and throws it at me right
because that would yeah that would be
bad uh but I I'm pretty confident I
could I could make the 10K I I would I
would do a collab with him where I teach
him chess and he you know teaches me to
not be so skinny well hey we can
actually ask him right now Levy if you
want to do that we have an interview
with both these players so let's get him
on the screen they're right behind you
right now uh Tyler era can you hear us
Tyler how about a little decorum how
about a hello first the was that
sorry I said hello after I just had to
make that clear audience what okay do
you want to get out your Miss grievances
now or do you want to just move on
you're horrible at everything you do and
League of Legends you blew my reputation
it's been all downhill from there I hope
you're happy your reputation is blown by
that how about your loss to e-rob didn't
that hurt the reputation a bit let's
talk about that you had a show that's
Droid his reputation destroyed that's a
good wordy Rob would you agree with that
Tyler
it's the one thing he's ever beaten to
me at in his life literally and since we
were kids it's not true
did you beat me at nothing IRL nothing
sports related nothing lifting related
nothing spraying related
you had a wonderful day I was dealing
with a lot congrats I'm about to have
another good day today oh you're not
I've seen her rating you're like 500 and
you only beat me at chess before because
I had never played in oh my God
you've been practicing everything you
played like 80 games yesterday
I have played three games today
all right look I sense a little bit of
tension between you uh but Tyler e Rob's
right that if he did win today it would
be a stain arguably a larger stain that
if you had played A League of Legends
event with another Creator who's just
trying to have a good time like that you
this would be worse I'm not terrible man
I'm just bringing the points here I'm
still a good time
it can be a fun game sometimes doesn't
matter you're not worried about it
that's your quote
not worry about it and then Europe
you're coming into this you're saying I
barely play the game I don't give a
I'm just showing it up
I I won your test tournament Ludwig you
remember that yeah the the one with the
uh the eval bar Chi chess I forget what
I called it
yeah I never got paid for that by the
way oh wow shut the up shut the
up shut the up shut up shut
the up okay no you're good though
right smile put the thumbs up to the
camera great uh he's good he'll get paid
out uh anyway
if you win today I never got paid either
by the way guys let's focus on today
right we're having a fun time if you win
today what does it mean does it mean
you're better than Tyler are the graphs
trending upwards do you get paid
tired of people
still games and I'm just gonna prove it
today
all right he's a cloud period he he has
beat me at barely he won like 9 11.
every game he plays for hours a day I
haven't touched in years and it was
still competitive well I've seen the
tyler1 Twitter account you played 174
games yesterday or something Tyler uh
you're rating a skyrocketed from from
100 to 700. last I checked impressive
impressive jump I think the largest jump
in terms of rating from any player in
pogchamp's history ever in the history
of the game uh that got him that's got
Gotham but ice here got him bro I
watched got him this video
[Laughter]
seriously I'm just saying oh we went on
YouTube and looked up tutorials how to
play chess man
it's called striving to improve Eric oh
my God
all right well hey let's let's let the
play Talk how about you two duel it out
it's a best of two if it goes one one
you go to a tiebreaker and I think we
can say whoever wins this match is the
better gamer of all time of all time
let's just put it
up and we'll talk to you after the game
go off good luck Godspeed
you're a loser
who is he talking about with that loser
talk that was crazy well when are you
paying us man don't worry about the
money it's about The Vibes you know what
I mean it's about the like the good
times and the and the long how much how
much was it like out of curiosity
I can't was it like thousands it was it
was like tens of them
with interest at this point and interest
yes you've been paid out though I didn't
do it okay great
I shouldn't bring this up now but also
the poker game oh oh you know everybody
I I do pay out I'm good I'm uh I'm good
for my word I pay out net uh 765.
standard in the industry uh so I just
take a little bit of time but but let's
focus on the here let's focus on the now
this there's some real tension in this
match and this room where's my money
no but this match yeah there's gonna be
moves made and
and it's gonna be great video comes back
Ludwig is just getting beat up yeah yeah
it was good to cut the camera from me uh
we have tyler1 uh again who did get I
think the largest rating increase in
blockchamp's history going from dead ass
100 something to 700 grinding
like 50 60 70 games a day which is
miserable he learned from hafu and then
she quit chess because she just played
chess non-stop for entire POG Champs
does he rage as much at chess as he does
at least yeah yes absolutely I remember
I tuned in one time and he's like these
Queen users they just Spam Queen
moves so lazy so brain dead and there's
a point though it is lazy it's brain
dead but he lost to it yeah
something you got to learn and adapt to
uh but I'm a little nervous for e-rob
why well because
he created a new narrative when he beat
Tyler last month it is the first time
that he someone who's been colloquially
called lrob took a win over tyler1 Alpha
gamer six foot five yada yada
and so if he loses this that kind of
gets wiped out
is that fair to say that's fair to say
he's six five no he's a little bit
shorter than you you're like six seven
right I have six seven yeah so we uh I
don't have to get into the details of it
but we were looking at some people for a
potential boxing match uh and uh and the
guy I'm working with Matt was like how
about tyler1 versus Knute
uh and because he thought tyler1 was six
foot five do you know who knut is no uh
he's
he's a six foot six 270 pound man okay
who looks like the mountain from Game of
Thrones
uh and and I just I I think it wouldn't
work out as a fight but maybe it would
because Tyler would win yeah David
versus Goliath yeah yeah
um but we're gonna jump into this match
in just a bit let's get predictions on
the board right here let's go left to
right Nemo starting with you who wins
and by how much I think that Tyler went
tyler1 is going to win by
it's only a best of two right best of
two so at most it's a 2-0
he's gonna win three sorry I'm gonna
guess one and a half to zero and a half
for Tyler for Tyler sorry a half half
what
I was gonna say it I heard it though no
I like it one and a half for Tyler what
about you I think he's gonna win I think
he's gonna win three zip Tyler win three
Zips
I think on a serious note I think I
think we'll get a we'll get a tie break
I want a little one one it's gonna go to
three and then and then you know they're
in God's hands I don't know what happens
inside break one one and it's in God's
hands yep just because Europe seems much
calmer and nicer I'm not as afraid of
him if I go against him so I'm gonna go
two nothing Tyler okay okay two nothing
Tyler
I'm gonna say one and a half for to half
for Tyler
yay Alex how does the draw happen sorry
one and a half okay there we go that's
correct how does it how does the draw
happen though like what is the half a
point where's it coming from yeah
oh he's still made it many times
either one has an insane chance to
stalemate I'm gonna I'm gonna
take the less favorite option here I
think e-rob wins this okay uh he won my
dumb chess tournament which did have the
eval bar that's why we called it dumb
chess that the players could see while
they were playing so they would know if
they're in a winning position or not uh
and it wasn't close like he kind of
crushed the competition and the
competition I would call them tyler-like
skilled people uh free training Arc yes
the training Arc is pretty serious but
like chess is not a game you can train
for 80 hours in two weeks and then all
of a sudden you are good at the game
have you met hafu she did it for like
two months and she played like probably
500 hours of Chess okay maybe maybe
that's fair yeah that's true but like
generally that's like the biggest issue
with POG Champs and chess as a whole it
doesn't have insane Improvement very
quickly it is much more gradual and like
you can make some like level UPS in
terms of not making mistakes but like to
see ideas and get good positions like it
takes a while
agreed and part of the process of
getting better doing puzzles but when
you're playing a game no one's tapping
you on the shoulder but you have a
puzzle in this position I think it's
really hard for people like I solve that
when I'm doing it on my own why can't I
do that in the game I guess that's what
dumb chess was exactly what's happened
you telling you to look yeah someone on
your shoulder that that is so tricky for
300s though because you're like it's
plus seven and you don't know why and
then you go for something and it's now
minus seven you know it's like a 14
point swing because you it was mostly
valuable if mate was on the board right
because they would see the M yeah yeah
that's the M's good well that's uh
that's really helpful yeah M7 is like
not helpful like maybe seven
what uh yeah I think Tyler even took
yesterday off from streaming to grind
for this wow wow uh competitive and
everything he does so not only did you
not pay him it seems like he lost a lot
of money so much about money and not
enough about the good times
I don't care about the money money I
just care about hanging out with you
right me and you love you we don't even
buy the shoes unless it's got a comma on
the price tag but amen but then again
who looks at the price tag come on man
so I'm saying uh all right brotherly
match I think we're ready for it
in just a bit I lied we're not ready for
it why didn't you guys put me and Andrea
against each other for this too it's not
close right she wants the money oh yeah
she just wants money
um I don't know Andrea's been grinding a
little very recently she's been training
are you insulting me anymore well only
because we have a match coming up Sunday
and I'm like Nemo's upset that I'm
higher rated than her and bullet now I
never bring it up
so she's higher rated than you are yeah
doesn't that mean she's better at the
game only in bullet yeah but that's
quick thinking so it's kind of like yeah
that no that's I mean bullet chess is
like the epitome of actual shelter I
grinded bullet for about two months I
got to like 1300 rated and it's all
gimmicks the 1300 bullet is like 1900
rapid because if you actually had time
to think you would you know yeah
actually true although most of my skill
was hitting them with checks that were
blundering all my pieces but then they
would have to click on their gang they
couldn't remove are you a pre-move king
yeah or anything
what the hell
what the heck go get it let's get it
going what is this oh yeah ref let me
see the game please well the game is
really looking good guys uh there it is
no but I quit playing and now every time
I play I get rolled are they talking to
each other yeah yeah
cringe fresh account ELO games probably
put
they're basically playing bullet so far
yeah they are playing incredibly quickly
where uh quite a few moves through
already what do you guys see Levy has
anyone want to chime in what's what's
going on I just love in the backgrounds
it's just one more game that's a pretty
sweet sign
I remember uh seeing this position I
think in 1982 in in the Columbia there
was a game uh carp of the last
tournament
[Music]
yeah
huge blunder by e-rob yep insane Tyler
took advantage of it he brought his
Bishop back and now that Tyler took it
he's about to say you take my Bishop but
my knight is protecting I explained you
my strategy
the strategy was he just took the bishop
there was
it was a good move I mean don't get me
wrong but
no it was interesting strategy you know
where's your best move
do you think Tyler has had to get new
tank tops as his muscles have grown
well that's a thing about like the tank
tops is they they form around you it's
like leather I see
oh they're panning his camera because
there he is he's always locked into the
screen look but he actually like uh if
you're what bro no I'm thinking
they're um
if you've ever watched online chess
events in the past forehead cam is a
real thing because chess players because
they've never been to meetings
I get 11 rating points if I win
oh
yeah
removed from Eric but he's down right
now he's down a full piece uh but Tyler
has been in this position before he's
he's plays very well early mid game uh
and he calculates everything out one of
the biggest issues I've seen with
Tyler's gameplay is he thinks every
position out and then he ends up super
low on time and he just cannot clutch an
end game with one or two minutes on the
clock
he is ahead
but that might just be because irav is
trying to come up with some kind of
comeback
look at that I'm looking dude
dude a chess tournament just saying
[Laughter]
like me it's five you're not
multitaskable I do think it's an
advantage for Tyler to be able to talk
because they don't talk in pogchan's
matches right I don't know what to
do
Ah
that's so exciting that's a maniacal
cackle like that scares me this is why
you have to be rude Tyler otherwise he's
mad at you like he's at Levy this is
like a big disclaimer for why you should
be careful getting into chess because
this is what you descend into I mean I
feel like League of Legends and chess is
a very is a wild lifestyle yeah that is
scarier to me than if someone said yeah
I start with Salvia and then I end the
day with like you know cocaine yeah
League of Legends in chess.com that's a
dangerous Duo what's the order though
League or chess first which is worse for
you
they talk yeah because you can by far
there's too many people on the other
team talking to you in all chat but to
be fair chess is really painful because
at least in League If I Lose I'm blaming
everything except myself I'm blaming my
teammates I'm playing blaming RNG only
yourself to blame in chess exactly and
OverWatch I would just end every round
by going I have four Golds and then you
know your trash and you should have
healed better it's always the healer's
fault exactly I feel like I don't want
to be teammates any of you except for
Ludwig because we're Champions
what about Queen G5 what do you think
about it this is my genius move
White's move but for black guy
I I like it it's not guaranteeing
anything but it's I mean a plan is a
plan it's kind of Saucy hey maybe
Tyler's just not going to see Bishop H3
with the Checkmate coming up he would
have to miss Bishop H3 and queen takes
G2 he would have to miss
but okay there's an on-pass home is it
worth taking how's the e-rob's French
better than yours I would argue uh
excuse you listen they speak to me in
French at the airport all right in the
French airport
that's just because they're French
people they speak to me in Japanese in
the Japanese airport I don't walk around
talking about it they're not going to
speak Japanese stop it but what's too
big uh what do you think they take there
I don't know I guess my first one
doesn't even know what ampasana is but
yeah it was one of the two patches to
chess fine
you know how that happened right I have
a theory how it happened okay I think a
ridge dude was playing at a bar and some
you know some some guy like he had
trapped his pawns and then the guy just
went straight through bro you know he
just like ran the pawn straight through
the blockade and this Aristocrat was
like this is my cell phone no well this
is not allowed so they just made this
rule like for one turn and one turn only
I can take an empty square and that
means that I capture it doesn't make any
sense how does it make any sense not to
sound like a nerd here but I looked it
up on Wikipedia yeah one time and
apparently it was used to counter pawns
were moving too fast up the board
to slow down the movement of Pawns of
the board by allowing amphisol but I
think I think a rich guy started it
because there's no way like if a peasant
in society said this is not possible
like you know that was not going to get
taken seriously Marie Lopez was a
peasant really no I don't know Bro
oh okay I just be saying stuff he was a
priest listen you could get a platform
doing that nowadays too so I like this
attempt by Tyler he's repositioning his
Knight I think for a lot of newer
players as soon as you get out of the
opening it's very hard to come up with
some kind of plan and sometimes the best
one is just putting your pieces on a
slightly better Square yeah the problem
is there are no Pawn tricks not a single
Pawn casters commentators his child
playing the background I can't focus
sounds like he's a worse Uncle because
he wants the child to remove oh I heard
that noise I was like is that Iran and
then I I mean I know I know it was the
kid but no I didn't I think he's a
better uncle because he cares he's like
oh I'm distracted because I'm that was
me
they're playing peek-a-boo that's so
cute yeah they're about to play peekaboo
with some of these chess pieces they
better fall off the board
but it's seriously you know that no
pawns have been traded so I think that's
where newer players struggle yeah right
because I need to open up the board
desperately and I actually think oh in
that line of thought B3 makes a lot of
sense let's open some lines for my
pieces because otherwise it's just too
close
yeah I always uh I I always I love
comparing chess and and mixed martial
arts because there's so many different
things you can train so for example this
would be like a training session in
closed positions like close positions
are determined by the amount of Pawns on
the board they both have eight pawns on
the board wow
they both have these fences they've
built and in close positions you can
maneuver your pieces or make Pawn breaks
just so he never gets mad at me Tyler
and I were on the same wavelength there
yeah yeah that was you finish each
other's sandwiches sandwiches exactly
okay well he he was very indecisive
he ordered the first thing on the menu
and then he went for the second thing uh
but this is still fine uh he's gonna
open up this song
called his brother ugly is that what he
said he called him an ugly Pawn Pusher
yeah what if he wasn't pushing his pawns
is he still ugly or yeah he's no longer
a pawn Pusher though okay the worst of
the two insults there you can get away
with such a more intense trash talk when
it's your sibling
uh I think you would know yeah I think
you're reporting from a state of
authority here
this is a pretty Advanced position for
black spawns
that sounds smart saying that yeah you
did I felt like a genius saying that
sentence well I mean if and he does take
back black has this outside pass Pawn so
if white starts trading off some of the
Rooks and the queen that could be
dangerous but for now up in a whole
night Tyler is in charge
yeah what else can black really do
though nothing
is this where you do a rook lift you
could try I think he's got to build
behind the a pawn
which uh you know is an OP
outside pass Pond and then you hold it
there I'm sorry you're calling outside
pass pawns Ops I see yeah
you got to know the Ops is this the new
terminology and you drop you're dropping
your book I I that is not in the book
but maybe in the reprint I'm gonna call
it the Ops always push for opposition we
need Ops
all I can just hear the baby in the
background he's probably saying B take
C4 stupid
I mean listen that ain't that right now
there are there are companies that
specialize in teaching kids who are
three years old how to play chess I mean
they might specialize I don't know how
good they are but the way they do it is
they create characters who are more like
actors and they just try to make it fun
rather than focus on yeah maybe we
should do that for podcast participants
yeah
you're talking like a like a little baby
learning tool for the competitors for
the 27 year old competitors yeah
yeah that could work oh Tyler looks
really focused right now he is up a full
night but the Rook is staring at his
Pawn he should push his Pawn here which
cuts off the Bishop from the defense of
the A4 pawn and said he brings his Queen
to a passive position it's not a bad
move you see the evil bar hardly changes
but I think that the momentum is
slightly shifting in Europe's favorite
so this is a crazy position because they
have four pass pawns past Pawn is
determined by whether or not an enemy
Pawn can stop it so this is a past Pawn
even though technically for now it can't
go through so these are connected past
pawns they'll go hand in hand these are
separated past pawns very weird
positions he said get that I think we
might see G3 and queen takes E4 with the
queen blunder it's not that easy to see
that the queen protects the pawn here
do you guys agree with you Rob is that a
good move it wasn't a bad move but it's
not nothing you can't really do it
depends what your criteria for good and
bad is let's put it this way so it's a
bad move it's not a bad it's a you know
it's a creative move I actually think in
positions like this where you're down a
piece you should just go for crazy plans
I want to see e-rob go for G5 G4 and
start pushing his king size pawns oh wow
the queen blender is about to happen
you're worried about taking E4 Queen
sees that yeah
and Tyler's gonna yell
I think he's gonna go E3 and attack the
bishop and that also sadly blunders the
queen
dude I was so bad at chess no that was a
second I was on the couch miss it
perhaps by show of hands oh all of you
missed it okay left my water raise your
hands
you're up thinking here's my favorite
words queen queen just doesn't have many
squares he can go back on the diagonal
he'd go to the side or back to F6 so the
three safe squares here Queen in line
with the bishop usually not a very good
idea this Knight can hop out the way by
either taking this Pawn or taking this
one but then he would grab the bishop
right exactly so he could grab the
bishop on E2 but then he loses his
Bishop back there on D7 so white hops
around steal some material not the
easiest thing to spot it's a very lucky
configuration because it's very natural
for white to play Knight takes Free Pawn
and lose the bishop but then the
position is so good sometimes that you
have a follow-up that okay so that
happens a lot of Chess where the
position just like works out and your
Knights happen to defend the things in
the back and I feel like it wasn't
really pre-planned yeah well it depends
on what ELO right at 1500 if that
happens that's because it was seen at
800 no it was a miracle of God like I
you know B5 is a great move yeah he's
just
yeah this is the movie you're asking for
earlier just cutting off the circulation
of black light Square Bishop on D7 with
that pawn because the past Pawn is
dangerous if you get pieces behind it
and can push it now it's you push it
you're just gonna lose it so White's
Rook is in the perfect situation
can I tell you my God like move what's
that Bishop C6
mm-hmm
you're devious it's a bit
Alexandra you doesn't work
uh it might be worth trying I mean it
doesn't do anything but it sets a trap
well it's not gonna jump to conclusions
it does a couple things right you know
he could play it and gosh yeah oh
my God so that would be incredible yeah
the whole idea that Ludwig is trying to
Encore because oh oh no my Bishop then
your queen is lost down the B line so
it's a good attempt but it would require
the foresight that the pawn has been I
realize I'm just a lazy cheesy chess
player but there's not you can't do much
here so and that's a great move that's a
really really good move the knight's
under attack there's two attackers and
only one defender on the night so the
queen and the bishop team up there are
tactical ideas here we were talking
about earlier you can give up your
Bishop here you know you would like to
take this Pawn on D4 but the fact that
Black's Bishop is defended is really
clutch so I think that the best idea
would be just to bring the queen up to
D3
like Robert's predictions have been very
on point this entire game
you you're in Tyler one's mind yeah how
do you get in the mind of a
terrible player
um first of all it's not terrible he's
improving he's a work in progress I do
love he always uses the term improving
you're so sweet oh thank you you're
sweet too I think it's because you
worked with me is the answer that I'm uh
that you know how to think like a doctor
player first of all you're not a bad
chess player because I'm improving
whatever well not right now
wow hey you stopped taking lessons
listen you're only a bad chess player if
you have to wear a helmet when you play
the game like all right let's hurt
yourself
um whoa that's a good move listen
sometimes the king's got to put in the
work you know that's a really good move
I wouldn't I mean it would yeah is it on
it yeah it was fun I would like H4 here
because he can't take with a knight
since the E2 Bishop is hanging and then
he actually gets some kind of attack
even if he sacrifices his Pawns
I don't think he would see the tactic
but he might have the intuition to keep
pushing yeah and the threat is Pawn H3
with check kicking the king away from
the defense of the Knight so H4 would be
an excellent try which is a a win black
just wins the game it's going to be
checked why would Paul not just take
that's fine yeah like that's probably
it's not the best move but it's totally
a response if Queen East is a good move
he's setting up uh the battery so he's
looking with the queen and the bishop
and uh yeah see that was an accidental
Brilliance I think because he was about
to get x-rated still losing because
white would end up with a bishop and a
knight for a rook but this is great
because now you're safe and the rest of
the game is smooth sailing as long as
you don't find a way to lose those pawns
white should win this game without
much drama but you never know they have
quieted down a lot
yeah and Tyler thinks he has seen
something you saw his face there he I
don't know what he's looking at maybe
the check and he's worried about his
King but he's played an excellent game
thus far he stole the piece that was
offered to him and he has not looked
back I mean there's still plenty of ways
to lose like you could get checked and
then that H4 plan and then you take with
a pawn and then Queen check is mate and
uh obviously it doesn't have to happen
but trying to get into the minds of the
players we gotta gotta foresee all
possibilities like uh Doctor Strange
Europe has been really good at taking
his time here especially when his pieces
are under attack but he is going to be
in here
[Laughter]
she's jumped can you imagine like
candidates tournaments
and what's crazy is how long e-rob took
he took his time even to reply yeah like
a car just like walking in the island
it's not a bad move yeah pushing a
past Pawn he's got a rook behind it uh
he is down a piece and I think that
Tyler can probably first focus on the
passer it's something to push the pawn
of your own especially with his last
move Rook here signals I want to push
the pawn up to C5 but that actually
allows the black punt all the way down
to A2 because the queen will join the
rook in the defense of that square so I
think that he should Corral that pawn
with like Queen to B3 that would be I
think the safest option
between B3 is good and queen B4 is good
he also need some crazy yeah
I mean they are they are looking at four
million 700 000 possibilities
sure there's more possible chest
positions than atoms in the universe
isn't that crazy is that real yeah I
didn't count I didn't count yeah you're
nodding your head like so confidently
yeah we've just all seen the graphic
many times it's like two to the power of
like 92 I don't even know I'm just
making numbers up at this point how much
money you owe us by the way
[Laughter]
I'll get there I'll get there guys
all right subscribe
quieter than I would have expected well
that's because you got to think it is
hard to think and talk at the same time
yeah and the moment you start talking
you are taking energy away from thinking
oh yeah agreed I do want you rob
screaming a little bit back Tyler
of
not necessarily supposed to win but like
expecting to win I barely practice for
this I'm just showing up to beat your
ass so if he's also chirping and then
loses that's like the worst case that's
a great move
yup he hits the queen Bishops are
staring at each other
and he stopped the check all at once
because his Knight defends that square
so if he wants to get pieces off the
board it's a good try he is in some
danger of getting his Knight trapped
over here that could be a downside of
hopping into enemy territory but I
really like the attempt there by time he
spent a lot of time on that move as well
it's going to be a moment here if black
plays Queen here and then white takes
and takes and the Knight gets trapped
the only way to defend the knight at
that point is to move a pawn and then
there's on pass on and you've got to
come back and uh
I don't know if any of this is going to
happen those are the stuff that we got
to calculate we might get Bishop takes
and then Knight takes Queen after all I
know I imagine what would happen in that
scenario is Queen takes Knight and then
the queen would take the
yeah and then yeah that's where you yeah
I think you'd end up and then probably
the bishop moves and we all live okay
that's kind of the same thing you just
yeah
that's hanging right now in fact that's
an even better attempt because if the
bishops get traded now black can get
that Knight on G5 with the F6 yeah so
that was a really good move
uh the computer wants you to to come
back and say that was not my fault that
was not a good phone my fault uh or or
here yeah and now age takes and you've
got to find a way to guard but
he might go here because I think Queen
takes is too tempting it's too tempting
it was also the last move that you just
played so now it's like do I take the
Knight do I take the bishop what do I do
but maybe he didn't see it maybe he was
just trying to move his Queen out of
threat how do you open your brain enough
to like
be ready for that
yeah and he does play that was the
expected move
because it's so common I
think I think that's a blunder
the one for one you Cloud David would
have called a mistake
terminology fraud he's clearly been
analyzing the games afterwards and
looking at the difference in that term
he's like learning the difference
between an accuracy of mistake I use
right though it's not a blunder it's a
one for one trade take me
he's asking to take me but it's his turn
does he know that yeah he does
but is he gonna attack the queen and
lose the bishop that would be very bad
yeah
you're saying if he pushed the pawn to
H4
which just leaves the bishop unprotected
I Tyler yeah no no no so I think what
I'm nervous about here and I think the
way Europe wins is on time because Tyler
does the entire look at checks captures
threats uh every turn and so like he I
think he looked at it that turn wow
oh good move nice he's getting some
counter attack finally yeah and if Black
season his kid supports it yeah I was
gonna say if the king plays like G7 or
something you can even swing The Rook
around to h8
that's like what virtual did against
cutie Cinderella he got his rook in line
with the Enemy King and it caused some
problems so the King on G2 not
completely safe and I have to say Tyler
has been extremely strong in this game
and when he played against xqc he was in
time trouble and that did him no favors
so he is calculating every turn which is
great for a growing chess player but now
under the duress of time travel it might
not be the best situation Queen B3 is
crazy that's the move you guys brought
up earlier yeah great play
all right well here's my here's my idea
Pawn A2
um
if if Rook captures Rook captures oh and
then Queen captures Rogue that is that's
like gonna happen yeah I feel like
that's gonna happen right now if white
takes the pawn exactly where it is at
the end the queen ends up defending the
Rook right so like at the end of the day
yeah so but like if Rook takes Queen
takes
you know because I'm expecting Rook
takes Rook takes Queen takes right I
mean right C Queen takes Rook God Bless
but so the geometry here works out a
little bit better but yeah you can't
move the Rook off the back rank because
the queen would take the Rook uh we were
talking about time though Nemo whoa
uh that's a big move it is a big move oh
oh oh oh what is he gonna is he gonna
snap take the Rook or is he gonna oh
oh and the because he could have grabbed
that
[Applause]
oh
my God and he had it and he had it he
saw the move yeah he saw every single
move just in the incorrect order
you're watching it we're not too happy
now let me take that pot as well all a
matter of time bro
he has no idea oh my God
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
it's not a problem
and it was like a villain who tells his
plan to everyone before he does it yeah
he's like doctor evil
aren't you not feel bad for Europe right
now he was so close wow well I mean it's
a classic Dynamic it's older brother
versus little brother older brother
looks like the way tyler1 does which is
which is how like much like uh
much like one of those monsters in Left
4 Dead that come out remember Fantastic
Four yes it looks like the Golem
Fantastic Four yeah brick wall yeah I
wonder how he feels about that he is a I
mean maybe he looks better than
[Music]
it's close
wait why is it close show me show me
it's not cool have you push the pawn the
king only is one square so like you have
to be very very careful
oh yeah you go right oh no you can't
fly at all Hunter F6 is made in one
which is crazy
Queen E6 is made
oh
you're always right here
I assume it is the child yeah
that is Emmy in the background I believe
he's missing Checkmate in one but he's
doing the right thing because stalemate
happens when you don't give checks it's
when a king has no moves but it's
non-check so if he keeps giving checks
it will be Checkmate he has it check man
two moves if he wants it but just keep
giving checks okay still made if you
check they remove us to be a check
please do not is he gonna try to go for
the third Queen
okay and now it's Maiden one Queen G7
Queen h8
Queen E8 does not Checkmate oh that is
Checkmate either oh I'm so nervous right
now I don't know why oh he's gonna he's
gonna find it Queen G7 Queen F6
oh my God
[Laughter]
oh my God he is up 25 points of material
how does that make any sense by the way
how does that make sense
how much material you're down
it does matter it's a shitty game
wow oh my God I can't believe it
happened we memed about it but he found
perhaps the most unlikely stalemate so
many attacking pieces and he moves the
weakest one of all the pawn and it's not
a check he was making so many checks and
then he just didn't and Deja Vu for you
uh well I pre-moved mine which is a
little bit cooler all right stalemate's
lame but if there's a cool way to do it
it's pre-moving it uh and so that means
it's half a point to half a point
so whoever wins the next game wins
unless we somehow end up with another
stalemate yeah which we will see when we
come back from this break
see you in a bit
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Champs 5 salty sweet tyler1 versus e-rob
the unthinkable happened tyler1 beating
his brother it was a story of Revenge
from his failure last month and he
choked it just a huge
massive
choke
25 points up and nothing to show for it
uh I don't think that stalemate should
be taken out of Chess but I do think
that we should be able to capture the
king in Chess I think if you put your
king in danger chess.com should not be
able to stop you agreed I think if you
miss a check and then you just don't see
it you they should be able to capture
your king yeah I mean
a question here yes what is more
embarrassing being up 25 points in chess
and squandering Checkmate by moving your
weakest piece the pawn and and
stalemating or
you're playing League of Legends it's a
show match and there's people hiding in
a bush and maybe someone on your team
hints that there could be people in a
butch but you don't know your bronze
right and so you want to Ward that bush
to find out but you don't realize the
range of the people in the bush so when
you go to Ward it they jump out of the
Bush and they kill you
which one's worse honestly because I am
a chess player and people expect me to
be good at chess for me personally to
Stillman obviously if you weren't a lot
worse but but it's interesting it's
understand it's interesting it's worse
the chest is worse right chess yeah
chest is worse chest is worse yeah yeah
let's just walk in there I've never
stalemated somebody wait what yeah ever
I've never I don't believe it is like
the online Blitz game it's just ever
like in time
why are you still me just check me
you're just lying no not find a
stalemate go find a sail away right now
this is crazy they definitely have that
on the insides on chestnuts they don't
even know just do it forehead just get a
Checkmate yeah like why are you still
mating what's wrong with you you know
your time trouble it's an accident I
don't get into time trouble
yeah Levy is perfect well I wouldn't go
that far he's not getting his GM wow
say she said uh your your hair looks
normal oh no she definitely didn't say
that that's
anyway let's focus on the match here
because we got game two which almost
assuredly will Crown the winner right
yeah probably very surprising if we
reach a second stalemate uh who do we
have all right let's get a updated
prediction let's go across starting with
you who do you think wins this so my
prediction
all right so I'm gonna stick with my
after era blundered I thought he
recovered very well until he missed the
free rook at the end sure
Hess I'm going with Tyler I think that
he played a great game at the upper hand
and he didn't deliver The Knockout but I
think he hasn't him that said erup did
play great as well in the defense but
I'm still going Tyler I think they make
another draw I said it was going to be
1-1 so another draw another draw all
right I'm going to stick with my
prediction to one and a half to zero and
a half so
sorry half half
which accent is that which accent it's
just from all the places I've lived in I
don't know at this point I'm not I'm not
gonna throw a dart at a map
uh I'm walking in Europe Iran erupt
takes us down he's got a little
confidence behind him he made a really
stupid blunder early on just
miscalculated how many pieces we're
attacking uh and and I don't think I'll
make that same mistake again uh so let's
check how close are we to Showtime I
think they might play a little slower in
the start too we were talking about you
know us playing bullet but they were
playing bullet right off the very bad
and I think that's what caused him to
lose a knight right in the opening and I
think you know they're gonna learn from
that hopefully He adjusted very quickly
after he took his sweet sweet time yeah
for sure yeah it's like you play a game
at 85 accuracy but you played the whole
game down a piece so you never had a
chance to win yeah so that kind of hurts
yeah it feels bad it's not easy you can
can't start a World Cup match down three
goals played really well you're still
gonna be on three goals does it matter
that e-rob's starting with white now we
also talk about white Advantage doesn't
matter at all nah I mean let me just
level I don't think so Tyler's been
grinding some Karo Khan but I don't know
if that means anything you look into his
matches you keep up no he played it in
POG Champs and then he said uh got
Gotham games I've been watching your
Karo because that's not my channel name
yeah
got him got him I I do for sure and
bacon and turkey and chicken breast and
yeah
um yeah he said he's been watching the
Karo Khan and you know then they blame
me if they lose so I gotta I gotta be
there in the victories and the defeats
and the draws and the stalemates that
was my fault so you're like the god of
the Carl con now I think so yeah I'm I'm
probably the most notorious Karo Khan
player of all time I'm not saying I'm
the best but the notorious yeah I've
played I don't know how many thousands
of games with it and I think it's a good
beginner opening uh cutie played it
today got a couple of great positions
why would you bring up
someone who lost with it if you call
yourself the thought of it but but you
don't lose because of the opening you
know we just saw it still made you know
he didn't stalemate because of the
opening he still made it
I don't know why he still made it really
I I don't know what the reason is but
sometimes you get nervous Okay and like
you just want to make them I've never
stalemated first in my life okay never
had sex in your life
sorry I'm sorry I lashed out that was
inappropriate that last show I lasted I
shouldn't have done that who's married
here all right yeah how about how about
somebody put a ring on somebody I owe
you money too
I'm good for it yeah so one's due to
getting the questions Jesus I mean
you're the closest of anyone here God
let's go back to the GM Norm
conversation yeah yeah
let's back out of this one I mean listen
the GM title nowadays is you go to
Europe you pay an 80 year old to lose to
you they get a couple hundred euros is
this real well there's this uh there's
this new the format that was banned
recently they do this thing called
hybrids right so covet it was difficult
to travel so they started doing this
thing in the Chess World called hybrids
where you get a certified setting and
then everybody comes there and you can
get a real rating without actually ever
playing a person face to face this was a
thing yes so a bunch of kids were
playing against a bunch of other people
across the world at three in the morning
and they were getting actual rating by
beating up senior citizens not
physically but in chess right so that
was what hybrids were it's not allowed
anymore but I could have done that I
could have farmed hybrids to 2700. they
banned them before I it would have been
great content though yeah I would have
that has been so cool just make the
candidates off the hardware then that's
exactly when they would have been like
let's say Fabiano's like I want to take
over magnus's rating and just starts
playing matches against your GM's from
across the world if someone's big enough
does it they find yeah yeah I think you
know just one of those things I just was
not dealt with I think hybrids like by
themselves are a great idea like that
way you can have the World Cup FIFA and
then have like chest players from
different countries play each other
that's awesome right but I think without
oversight it just was a horrible system
that was abused maybe they have to do it
in the same time zone so at least it
evens things out a bit it could be yeah
they definitely were not no they were
not doing that I I heard a story of a
guy going to the hospital at like two in
the morning over there and then he came
back and he like finished the game
that's the dedication honestly honestly
yeah but I know they can't do that we
are in it first move played E4 from
e-rob let's switch over to the board you
take a look E4 Rob I love an E4 I'll see
if uh Tyler's still yeah Tyler is tilted
at all from the draw 100 he looks like
he's on drugs right now
he looks so panicked I think he just
realized the match is starting and he's
closing out of his chat and he's closing
out of the Stream
he's losing valuable time I guess
they're going to reset this yeah are you
playing Tyler yeah I'm playing I had to
get it ready for screen
oh
this is not what you expected that is
also not what I do I mean an advanced
French so it's like that if black plays
D5 but the problem with pushing your
Pawn so far in advance is that they get
stranded so like even a simple
developing move could put pressure on
this pawn and he just goes for the pawn
right away and it allows him to develop
his pieces more quickly it's a great
move by Tyler trying to trade and now he
could take take and trade the queens and
white loses oh but now it looks like the
French again it's a French but white
goes again yeah
I don't know what he's doing he's
distracted but I don't know by what I do
love this position where the Knight gets
the two little pawns and it looks like a
heart you see what I'm saying like the
Knight defends both Pawns in the middle
yeah yeah
like I like that too you need to
complete the heart though you can draw
it for us that's like a Lonely Heart can
you draw the heart for me you want to
draw a heart from where to where the
Knight I don't think they won't look
like a heart though no well
well kind of you can connect it on e4
oh C4 whoa oh aggressive loves pushing
pawns what is this called the cow I feel
like that's what I kept hearing while
watching this is the cow the cow doesn't
really go past the fourth rank though
yeah I think that was a little over I
feel like pushing my Pawn man no it's
not yeah but nobody nobody does that
it's not smart
do people refuse to push pawns because
they're not smart listen I don't mean
any disrespect whatsoever he was down 25
points of material like I feel like I I
feel like we don't know what anybody
does ever at the at this level you know
it's very unpredictable so Tyler
accidentally pre-moved
oh he doesn't know how to uh he doesn't
know how to unpremove you just click you
just is he playing on his phone what is
going on
I had no idea it looks like with the way
he's looking at the board but I saw this
happen to foosli where she accidentally
put in like six pre-moves and was
panicking but then it seemed like it was
on purpose she just didn't stop doing it
so I I don't know if my phone crashed oh
he is playing on his phone
yeah Dennis looks like he's ordering off
doordash right now wait Levy don't you
play on your phone too I they
exclusively play on my phone oh you
can't hear you you do yeah really yeah
wait why I moved now it's because I'm
usually playing like I'm just kind of
bad mood sometimes I play a lot of Chess
on my phone at night so bad actually
some top players they like to play on
their phone or on a tablet because it's
smaller so they can make moves more
quickly they don't have to drag the
mouse as far yeah but like it's more
accurate
replace this
you're good enough you can just use this
I'm just playing the game man all right
I once played a bullet match against
Carissa app who's like a really strong
American female player and she was
playing bullet on her tablet yeah yeah
like that was her thing that's insane
so is this a real opening has this been
played is it really not okay we've
all yeah this is not theoretical
although Tyler said you know this is not
what people do so he knew that they
exited his version of theory and now
they're here but the moves haven't been
bad there have been no blunders and in
this position why is all this space look
at these pawns just taking control of
important squares in the position
they're very Advanced that could be bad
if you can chisel at them but for now
they're just clamps there restricting
Black's pieces and if yeah see that's
such a loser did you say he is or yeah
like Queens
he's talking about how he hates Queens
all you do is pods
Pawn pushing
PPP that's what I'm talking about triple
P I love that Europe is so used to that
he doesn't even Flinch yeah no you can't
get out of this position unless you make
a pawn break at some point and uh it's
actually a closed position just like
last game but in the last game like we
were saying erob was down a piece
so he was struggling a lot this game
he's not down a piece and if Tyler
doesn't make a pawn break at some point
things are going to get really bad for
him he's just going to run out of oxygen
and erupt should go full Alpha zero
that's you know for our chess fans out
there pushing the H Pawn is a good
decision because black has not developed
you can actually continue advancing and
you'd like to push that pawn one square
further and kick this Knight out of its
place because let's go back here there's
zero development from black you're just
super cramped so I move to H4 I don't
think it will be played at least not
intentionally like that but that would
be a good idea to just pounce on your
opponent
quick have you ever heard of the saying
that pawns are The Souls of chess
that's fire no but I do believe that
they are the most valuable piece I
believe you're the soul of the Creator
economy really yeah have you heard of Mr
Beast you're you know he is the white
hot sauce
I'm one of Pluto's moons listen Pluto
doesn't even exist anymore according
by accident that move was intentional
I don't know if I can talk or I'll just
yell but um but my whole screen's
pre-moved you want me to not move yet no
you might just do it just is what it is
just go see what happens are you sure
close it up and open it back up
well no because I had to join but why
are you playing on your freaking phone
man he's playing sorry oh my God he's
playing on Safari on his phone that's
why it's not oh my God it's not what
wait these are three movements right
yeah like what is he doing so on your
phone you can only make one on the app
one pre-move at a time yes but on the
computer or on the mobile browser you
can make multiple premiums so he
accidentally pre-moved this bishop back
here after his Pawn to take this knife
and on the desktop you could just click
the board once yeah I don't think
the mobile browser has that
functionality he doesn't even know like
I moved my Pawn up one to take your
knight
fine then
step back great
what does he do why is he on the phone I
I don't know but e-rob's also confused
and that was a very you know Sports and
I think he's offered so many concessions
he said I'll I'll make my move I'm
telling you what I'm doing
so what just happened was he
accidentally pre-moved his Bishop back
and then
yeah nice who cares chess.com doesn't
work is that my fault yeah there's an
app yeah why are you on Safari or on
your phone yeah what about the computer
well she was using game one yeah plus 25
points of materials
did he did he switch to his phone
because he stalemate it on the computer
you know what this is and I'm gonna call
like I see it here because I've
done this plenty of times this is a
classic John all right so we call this
is an excuse in the making he realized
that e-rob was too much to handle he
needed and out so he goes to this mobile
site rather than using the app rather
than using the computer that his
camera's clearly showing he's trying to
have a pre-built excuse for this loss to
e-rob which is almost assured at this
point
I feel like Europe's King's a little bit
exposed that could well hurt him the
game
yeah that's not a bad move I was gonna
say you could oh my God
I accidentally lose like that but now
did he pre-move again he said he did no
no did he no wait me he might have what
uh okay that's a good move
okay
and he his victories throughout politics
have been down the G file like that has
been his success so yes if white were to
take this Pawn on F6 and he takes back
that's what would have happened then
this file opens up and the white king is
already there so why does it have a full
piece right he took a knight on H4 for
free but his King is a little bit
exposed and white being e-rob is down on
the clock by a minute
yeah he does like making batteries with
the queen in the rook and that's how he
ended up beating squeaks in like
terrible positions squeaks lost two
the exact same way that Robert described
down the G file
he's a one trick and he's bad at video
games
and he's going for it he's trying to
open up the G file love it I love that
move because what he's trying to do is
as Alison said break everything open and
go for the white king and I think that
players in POG Champs they get scared
like as soon as their King is a bit open
they feel like they're gonna get
checkmated and era looked completely
unfazed by capturing there but now's the
time for Tyler to take and then you're
gonna try to push this Pawn but
unfortunately with your king here as
soon as you push that pawn up the board
this queen can infiltrate and cause
problems to the black king what I'm
concerned about is how do you get the
queen over
his Queen his white Bishop they're
trapped by his own pieces he can't even
move his own Knight unless he moves it
back to the starting Square I guess he
could move it to the right maybe but
he seems like he's gonna make you in
five by the way on PC just like
did you say I'd meet you from on PC he'd
made him in five on PC okay so you're
right the excuses are coming out I'm
telling you why is he not on PC these
are questions that I wish I could answer
but I don't know how he said something
about for the stream but I don't know
what that really means in this context
also e-rob is fully focused but a good
first game of Defense after blundering a
piece so could this be a role reversal
from game one right in game one Tyler
won a full minor piece early on and here
irab has done that the same and now he's
gonna have to deliver a checkmate at
some point yeah the only fair result is
another stalemate yeah we want to go to
timer
we got we got Frank and sea dog sitting
in the other room starving because they
haven't delivered lunch and they've just
been here for hours staring at each
other making small talk man you know in
chess tournaments uh players show up
they like barely talk to each other
because it's very competitive very
cerebral game you gotta sit silently we
got Frank and Sea Dog just chatting in
the other room about our United Kingdom
like I don't know what they talk about
they talk about brexit or tea or
I don't know yeah they've been they've
been there for hours probably tired are
you a fortnum Masons guy you know you
got to go through your Brands I uh uh
twinnings I think the twinings is a
classic yeah it's affordable
what is Affordable are you calling me
poor no no no he didn't pay you so he
knows that is accurate that's not giving
you bills you're getting four to Masons
yeah yeah no there's like all these
stores that open up now that just do tea
like David's teased that's not sponsored
by the way but you can sponsor this
broadcast
you certainly can it ends in like two
hours not this you're right I meant this
you know you hit up offering and or
what's your thing called what I think
it's not working they're not listening
yeah if you make tea DM me there you go
get a boba sponsorship that'd be cool
now I want Boba what are you doing over
here are you guys delivering Boba yeah
now I'm hungry oh wow he's going for the
attack he's going for the attack
disregard the gigantic ugly question
mark because stockfish is a scumbag this
is a question mark like you mentioned
because the queen can now go to the back
rank cause a little chaos maybe get that
Rook
King might get checkmate in a few moves
that's the problem it's like the king
will only have one square so like if you
just get another check on top of that
the king will be in the mating net and
Black's pieces are just so cramped it's
very difficult
oh my god wow
great find great move on the board
exclamation point in chat yeah there's
only one legal move now and then
So the faster away that white will win
after King f8 is actually probably
taking with the bishop in my opinion
because then you'll get the knight in
and the Knight threatens a queen mate it
threatens this
I
I guess we're doing a little early clap
there I don't know what Tyler's thinking
about this is the only legal move there
is absolutely nothing to think about
here because whether you like it or not
you have to go there but on PC he would
have played this faster
I could see a queen blunder though like
I could see after a capture on G5 yeah
with the queen and then what you're
gonna do little man
no idea actually I don't but what do you
mean there's there's one move there is
one movement
I know why because on PC it shows your
king is in check and then
yes it's checked out that's why the game
is oh oh dude it's his app he's not even
on the app he's on the mobile browser
he's not even on the app and he's
blaming he's on just about the worst
playing experience like you are not
supposed to use
chess.com's website on the phone you're
supposed to use the app it's the
equivalent of playing League of Legends
on a VPN on Chinese
yep yep and let's not forget uh there
there are ways to yeah yeah wow and now
you gotta go here because if he goes
here it's Maiden won three different
ways actually one two and three if Rook
cheese mate with Knight would be so sick
he has to take it's the only move yeah
and then white has to take with the
bishop and not the queen because if you
take with the queen on that line The
Rook slides over with the pin and then
the game turns around
big moment did any of us predict era
would win it was Ludwig right yes I've
been saying it since day dot e-rob's a
good player and I think Tyler
although improved a lot
he just doesn't come up big in those
moments actually if I could just defend
him I said it was going to be 1-1 and
then it was going to be a tie break so
you know which is also wrong I well I
like you don't know Queen she's five
true because you have to take out the
bishop that you have to take with the
bishop Queen takes G5
great play by you're talking about
because then the The Rook would see the
Queen the queen is pinned to the king
yeah you would have to trade out a queen
for a rook that's right Rook G8 is still
a completely fine move because white
would need to do what's called a
Desperado because you're gonna lose your
queen if you take that Queen so you
might as well lose your queen for
something and then take this for free uh
I don't know if he's gonna find that he
might play Queen H6 check or he might
play Queen E6 and hang Queen G5 and
queen G2 I mean I don't know that's a
great move and uh this is very likely
now because you look around with the
queen and you go here here you go I
can't do anything whereas you should be
thinking of this move that's really the
move you should be thinking of because
you have to look for checks uh and a big
moment if he takes it's uh it's game on
again
uh if he goes here it's game over that
would be that would be really bad and I
think I think players don't like to
trade Queens like in POG Champs they
want to go for checkmate yeah so it is
likely he tries to find a way to keep
the Queens on the board I'm not sure if
he's thinking oh I'm up a whole Bishop
in this position I mean trade because
I'm taught to go down to the end game
but if he tries to keep the queen on the
board that's how you kind of lose this
position your king is open for what but
Bishop H6 is really interesting because
of
um
Tyler plays King to E7 then there is
Queen to G5 with that check and then if
the King goes back to F7 it's Checkmate
on G7
oh you saw it okay you saw the future
here yeah now I don't know if he because
the king is gonna go for a run because
you're not gonna do this because it's
bad so usually you think you're gonna
run now this move is very natural but
then the king runs there and then black
might win because black might win on the
G file so you have to do what I like to
call a boomerang technique where you you
check the king force him back and then
you go to the square that you want to go
to uh which is like that's hard to see
it's very hard it's very natural to go
forward or make a draw which that would
be wild if they made a three move
repetition that would be unbelievable I
don't think we've ever seen one in
pogchamp's history so far
yeah unless it's an accident right like
it would have to be an accident because
nobody would intentionally be bad for
you rob here clearly but nobody's
intentionally gone for like a draw to
win uh Queen G5 Queen G7 forcing the
king back from escaping is like a like
to see that in a puzzle you would need
to be around 1500 uh or you could sit
there for an hour but I mean to see it
in a couple of minutes to see going back
first
is very challenging on 1300 like yeah I
don't see it yeah yeah I mean oh wait he
just he said he sacrifices but
this makes the game a lot easier for era
for sure I mean he might not have
checkmating threads but at least he's up
a full rook and there's nothing on the G
file they can come down for a Checkmate
so and the King should Run for Cover
because actually if the King goes here
the most gangster-winning move of all
time would be king to H1 and tire it's
over man
[Laughter]
and then this that would be the quiet
move to the corner King is trying to
glitch off the map
[Music]
daughter doing like cartwheels in the
couch back there yeah yeah she's going
crazy
that's cool she's an athlete oh he's
he's gone running
sees Queen G5 check to just bring him
back he doesn't move that's still a good
move yep it's plus 30 14. and a half
nobody actually really knows what that
means like basically the computer's
saying if black got 14 points of
material somewhere it would be equal
I'll just take
actually now again like if you look for
this check the king is completely
crisscrossed like you can't do anything
Queen G5 ends the game because Knight F6
and you simplify everything and
but again the game is never really over
here if we remember the last race
there's too many pawns though right too
many Knights because like e-rob had a
clear plan after he lost he just pushed
all his pieces and and Tyler gladly took
them I don't think it's possible to do
the same and they're both getting low on
time uh we have Tyler with two minutes
erob with three anything good
advantage to the person who's using a
computer disadvantage to the person
using the very underused mobile Safari
browser oh my sweet oh that was a that
was a slick transition there that was I
thought it was going to be uh we're
looking at a great father and a great
champion
yep is he he's yeah okay I I still could
see this going wrong for I mean you're
doing everything right but his King is
still open what is that doing yeah
everything right because yeah but like
his uh ideas are good even if he hasn't
why do you have makeup all over your
face
there I said it somebody had to
well now his daughter is distracting him
rather than Tyler I also think Tyler's
the one who needs sympathy here he's the
one losing
he's losing he's down 40 seconds on the
clock he's playing on a mobile browser
I do think era was finding it difficult
to play the game though with his child I
don't know where to go
okay reasonable yeah developing his
pieces and how is Tyler going to handle
time trouble on the phone and how is he
gonna handle developing his pieces on C8
he knows how to pre-move yeah that is
true time troubles will not hurt him
there was one thing he knows how to do
on that phone it's make a lot of
pre-moves
and he's down under a minute and 30
seconds so he's gonna have to start
pre-moving he needs to get his pieces
developed this bishop here blocked him
from the night
he wants to get his Bishop out I guess
why are we all freaking out because he's
put his last piece on the back rank but
I think it's going to work out for him
because he can bring his night out and
his King out and then finally his Rook
can try to join the party but I like
what e-rob's doing he's throwing all his
pieces forward he's oh now the knight's
just trapped back there so that rook's
not getting out this is so difficult I
mean this he like oh I don't like that
though I wouldn't have locked it down
but it's still very difficult for black
but this is like the little brother big
brothering uh the big brother this is he
can't do oh there are there is a song
but yeah now Rook A7 and then move the
bishop out the way and hope that oh God
doesn't see the Queen's under attack
oh God that's cheese I love some cheese
that's a great idea
you can take and then like Queen B7 and
black position so bad you can't even do
anything about it oh he has not taken
any trades oh oh Bishop takes Bishop 96
and queen C7 is mate wait this is a
really good move
excellent stuff this might end the game
uh wait hold up I'm slow Bishop takes
the bishop then the Knight goes to C7
now that night here and then you could
take the queen but Queen C7 is just
making one ah it's the night in the
queen I think he would take the queen
yeah which is more than good enough
because there's no stalemates
accidentally Europe's got there actually
we're very close and there it is Knight
takes Pawn oh my goodness you see it do
you think he sees the mate oh
Could Happen black has no pawn moves
yeah but by night he'd have to get rid
of the night yes yes and he might be
doing it right this would be insane he
can't checkmate with just a queen
yeah not here he might push the pawn
it's a good move
once again Levy's King H1 would be
really good here just to bring that Rook
into the game oh this is scary yeah and
then here you also have your position is
good enough you have this Rook lift but
I feel like he might just run his Pawns
okay how do you get stalemated here he's
gonna take the Rook I think oh yeah
you know Rook here then E6 is Just
Killer wow this is crazy we're seeing
the uh
the younger brother storyline here
absolute demolition I mean aided by the
fact that Tyler did pre-move his Bishop
backwards when his Knight was under
attack but as you said love like it's
just the creating the narrative in
advance in in the event that he loses I
don't like how Tyler is not setting
himself up for a stalemate he might
accidentally
he's got 30 seconds by the way
he does have to move it would be sad to
win on time wins are always yeah the
lamest instead of multiple excuses yeah
it would be smart for him to let his
time sure perhaps yeah yeah well
sometimes it's not even real
it's not using this dog thing that
isn't supposed to be used
just don't go here oh my God that is an
excellent move
Rook C7 now only move how do you how do
you get still made it here
you can play another Pawn oh my God and
then there's going to be like some oh
you gotta
wow we don't have stalemate yet but it
it feels like we're getting closer
definitely closer
50 50 20 seconds on the clock it takes a
rogue yeah oh I was missing it he's
missing it but I mean the fact that he's
not taking it also avoids stalemate yep
black still has legal moves with every
piece which is important the pawns don't
count uh they haven't been able to move
for a while 10 seconds man yeah 10
seconds in the morning he's giving him a
warning e-rob has been a consummate
professional throughout this game takes
yup
oh and now just remove and pray oh now
I'm scared that he's gonna take the
night yeah he's taking all the pawns oh
my gosh he has to get the Rooks into the
play here wow finally wow yeah and now
the only way to stalemate is somehow
getting pinned
there's so many ways to like hang your
queen
you're getting kind of close yeah
yeah he has to move his Knight The King
has no legal moves anymore so he's gonna
try to move the kings are you gonna even
find it in 12 seconds he does okay Queen
D5 Queen eight is mate rookie eight is
made in one he's gonna find this he
might also play Queen D5 Knight goes
back oh my God oh my God oh my gosh
any pawn pushes a draw now oh my
goodness oh my God
this is
oh God
he has to go here and now Queen takes
but after Katie semi doesn't give a
check yes oh my god he has to give a
check don't move a pawn
come on I got it
this game sucks ass it's so bad
chess.com website dog chest this
game is so bad
you can't even play it on mobile
you can't even play it on mobile yes you
can just download it yeah there's an app
it's 2023 and we're still using Safari
browser he's yeah you gotta go check it
out there's an app he said it right
after as the reason yeah I know of
course I I know Tyler because I am Tyler
we both were the best at what we did he
was like one of the best League of
Legends players as an Entertainer I was
one of the best smash players right and
we've since fallen off a bit and we hide
our egos where we can okay I do the same
thing you know what it is it's failure
to notice where you need to improve but
hey I don't need to talk for him let's
let him talk for himself we got an
interview with our champion of the salty
sweet d-rob and tyler1 uh let's see if
we can get them on the screen how's it
going gentlemen
pile of websitechess.com
device tell me why tell me why
pre-moving's bud can I tell you why tell
me how dog because there's an app
you're using the Safari browser but it
doesn't work with the link because you
try to open the app store and they can't
invite you whatever it is what it is now
let's talk about Chess being a stalemate
bro who sits and it's like all right
this player has 15 pieces this player
has one it's a draw like what is the
logic behind you the game was made and
then the stone eight oh it's time to
update it
uh well first off congratulations
congrats you rob a huge win Ludwig thank
you for being the only one that believed
in me man since they died baby and you
are also coming out to the world's
greatest gamer contest and I think you
have a good chance of taking that one
too people are sleeping on here I'm
telling you they are it's the year of w
Rob it's it's not it's not a joke at
this point that's two back-to-back wins
over Tyler how do you feel
I feel good but it was expected uh I
gotta retired Tyler
from chess
is that right are you retiring from
chess Tyler
that's right I'm playing this every day
on stream for like the past month yeah
all you you're talented I
guys I gotta leave bye-bye all right
Tyler have a good one
he got retired from the game I mean
that's that's an emphatic statement from
era I think it's like an NFL retirement
I feel like he's gonna be back in 24
hours yeah yeah he's back next year
that must have felt good can you explain
why Tyler was not just on his computer
because I he's like he when he plays the
game a certain way he has to always play
it that way or it's not the same like
when he plays League of Legends he has
to have the exact mouth the exact
keyboard the exact headset and the exact
spot or he cannot play but like when
he's on stream playing in between League
games he's playing on computer right
yeah I don't know practicing he's been
practicing so much Offline that he
thought he'd be better that way he
thought that would be his comfort place
but it actually ended up being his
undoing because he made the obvious
blunder and I gotta say Hey you played
like a consummate professional because
you offered some take backs you told him
about the mistakes you did everything
you could uh and I think that's why you
deserve the championship all the more
don't
but we can't
I know now that when I go home he's
going to use that as an excuse every
single time yeah I called it out during
the broadcast he's got a list of excuses
you're never gonna be able to really
truly cherish this win but let me tell
you the people know the people know who
wants it up they're not confused
uh we'll appreciate you rob you have a
good rest of your day and uh I'll see
you in a couple weeks here uh yeah I'll
see a couple weeks man all right get
some training then see you man yep see
ya
all right that was it that was our salty
sweet match that's our champion e-rob
with the kid in the in the in the
picture there I mean he's doing it all
father champion
Fighters always say they feel the most
inspired after they have a child because
they feel like every time they're going
out they're fighting for their family so
it was a beautiful moment that was him
fighting his uncle or the child's Uncle
yeah next barbecue is going to be crazy
yeah I was gonna it's gonna go to fists
yeah I think it was help though that uh
Tyler staleman him because then he
probably was looking out for that in the
second game when he saw all the pieces
right he definitely slowed it down he
might have stalemated had that not
happened uh but that's it for our salty
sweet and we're coming back after just a
few minutes for our Championship bracket
finals it's Sea Dog versus Frank uh
we're gonna see who wins that one it's a
best of four that'll be after a quick
break uh we'll see in a bit goodbye see
you later go go off now see you in a bit
don't go anywhere
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to pog Champs five we're
here for our final match but first
I think we got a new guy on the couch
with us here Danny hello sir Danny chess
chief chief chess officer that's as made
up as it sounds is it binding like are
you do you have a contract not actually
okay that's why they gave me that title
so they could get rid of me in an
instant yeah officer you could be they
could just call you like like
accelerated janitor it's funny because
it's made up as it sounds when you go
around other Industries I've seen like
chief of basketball operations I mean
like what exactly are you operating with
the basketball itself all titles are
made up to inflation he goes Danny and
take control over the workers
there's more exciting things to talk
about which I'm hoping you can let the
people know about a little surprise yeah
you want so
Ludwig and I this has been a really good
relationship and so we're gonna take it
to the next level we're gonna go to
Paris
like you booked the hotel yet no I I
haven't honey I thought you were gonna
book for us well uh you want me to do
the announcement yeah I'll take it over
right Danny Danny's right uh you know
it's I hate the turn we take it to the
next level me and Daddy happen to be
going to Paris together at the same time
coincidentally in the same hotel room in
the same hotel room totally irrelevant
to the main thing that were there
that's because we're saving money that
has nothing to do with anything else
because we're Frugal we're trying to
help Ludwig pay back his debt I've been
watching like everyone else and I'm
nervous it's a big day and I need your
help to pay it off which is why
chess.com is incredibly excited to
announce chess clash
the greatest chess clash Universe
crossover you didn't even know was
happening
but you've heard of it you heard it
Clash you've heard of Chess and they are
making a uh a brand new uh event with
supercell it's your favorite creators
it's an epic series of Chess and Clash
challenges and a star-studded lineup
Alex gonna be there Gotham Chad's gonna
be there you know what's crazy they're
not flying me out to Paris so Ludwig
you're getting special treatment yeah
the Paris actually is irrelevant to this
that's just me and Danny getting ready
for each other
uh but there will be a big event you
guys can watch September 7th at 2PM
Eastern 11 p.m or 11 A.M Pacific uh
exclamation point clash in chat you can
see all the talent below sir tag I
believe a clash player sapnap orange
juice Anna uh and also everybody on the
couch yeah
but except for you guys who don't get to
go to Paris we go to Paris that's our
thing yeah I didn't I didn't know that
was happening up I would have accepted
an invitation to Paris do you speak
French I do well I mean everyone speaks
on poisson a little bit it doesn't
really come up in language
about it
uh but that is that's for another day
let's do another day get stay excited
for that but for today stay excited for
our next match up the championship
finals come on out
Frank is here and Sea Dog VA that's
literally Frank is here and that's
that's it he's here also yep what's up
hello how are you see here you go Frank
this is your microphone this is your
microphone Connor Connor fantastic you
look good I stole you'll fit yeah I got
the Crocs this is literally your chest
boxing fan this is
well this is my suit but is that my suit
no this is one this is actually my one I
have a similar one you have a solaro
suit I did store your Crocs there thank
you yeah it looks good with a nice Croc
crop gibbet yeah uh Frank does this
intimidate you at all uh no
all right Connor I mean I guess this
plant backfired immensely I I just
wanted to feel great so I play great
that's kind of what I was thinking feel
great play great uh Frank what's your
play going into this matchup uh win that
was the main plans
you are good you are um you are many
people's favorite coming into this
matchup you are a protege an apprentice
of of Mr Gotham tress here
what are your expectations going in is
it all Levy's fault if you lose
is it all your success if you win what
are you thinking
um well I don't want to not not all
Gotham's fault if I lose because I'm a
free man with free will so it'll be my
fault if I lose but um if I win then I
win and I get all the money
twenty thousand dollars what do you want
to do with the twenty thousand
um probably
uh you buy my family a holiday ah to
like a country to Paris a country he
hasn't gone that far right let's just
focus on the holiday yeah uh crash that
honeymoon yeah Crush our honeymoon in
Paris Connor what do you do if you win
the 20K I can reimburse the flight here
no we I paid for the flight I gave the
money it's that 365. it's coming listen
I just want to win because I'm
competitive I don't the money is
meaningless to me it's just victory
that's all that matters can I have it if
you win
meaningless you know I I just want to
Metaphor no no you can't get the money
well okay you guys are doing it best of
four you've proved you two are the best
of the entire pool of 16 competitors
coming into this you've beaten a lot of
impressive players along the way now I
want to ask you Frank you are renowned
for talking every thought out loud while
you play this is an in-person event you
were playing over the board how does
that change how you operate are you
going to keep talking what's the Thought
um nothing I'm just gonna go how I go
and but maybe not speak out every
thought because that is quite stupid and
they'll just lose me the game in
hindsight so gonna keep on talking
though I want to keep on
keep keep that going
oh I'll be laughing too much to focus
yeah do you think this will get in your
head a bit I've been a bit distracting
absolutely
um yeah you're a very like classic like
what you think of with the chess player
because you listen to classical music
you say almost no words except for
occasional
I like thinking noises I think it it
makes you seem like you're actually
thinking and a lot of the time like man
I should just move my Bishop one square
or something I don't know a lot of the
time I'm not really sure what I'm doing
all right well hey gentlemen it is uh
off to YouTube uh to do the champion
bracket matchup for that trophy right
there and twenty thousand dollars it's
so big you've both flown across
different ponds to get here the Pacific
and the Atlantic to come together in La
uh so go off let's go make this happen
all right God speak to you both good
luck I'll take this from you good luck
gentlemen you got to get out of here
we're gonna watch you we want to watch
you play
it's a cool trophy huh don't sit on it
oh man uh predictions I guess let's wait
let's let's let them let's let them
scare you out of here
[Music]
okay they're out they're out what do we
think what do we think about this
matchup you want me to start yeah I
think straight up
Sea Dog VA is going to 3-0 Frank is here
it's going to be the fastest finals ever
wow wow wow do we have a time stamp of
how many minutes the consolation final
was no but I do have a game that you
still made it that I just looked up in a
slack chat not too long ago was I wasn't
let's do it I want to see it I want to
see it because that was that was
definitely have you really never still
made it anything I've seen the clip
it was a GM yeah 2.7 seconds please
definitely still but nowadays you could
just say things you know you could save
things it goes online
yeah
I do a bit of Googling
video I want you guys to mull on your
predictions then because you guys seem a
little a little shy about them okay
check out this video I want to come
right back I want a firm prediction all
right let's go we'll be right back
you know I'm glad it was Frank I feel
like Frank deserves to be here in the
final uh but that's about as far as he's
going to get unfortunately because
tomorrow it's all gonna it's all gonna
end for him I'm gonna plan like a dog
mentally I'm gonna be that I'm gonna go
woof woof not actually but like I'm
gonna want to do that theoretically uh
Frank is very fast Frank uh it's almost
too fast at times
um but never really tends to have time
travel because of it which I always do
um he has some good ideas but often just
I find that when I was playing him he
would just do one blunder that I was
able to capitalize on well
um his strengths he doesn't blunder
pieces that's a big strength I think he
doesn't like Bishops so I might use a
lot of Bishops so before I don't like
Bishops that much but I just need to use
them a lot I'm sure he's researched my
opening and I'm not going to change my
opening I'm gonna do the exact same
thing I've been doing and I'm gonna beat
him using the exact same opening that
I've used on everyone else Frank you've
done very well to get here but in my
mind this is a battle between Wales and
England and Wales has got to win this
one I'm sorry can I be honest don't
really have much against Welsh people so
about like a thousand years ago England
took over Wales and they promised that
they would give us a king if if we
joined up with them and then we joined
up with them they didn't give us a king
and we've been pissed off about it ever
since those are like millennials okay I
mean if we're going that far back I have
hatred I have much hatred I'm gonna want
to win Frank you're a really nice guy
it's been great meeting you but uh
unfortunately I'm gonna put you in the
dirt tomorrow kind of better watch out
because I'm I'm winning it for England
I'm winning it for England and Wales are
going down
a classic rivalry England versus Wales I
like how Frank learned about it and then
instantly was on England's side with
zero research that was productive I feel
like that was you know that was like a
bait production was like you said this
what do you think about that the thing
yeah they got some good sound bites I uh
centuries-old rivalry now on the stage
in a new way with less death than murder
let's go yeah but still perhaps a
bloodbath and I think we're jumping into
it yep all right on the couch right now
predictions rapid fire starting with you
two and a half to one for Sea Dog that's
not possible it isn't possible but I
respect that you think it is two and a
half to one is not a score line no it is
because it could be one and a half to
one and then Sea Dog wins the last one
oh I know it's the best out of it's the
best before
well it still works because it'd be I'm
not smart enough for the numbers just
who you think will win Sea Dog Sea Dog
I'm you know Daddy's vote Sea Dog and
double overtime Sea Dog double overtime
that's what Danny told me I think I
think Frank takes it in game four you're
so biased do you believe it though I
mean listen you're you're in a
relationship with one of the players
I mean you know I I have uh I I
commentated Frank's very first chess
match that he did uh live on a broadcast
we had 20 000 live viewers who made it
from Tick Tock I mean like real people
it wasn't Bots it wasn't embedded
anywhere and Frank Frank going for akaro
Khan courtesy of the Gotham School of
Chess so talk to me about the opening
you've taught Frank in the past are you
actively coaching him for POG Champs not
I mean I I wouldn't say actively but we
had a couple of training sessions
together uh we knew that Sea Dog was
gonna play The King's Pawn and Frank
basically would play about three moves
every game and improvise I have no idea
how he got to around 950 doing that uh
but I was like Frank you're gonna need
something a bit more solid and I
actually predicted Conor would play the
advanced variation after looking at his
games but he seems to be just trading in
the center developing normally uh this
is the best option for a karaoke player
because just bring your Knights out
Bishops everything but Frank is naughty
uh left on his own he will burn a house
down so so far so good so far he has not
found the matches uh and he has to be
solid he has he has to be good and um
the thing is every move the chance that
he makes a big mistake compared to Sea
Dog is higher so he just has to behave
himself and good things might happen
speaking of Behaving himself he looks
like he's having a really hard time not
thinking aloud still very expressive
just no thoughts out loud
incredibly expressive I would argue to a
fault right because he is mapped out
lines that he is planning to do in games
while streaming POG Champs and if he
hints at that with his space I think
Conor is you know he's an adult enough
to read that and be like oh there's
probably something I should be aware of
here what if he's tricking him do you
think Frank has that double mind game
yeah he's got that dog I think he does
all right Frank he lets people believe
that you know take him seriously he's
just joking about but he can play chess
like he's improved a lot and even he
didn't hit the clock on his first move
and he's like oh and he wasn't hitting
the clock yesterday but I think he
learned that it's new to him but I do
think he embellishes a bit and that
could play his favor I see and sea dog
thinks more than Nobel winners
like he loves to think yeah and then he
loves to push upon one square
so so you're saying he's thinking but
the thoughts ain't doing much for him
yeah and also Knight to C3 is right
that's an inaccurate move in an exchange
coricon because that Knight actually
puts no pressure on the center now uh
Frank forgot to bring out his light
scored Bishop
before blocking it in the center but
it's fine because if he just develops
the knights and then brings the dark
squared Bishop out and castles like the
good thing about the Karo Khan is it's
rock solid so even if a person has bad
habits in the early stage of the game
they uh they'll be fine if he remembers
to develop everything and again sort of
behave himself but
we don't know and uh he keeps hovering
and they're talking to each other and I
think he has brought out Knight to F6
seems like it oh okay that's also fun
yeah his facial reactions are just
awesome they're great he's just fun to
look at more than the game half the time
I will say Conor going into this his
biggest concern was blundering he said
that yeah sorry yeah yeah the start of
the game because what he likes to do is
play chess puzzles he's like 1900 rated
in Puzzles and when you play puzzles
it's like ah just look for a check and
then the moves will kind of present
themselves that's okay but if you look
for a check in a game sometimes there's
no moves to present themselves you've
just found they check and put yourself
in a worse position and I think that's
his concern is going for a non-existent
tactic
oh I see oh yeah Frank has this uh Frank
has this habit where he says ooh after
every move
uh okay that's an interesting way of
developing I don't think it's oh Frank
is doing the development that you're
supposed to do in the advanced Karo Khan
you're supposed to zigzag because in an
advanced caracon there's a pawn here so
you can't do that
uh Frank is lucky that this is
completely fine but the dangerous thing
about doing this is the Knight is
supposed to guard that pawn when you
Castle so by doing it this way the king
upon castling will be the only thing
guarding these squares and CDOT could
just go here and here
and it could get real bad uh but Conor
doesn't always play that barbarically
like he will develop pieces and improve
his position and maybe he doesn't just
go for the kill but this is a this is a
championship level position for game one
of the finals
it's not a tricky position yet either so
I don't see tactics off the bat but
hopefully we'll get there it's going to
be a little bit challenging for Frank to
figure out how to develop the rest of
his pieces especially that Bishop on C8
because he's kind of Trapped behind his
white pawns uh that you see that see Sea
Dog just thought for a minute move the
pawn one square
yeah that move doesn't make a single bit
of sense but he but he again every move
the chance of him making a fatal mistake
is quite low and now Robert like we're
you know I I showed this right and these
different ideas but his Bishop is here
does Connor I really wish Franco's here
and it's going to be a big moment does
Connor just take for the sake of taking
because the bishop has been there or
will he back up and go that's kind of a
soft spot so maybe I can create
something over there he's more likely
Retreat I think than most players in POG
Champs because he's so worried about
blundering or making the wrong decision
and it's not the best mindset to be in
because sometimes he needs to go on the
offensive yeah so I need to go for the
enemy King but other times he does
blunder check a lot and oftentimes the
POG Champs games are decided as we saw
uh in previous matches just one mistake
loses the game on the spot and I just
don't think that Conor does that yeah
yeah I think his strategy has been make
as safe of moves as possible wait for
the mistake to present itself and then
take advantage and then win with
Advantage because that's much easier to
do
and hear it and the position looks
imposing for white but what's funny is
that the quality of the development is
actually much in Black's favor none of
these Bishops are actually exerting any
sort of real meaningful pressure and the
Knight has no role in the game and this
Knight can't go there so it's not just
like my pieces are out and I did what I
had to do it's like my pieces are out
what are their next moves and actually
white is running out of them much faster
because black still can go excuse me
here here bring the Rooks attack the
bishop attack the other Bishop like this
Knight can go here once the queen moves
or now because it's bog Champs and you
would lose the queen so Black's future
prospects are much stronger depending on
what he does now I think if Frank
doesn't blunder he can win yeah I think
it's it and he played the top computer
move by the way but for a human Pawn to
F6 is bad because it weakens the e-pawn
but the computer thinks it's a good move
guys because something like this in the
future right that's sort of the point
but he blocks the PIN for now
but he might play it too soon right
that's the downside of trying to break
you had this beautiful Pawn chain and a
pawn chain is only as strong as its base
Pawn the pawn F7 was great but if you
play E5 and this capture happened you
may lose this Pawn in the center they're
gonna be plenty of tactics here you have
to calculate a lot I think a safer move
would be one like Knight to F5 just
developing your knight even further
advancing it but I could see Franklin
I'm gonna strike let's go with that pawn
push yeah yeah who do you guys think is
stronger in Middle gameplay I think you
just did that by the way yep yeah wow
there it is there it is who's stronger
in Middle game yeah oh that's a great
question I think Connor right because
it's got to be the higher rate of player
he makes safer moves yeah but he's not
that much higher rated like Frank is now
9.50 and Conor just over a thousand so I
feel like within 100. yeah Frank is on
the upswing and I don't know you're good
friends of Connor you play chess them a
bunch like oh how seriously has he been
taking this
Bishop takes us that's a really bad move
Frank is winning if he takes with the
pawn solidifying his Center like he's
actually just winning
I wouldn't go that far but he has a very
nice no I know I know but like wow he
doesn't know he's minus two but the
point is that now all of White's
pressure is completely gone he will
never ever win that pawn the winning
idea there after E5 was to take that was
the point and then if and then you would
win this because the queen opens up that
was what Robert was showing uh but this
is really this is really actually really
bad yeah for what for white I played
Conor I think twice since he's been here
over the board and both times I like won
something in the in the middle game and
like just he blundered something I got a
fork whatever it is uh but what he's
really good at is like persisting like
he stuck through he had zero
inclinations of resigning and in one
game he ended up getting a draw through
like a very long end game and the other
game I ended up barely winning but like
if he's down in a bad position he he
plays much better in the end game than
like most people at his raiding one he's
down a minute and a half right now is
bad he has no active plan nope
everything that Frank has done has been
good like he made that mistake there was
an accuracy putting the pawn up he might
have lost some Pawn but the idea was
good I just feel like Conor hasn't had a
steady stream of ideas here he's kind of
making one-off moves every single turn
well it's also very much harder for
white to find plans here since all of
his pieces like Levy was saying earlier
already seem like they're on their best
Square so I guess that's why he's just
going for the pawn pushes now whoa yeah
and and if you're gonna attack somebody
in chess you want to keep the center
closed taking would have been a terrible
move because it would have just allowed
every white piece to flow through the
center now this Knight is going to go
back Frank could Avalanche how do you
stop it I don't think you can and it's
instructive that in chess we often
attack in the direction of our pawns yes
the white king is here but sometimes
even if the king isn't outside the board
we have pawns aiming in this direction
let's not allow another one to join the
party that looks very strong he can
simply play Queen C7 which is a good
move in many different caracon positions
we saw cutie Cinderella drop this Pawn
with check earlier in the day so he has
options Bishop Ace all of these are
reasonable and strong moves yeah and
actually that's like a that's like a
great move because when the root goes
here it's dead and it it stops defending
the king like Sea Dog's not gonna go
here he's probably not going to retreat
he's just gonna kind of play the you
know the simple Rook move and now the
quality of the bishop move versus The
Rook move is is just night and day did
you hear Frank that you saw it oh no he
was like upset that Connor a very
obvious Bishop attack
yeah let's see if Frank uh continues
playing toward the pawns toward the
space Advantage because again per move
the chance of sea dog making an
inaccuracy that's fatal is lower so
what's Frank's move here not a bad move
right not a bad move but Pawn to F5
leading the charge with the uh what the
pawns would have been better but still
very difficult for Sea Dog so you all
are being like very Savant chess players
talking about how bad it is it's equal
in pieces do you think the players know
that they have an advantage because that
matters almost as much as having an
advantage I think Sea Dog
thinks he's in a bad situation that
could just be personality though like he
might always think he's in a bad
situation he's British right he's not
British Frank's British they're both
British he's Welsh I guess yeah it's
British yeah come on man yeah it's all
parts of the United confusing like your
English but yeah yeah he's not English
he's British yeah now I I think Frank
sees moves like this and goes oh my God
I'm under attack like I don't know what
his confidence level is but Knight takes
and F5 F4 is is actually just lights out
these nights are super stuck the space
advantages really cutting the
circulation here but Frank might think
oh I'm under attack but he's not I mean
the queen can't beat up a fortified
Fortress of pieces uh but if he goes
like Knight to H6 for example people
unders okay he takes
good move that's completely fine
I feel like Frank is doesn't realize his
position is better I think he does right
because he I mean he's saying that's
fine if he finds that 5 F4 he could very
well be on his way to winning this he's
doing it but he's also letting out size
of relief you know he's a little worried
this is where we discover Frank's been
like a secret 2300 the whole time I was
telling you I really believe that he
kind of like allows his opponents to
think oh he's not that serious he's
joking around a bunch even this movie
yeah wow that that's it's not the best
evaluation bar we see it go down a bit
he still has a huge he's bringing his
pieces towards the action oh my God a
backwards bishop move rerouting and it's
not bad but you know the better thing
would have been to step on the gas but
this is fine you know this is you took a
wrong you passed the exit on the highway
you're still gonna get there like 10
minutes later yeah you're talking about
how Frank might secretly be great or
whatever I think he just comes alive
when the lights are on because he lost
yesterday in a secret like show match
against virtual
yeah he also lost him this morning yes
uh they they were playing like to warm
up the board and make sure make sure it
functions and everything the the way you
do this is you kind of ask yourself this
question how do I activate my queen
without moving it
and the answer is this that's the door
and then and then out of the door come
comes the dragon and then it's you got
some phrases on you yeah you know and
then all of this good stuff and white
can't do a damn thing like whites just
can't move any pieces yeah can't he also
just if he doesn't see the pawn push
like Bishop F4 because that Rook has
nowhere to go yeah the bishop yeah
straight up by the way it's just trapped
yeah because this bishop covers the H3
Square so he can win material on the
spot I F5 is a fantastic you're just
going full steam ahead for the attack
you might Checkmate this King and
trapped The Rook with a pawn but Bishop
F4 will net him some material too
this is insane Conor might lose
yeah yeah uh this is why I wanted Frank
to pick up the Karo Khan because I was
actually I thought the position is easy
enough to play that just you know on an
open field without both players knowing
exactly the best plans that something
like this was possible but see now is
the critical moment like we we got here
he did all the work and what did he play
did he play what did he play
okay his position is so good he can
afford to do whatever he wants he did a
counter move but thought for two minutes
they moved upon yeah I mean he was like
doing construction in the living room
and just like went out the side door and
just kind of left it there he's got to
come back and finish the construction
hopefully and and Connor has a big
moment here because his Pawn's under
attack so he should do it he should push
it rather than taking and I think he
just did that and the reason why that's
so strong yeah is now Black's Pawn
structure I said it before a pawn chain
is only as strong as base Pawn the base
Pawn's on C6 once you remove that D5 is
easy to attack in fact after Pawn digs
B5 maybe Queen takes B5 maybe Knight
takes D5 right away the point is that
the center might collapse for black yeah
I'm not surprised he saw it as pushing
puns is his specialty did Frank also
push oh so now now it's now
unfortunately it's back to equal but
it's only back to equal if Knight takes
and then F5 still is played the computer
still evaluates the position is so good
for black that this attack is very
significant but if Frank doesn't see
that
it could get really bad but Sea Dog
might play here and then it's right back
to black being the one calling the shots
if Knight takes Aina even if the bishop
takes checks the king and then Queen
takes yes there is this very nice
discovered attack but at that point
white would take here and here and then
you're just in a position where black
has lost the pawn chain black has lost
all the attacking chances and white has
a pass Pawn so a lot went wrong but Sea
Dog has less than three minutes yeah I
was talking to him earlier and he was
saying how he much prefers to take his
time because he feels like even if he
gets to one minute in the end game
that's enough for him and that was a
that was a pretty big mistake because
now Frank will take with the bishop and
his Queen will defend the center pawn
and the bishop will hit the Rook which
might be forced to go here and then for
instance Bishop D4
and maybe F5 F4 again yeah he might be
forced into finding F5 F4 and this is a
big moment for O'Connor he's probably
going to move his Rook but the best move
is probably to actually allow black to
take by bringing the Knight forward
there are a lot of weak squares Rook G3
we knew that was going to happen he's
also staring at the black king but now
is the time for Frank push yourself
I feel like if you miss it for three
turns four turns in a row you're never
gonna see it and yeah Frank Frank is
covering his Bishop he's also been
focusing mostly on the queen side of the
board and I think one of Frank's
weaknesses throughout pogchamps has been
that he sometimes tunnels and can come
to a new plan and what he has to realize
is yeah I heard him say the word cheeky
that the cheeky counter is that one he
can't touch his Center puns so he's
moving the bishop okay he attacks The
Rook again that's fine
um I mean we could we could have a
repetition here actually Rook E3 but
then there's you know there there's a
crazy moment that can happen here where
the Rook goes back and then there's a
repetition there's another crazy moment
which is rookie three Pawn to D4
Conor finds Queen C4 check picks this up
but loses to a discovered attack on the
queen
oh my goodness this is possible but D4
Conor might find Queen C4 forcing the
king to move Queen takes pawn and then
this Haymaker Queen takes Queen Frank's
face he's seeing it I I he cannot be
seeing it right no there is no chance he
sees the fork which looks like it's
winning then it's going to be a huge
plot twist because Conor has a check and
another plot twist is it a win if you do
it in reverse AKA if you do the bishop
check now no he he traps The Rook yeah
he found that wow and and this is gonna
be a really difficult moment for Connor
he's like he's playing at home yeah you
see Frank he's celebrating yeah look at
that face he just has a smug smile this
is a huge moment because I actually
truly deep down think that even though
Connor is like a cautious player and
he's a humble man uh he he did consider
himself like he was going to sit down
and win three games oh yeah and uh this
is a huge wake-up call and it could be
really unwelcome he's he sacrificed the
night but oh wait yeah no and just Queen
takes Queen takes nice free yeah I think
he takes Knight he's hoping I assume
that he takes the bishop and then maybe
the queen can get involved with like a
discover check
the night yeah but the thing is Queen
takes and you're attacking this Knight
Through The Rook so too many of whites
pieces are loose 1965 he's just trying
to muddy the waters but you can see
Conor's time under two minutes and he's
he might just take it you hear Frank
maybe he's hoping that Frank takes the
rook and then he recaptures with his
Knight I think I think Frank has the
self-control to take the Knight it's
like again you play enough hundreds of
games you go I've been here before if I
grab the Rook he's gonna bring the
Knight back well if he doesn't it's a
huge mistake but I think Frank's gonna
grab the Knight and go I don't see what
he's trying to do yeah yeah he does he
doesn't have enough respect for Connor's
game plan to believe that there's some
trick that he doesn't see yeah and now
Rook takes pawn and and you lose the
second night Connor's smiling because
he's going what the hell is going on I
was just supposed to you know sit down
and win but now it's game on and
sometimes that's what it takes sometimes
it takes one punch to the chin and go oh
my God we're in a you know you would
know because you slapped each other oh
yeah and he has a strong slap
I'll tell you what I do not want to
fight him again and we do not want to
see him slap his opponent that would not
be you know what happens if a fight
breaks out
[Music]
then British law applies
um Sea Dog
took and uh bishop or queen takes Knight
well Queen takes is actually kind of
interesting because if the queen takes
here then that check that we've been
talking about with the White Queen will
hit the king here and also hit the
bishop on F4 so you can get that piece
back so Bishop takes would be uh precise
you can also and he takes of it that way
and Bishop B7 happening next oh here
there's also Rook D1 so it does have
counter play and then there's rookie
eight check oh my God oh my God there is
rookie eight check and if you take you
walk into checkmate and if you don't
take by playing King F7 you probably win
the game
this is so sick he might lose this game
up two Bishops because he just Auto
Pilots to take
that would be heartbreak time is low on
the clock for each of these guys under
two minutes and and you know this yeah
like Alexander said Bishop B7 is an
All-Star move danger levels x-ray what
did he play I think he did it on the
board oh he is not winning he is not
winning if he goes here apparently seven
yeah but then King G6 oh you lose the
rock oh oh wait wait wait he
oh he just took is he going rookie eight
check anyway is that the oh my goodness
but then Frank has the and he's done it
oh my God so the issue is if he takes he
cannot take it he has a hundred seconds
to play it's a 50 50. rookie eight Queen
E8 is game over
he might just realize that he has to
move the king
process of elimination that's something
we teach people when they're improving
his chest stories he has no choice here
you take your mated
oh my God
oh no move your king no definitely not
move your king Frank I'm biased like
don't care do not take the Rook okay oh
my goodness
he's doing it I think Cross of
elimination he has to he has to or he
just he was ready to lose
oh my God he's got a minute I'm gonna
lose my mind
less than a minute 58 seconds on the
clock
[Applause]
wow and he makes the ticket
Connor just leaves mate in one on the
board oh my goodness back it up back it
up replay Queen takes E8 is check and
mate the King has no Escape here
oh my God instead he Auto Pilots Queen
takes Queen which seemed like a freeze
but look two Rooks and a bishop okay
still winning this game
but he might not have enough time to
find the win nobody has any time to find
the win Connor didn't even press the
clock come on foreign
[Music]
move and and the queen is the favorite
uh it is impossible at low ELO to play
against the Queen the Queen's gonna
Feast on the pawns and uh Conor only has
one major piece that he has to move now
Queen takes Pawn he's just gonna push
those pawns and and I okay we have a
check
and King moves oh my God this game two
huge wins just left on the board by
Frank and Connor and this the problem
with the Rooks is they need to team up
and you get them both on the second Rank
and then it's Devastation on the first
rank you're actually not threatening
anything one check the king runs away
and that's it yeah yeah and it's an
equal position because there's
space that's fine now Conor's gonna go
B6 probably uh and then Frank's gotta
get in here exactly what Robert said you
just gotta you gotta get to this King
you don't have to get to the king there
which is very likely to happen but then
after that you have Rook G1
which also might happen I think we're
going to get a king walk over here and a
pawn promotion potentially and this is
just chaos
and black has only 20 seconds right now
Conor has 44 himself and he did push the
pawn and and and and frankly Frank Blaze
Rook to eat too wow oh my God great
movement Pawn F3 does not work because
there's a pin along the second rank yeah
yeah and Sea Dog might play Queen C5
what did he played oh my god oh he's
gone Rook D2 is winning now but Frank
might also take and he's taken good
enough Rook takes G2 next we'll be
checking yes Conor's got a wrong with
the king oh he's trying to promote oh
Connor might see it he's hovering he's
looking
it's mate he has he has he's pressed the
clock it's over Frank wins game one oh
my goodness
oh my goodness
wow he played very well I I think
he was congrats that
oh my goodness
wow I wish I could telecommunicate to
these players and they'll find out soon
I'm sure
they both had made you know that Conor
had a maiden one on the board at a
certain point he doesn't know that right
now he's sitting there thinking like I I
was from the get-go is the
opening he played super well I had no
opportunities he had a huge one
it's very tough to say because he won
the queen he might still think he made a
good comeback like yeah of course main
one is huge but right he's still gonna
think I won this queen it was it was a
good chance there and then wow totally
Miss Rook takes pawn and that's what
happens wow it's definitely gonna rattle
him but he has to be confident after
beating Frank you said it was gonna be
three seconds
I didn't know your guy had that 183 you
want to do it no I don't want
oh man well let's take a look at some of
the highlights from that game uh it was
a good game one uh and and Connor said
to me said if he loses one game he's
nervous then it'll rattle him and he'll
lose the rest of the game
oh come on bro my guy can totally
destroy your gun we'll see it after the
break though
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
foreign
okay
thank you
foreign
we are back for our final battle of the
evening POG Champs five Championship
bracket Nemo is joining us here and
Andrea has swapped out for Hess
what are your thoughts on that previous
game you watch it you get a good eye on
it that was insane we were just watching
it over there in the cafeteria and
everybody was like going like oh oh like
it was like we were watching a soccer
game it was like
exactly and if you were one move behind
if you just heard one part of it you'll
be like oh Frank's winning and then you
realize Connor has Checkmate in one and
then the next second all of a sudden
it's two Rooks on a bishop and it's like
what is happening here what was the how
did you guys feel about those exchange
of tactics in the middle
oh I mean I I was just sitting there not
understanding what was truly happening
but when I see the eval bar flying up
and down
that's a that's not a good thing it
shouldn't be happening in chess matches
chess matches are usually more boring
than that no that was uh unbelievably
exciting performance from the players
but also super clutch by Frank because
he like it's much easier to play with a
queen yeah so Sea Dog was just gonna
push his pawns take everything and then
Frank found this Rook to the second
ranked move
and he does yeah it's a deserved win
yeah Frank has the underdog narrative on
him and even in chess.com chat only 25
of people thought Frank was going to win
yeah
this is your this is your student you
said he was going to lose three zeros I
don't even wanna this is my dog but this
is your student you are very prideful
about your student yeah well if he lost
then I would be like you know we only
trained like once or twice hell yeah
like oh yeah for sure you okay you have
trained a couple of people for bog
Champs what is the thought process when
they when they lose what do you tell
them how do you make them feel better or
prep them for another game do you send
them an encouraging word honestly yeah I
just told them to know worry about it
you know because sometimes you're just
losing chess and there's not much you
can do about it sometimes people just
have a bad move sometimes people just
have a bad day look if you lose in chess
it's not the end of the world and it's
definitely not the end of the world here
for Connor because there's three more
games and anything can still happen all
right I just messaged Connor I said it's
okay you
a good coaching tactic taught to me by
Nemo uh but before we jump into our
second match let's first take a look at
a video from one of these players on how
they feel about this matchup
uh I started playing chess from like
when I was very young actually as far as
I can remember I started playing chess I
used to play competitively when I was
like 11 12. I used to play for the Wales
team played a bunch throughout my early
childhood and then just kind of stopped
I only recently got back into it because
of all these tournaments that I keep
getting dragged into and hopefully I can
win one this time
I'd say my chess play is very
instinctual mixed with using the time
almost at a disadvantage sometimes to
try and make sure that my instincts are
right A lot of the time that I end up
voice thing is just me confirming that I
was right or I think I was right
um but I like to think that I play quite
aggressively I don't like to defend much
I like to attack as most chess players
do I think I spot really good ideas
sometimes but I just really struggle to
kind of really commit to it and believe
myself that it's a good idea time time's
definitely my weakness I definitely take
too much time because I have been in
this situation many times where I've
been in the chess competition the
choking Factor cannot be understated if
you choke in the chess match everyone
will remember this everybody will bring
it up to you that's why my name is choke
dog VA because of my previous jokes and
chess tournaments I I mean I started
playing chess from Over the board so
it'll feel like a nice return to form so
I'm not worried about it it'll be fine
so I'm very cautious which leads me to
spending a little more time than I
should on moves I was low on time and
came back
why does everyone want to draw in this
competition am I going to use you to
accept your loss
God damn it Connor why are you why are
you making this so hard yeah
game one was uh saikuno which I it's I
mean it was a massacre that's not a game
his chess game was lacking severely all
right so I'm watching a clip of me it's
like here now oh yeah
yeah I would not take it so maybe he'll
accept I would not take a drill uh
played Jarvis where I lost the game
which uh JavaScript played very well and
I also felt like I just didn't deliver
but we managed to win that game too and
then I played Frank and I'd like to
think I beat him pretty decisively 2-0
made it all the way to the quarterfinals
against sapnap which is probably the
hardest game I've had uh where it went
to tie Breakers nail-biting finish but
managed to somehow get the win uh and
then I played Alex uh Alex was scary but
managed to beat him the low light
definitely was getting on percentage by
Jarvis I haven't forgot that you
Jarvis but my highlight was getting to
on passant uh against Alex that was by
far the Highlight getting on passanteed
is it's just like getting hit in the
balls in the middle of a chess match
literally it just feels it feels unfair
and then getting to do it on someone
else oh it's so cathartic uh maybe this
is like hubris talking but I don't need
a coach they need a coach to beat me but
I I think I'm good without it I think I
just got the better game I've always
wanted to be in POG Champs and this one
kind of stuck up on
um I didn't expect to win I didn't
expect to do much that's why I didn't
practice I didn't do anything and
somehow I'm here in the finals and when
everyone's telling me I'm the favorite I
was like what how I just showed up I
think you'll probably see
some of the best and worst play for me
I've taught a lot of I mean I have
to win this is embarrassing if I don't
win it's gonna look terrible
it does look terrible yeah he uh he lost
his first game he's somewhere deep in
his mind Palace but he's talked a lot of
he's known as the favorite coming
into this and he's down one game to
Frank and we are entering game two
I don't know how do you guys feel what
do you guys think he he talked some
but he also half the sentences where I
don't have a coach like why are you
expecting me to be the favorite why are
you uh it's a nice balance because you
never know
you never know if he's the villain or or
what
he's not great at being a heel because
he's too nice of a guy but he
technically is the heel here right like
Frank is the hero because he is this
passionate chatty chap who's who's up
1-0 and two games away from being our
POG Champs five Champion they're
discussing what Frank should play versus
Sea Dog's Sicilian Defense I know what
Frank should play elephant that is what
we discussed and that is what he goes
for but of course yeah it's the easiest
thing to play against the Sicilians the
only one I know so I'm glad that it
happened yep and uh it gives you a
really easy game and that was just my
goal Frank get an easy position oh wait
me and Connor played this exact position
last night okay we played the alapin uh
and it ended up somehow getting super
bad for Connor uh because he had
misplaced his white Bishop uh and he'd
basically gotten it trapped into sucked
the whole game because he went to like
uh he basically just got his pieces
stock uh he did not play very well with
it okay
um so that's what my concern is here
yeah because you want to get it out yeah
and that's that's a that's a good move
for this level uh Frank my okay yeah I
mean Frank is just sort of on autopilot
at the moment uh Sea Dog has played in
the best way possible
and then after Pawn takes you can't just
take back because you're gonna lose this
which is very likely to happen by the
way because
well we're about to see I'm very scared
Frank doesn't skip a beat he went right
for reaching for his nightmare and Frank
is losing in six moves because it's
rubbing his hands like a maniacal
Mastermind wild down upon yeah so
explain what's the issue here he's
losing the phone on the center because
it's attacked twice by the night going
forward and the queen going forward yes
should the queen take to offer a trade
yeah probably and kind of does it
oh
um this is a good spot all right you
guys are all very good at chess you're
in this spot right now imagine
yourselves are you like oh it's in the
bag
for black for you if you are black right
now yeah it's locked up yeah dub mag is
here
yeah
no probably not okay but I won't lose
but most people
what about you Andrea Ferrari games for
sure about a but at pogchem's level
especially after that last game
literally anything can happen right I'm
also curious who do you guys think of
favorite is in the more middle game end
game positions now that Queens just came
off the board
well I thought it was Conor but he
clearly had a lack of defensive Vision
on checkmates so if he avoids that
generally he's pretty good like he he
holds on in losing positions much more
than most people would
um
but I think he's someone who plays
better with a lead like he's I don't I
mean I guess that's everybody to an
extent everybody wants a lead
um uh Frank is just completely tilting
this game oh this is
is he's yeah you see what I what
I meant in game one when I said he has
to behave
this is uh how did this go bad so fast
we're on move eight he played the move
Knight to C3 uh we'll just bring this
back very quickly played this move in
about I don't know one second he
definitely seemed overconfident yeah I
would agree I think the last game Frank
was definitely holding down his nerves
and this game you can see he kind of had
a change of mannerism started playing a
little faster definitely that Checkmate
did get to him a little bit but he could
drop this Knight back get an exchange
back it's not necessarily over yeah and
and there's a nice way to lose here by
the way like Sea Dog I think will block
with the bishop uh and he did that but
there was a nice way to lose if you like
put your king here and accidentally got
checkmated in the future but yeah Frank
can take go here like Andrea said take
the Knight and then the king is still in
the center and the King might go there
and still get checkmated so uh it's a
good start for Connor but we'll see
we'll see if he's playing right now at
99.3 percent so it's a good number yeah
oh well Frank should have taken with
check because then he would have been
able to play Knight F3 right away yeah
and just be very Speedy about
recapturing the night does he get
defeated does he does he get bummed out
I it's very tough to say uh probably I
feel like most people do but he he has
played like two good moves this game I I
don't know what happened it's probably
overconfidence
uh in a little bit of invincibility from
that first game it does happen
after you win a game that maybe you
weren't expecting to win but yeah it's
interesting how the tables have turned
because I'd say in the first game
especially after the interview Conor
went in a little bit overconfident I
even underestimated Frank myself but
that's what winning does to you gives
you fake hope
you're just kidding it's funny that the
people who seem to have had the highest
confidence were instantly punished for
that yep Conor game one tumbling game it
is
like this matchup because we have
someone
wait are they pointing out the threat to
each other I'm very curious
it does feel like they are open about
the threats because when you attack
something you know you want to pretend
like it's not there so your opponent
doesn't see it but Frank Is An Open Boat
[Laughter]
and falling for you're down so much
you are not well it looks like he's
gonna develop his night at least so he
is getting that night on A1 back yeah
what's he doing what's he doing I told
you like he's gotta just Alexander just
said because he reached for his night
and now he put his hand down I have no
idea what the hell he's gonna do he's
not gonna move tonight
what else is he looking at that's the
question your pieces are developed
there's two that haven't moved the
entire game this is like you know it's
like coaching a boxer who has a lot of
other skills and just only just gets
into ridiculous fist fights where his
like whole face is busted you're like
just just don't do that you know uh what
is he thinking about I mean really what
is he there is nothing else I think he's
just playing mind games with Conor it's
failing he's
with us at least he's hopelessly lost he
has to fight back by developing his
pieces and winning that night in the
corner but am I going to be able to Flap
my wings about oh yeah she's commentary
is if anything not helping his opponent
he rattled the stoic Connor yeah yeah
yeah yeah he did true he got a giggle
out of him and he made the best move
there we go I used to teach like five
and six year olds before all this online
stuff and you know one of the craziest
things that they would say
yeah you just wouldn't do that yeah he
kicks his night out one of their
favorite things to say with each other
was I know what opening your place yeah
and it's like no like we all know
yeah no idiot it doesn't matter
yeah I mean and then the kid will come
and cry he knew I was playing the London
yeah it's not a secret like we we're all
on the same page here
just
it's just amazing isn't it like he's
winning the match but he's still in awe
of his opponent you know I mean it's
really easy to play well when you're up
a full Rook it's not so much that not
that Conor didn't play well but it's
more that Frank just fumbled the bag on
this game
yeah from the get-go so I'll be curious
to see how much Frank can bring it back
whether it's winning or maybe just not
losing as bad
yeah uh the worst part about this I
cooked my way out of this one wow the
king is coming to play defense that's
insane right yeah but the point was that
if the bishop had moved the Knight would
sneak out with the defense of the Rook
uh because he couldn't take this he can
actually play Knight C2 here and get his
night out he can he can still play this
by the way because the king can't cover
two King is so beta I mean it's
ridiculous
a lot of good moves for Connor here yeah
the king Frank did an act on that night
fast enough I think Connor clapping his
wings I don't yeah there's almost
flapping it's also this move yep exactly
and uh you got to go there now the
Knight escapes by capturing which would
be really bad
and I think Frank Frank it's just the
best of two after this you know what I
mean I
we're gonna have to play a best of two
which is how you can get to 2.5 and one
like I predicted everyone was being a
hater on you I didn't understand the
math but I'm on your side 2.5 to 1 is
not possible it would be two and a half
to one and a half oh yeah because they
drew you're right okay
and so yes yeah I fell for that yeah
okay oh he's getting distracted but he's
trying to set up another cheeky Fork
yeah the pawn is looking dirty
British commentary is so much better I
think he also enunciates his his words
like Austin Powers sometimes he does he
does really he's a mix of uh Austin
Powers I I said it once Austin Powers
and somebody else he's so funny
um
and so authentic too Frank in person is
just like Franken on the screen okay
what I like about though let's see if
he's doing it oh that that was not where
I was going to go physically stops G4
but completely hangs upon
um like he cannot go here yeah but maybe
Connor won't see that
at least he's getting the Knight back on
A1 you know there was a world a couple
moves ago where he wasn't going to but
then Conor is going to go here and then
here anyway oh that is
um that is a nice line yeah this is this
hasn't been a good game this is you know
Connor is like a thousand sixty because
sometimes he plays like a 960 and
sometimes he plays like an 1160. yeah
Frank is 900 because sometimes he plays
like a 1400 and sometimes he plays like
a 400 and last game was a 1400 Frank
minus hanging mate in one uh and uh you
know this game is so his variance is
higher it's unclear which one is better
it's unclear which one is better for the
long-term chess career but one gives
your coach a heart attack four more
often so
and what advice do you give to your
students who are just
so erratic
oh I I don't give Frank I you know um
not not in the middle game I mean you
gotta ask Frank for advice yeah I really
I want to be as confident and cheeky as
as he is it's hard like a game like this
is a complete opening disaster so
everything you do afterward is kind of
meaningless because you know you're
gonna fix the opening disaster so you'll
never be in a position like this uh it's
it's tough to learn from the middle game
of this game all right you know we've
been talking all this smack but Frank's
move Bishop D4 was kind of Genius
because it's completely avoiding that
fork that Levy pointed out yeah it's
dying and now he just has to fall
yeah and does he know that because this
is like everything he's prepared for
yeah this could be a comeback Andrea
called this out like 10 minutes ago she
was like
I think so
it would be awfully good
um
yeah
just say goodbye to him now do we say
goodbye to your boy now you know what
I'm predicting a Frank comeback because
yes he's down material but Conor's
pieces his Knight on G4 is even a little
bit tied up it can't really Retreat
Frank's Bishops are in the center
somehow King in the center he didn't get
punished for it and he's going into a
middle game end game so I don't know his
pieces are looking like they're going to
get more and more active I think yeah
but that was a nice move on Conor's part
trying to trade when he's up
the problem with Frank's position is he
just doesn't really have any plan here
he's got a cheeky Pawn he could take
yeah he should go here
because he's I mean
why
he needs to avoid the bishop trade
because
that would just free the night this is
what we expected coming into this
matchup
which was what dominance by Sea Dog yeah
winning in six moves exactly I don't
know if this is dogs
like Frank's holding his ground he he
made some silly mistakes and the opening
but I don't know if I would say this is
dominance is this comebackable no
no chance no Andreas I think so not with
not with C though I have faith all right
Andrea be real have you lost a game with
this level of lead I have lost hundreds
of games with this level of lead it's
actually what I do for a living
okay then it's compatible
levy on the other hand never stalemates
never blunder so that's why he can't
really he's a perfect place
Rosman I've never I've never lost it
never lost the game
um on a serious note yeah the title
player level it also depends what is
there 30 seconds left or is there five
minutes left is there 40 minutes left
like I think that's why I'm less
confidence because Frank is also down on
time
yeah but he could have like Conor could
have I I'm only gonna start thinking a
comeback as possible when Conor gets to
around two minutes and all these pieces
are on the board Connor is I will say to
his to his fault bad
at specifically converting end games and
like just getting the Checkmate like he
makes it hard on himself he does it
slowly and we we saw that again against
uh I think psychuno
where he was really trudging through the
mud trying to get the check made
um well right now what's gonna happen is
Frank is going to move his Knight
because it's targeted and then that's
gonna free up a square in the center I
think he's gonna move his Knight to the
center okay he moves it back that's fine
let me just show this on the big board
now that square is free for the night
yeah this is looking not good and then
you snap that if the king keeps going
forward you have a discovered attack on
the king
like this and yeah 95 is a lethal blow
If he if he plays it you know we missed
that mate in one the good news is the
Knight defends the bishop so he could
move the king back right he he did not
he grabbed the pawn which I mean can't
hate
completely reasonable move and he's
probably just gonna move it right back
to where it was
yeah he took the pawn Frank don't like
what you've done with the place
well at least Frank can play a move like
Rook B1 get a Tempo and maybe avoid 95.
I think Connor's just gonna go exactly
where he came yeah this was a really
nice move order for Connor if he would
have taken this Pawn earlier you know
white could have tried to take on B7
activate the Rook but he even defends
this Pawn first now there's so many
threats okay
yeah Frank might
run out of ideas and just go here which
will force that move or maybe Conor will
take a pawn always time for one
he's playing that's not about yeah
Bishop B5
trying to get rid of the blockade try to
get that pawn gets his Bishop out of the
fork yeah so now this move you can just
move your king
listen the longer this game goes the
higher the chances Frank wins come right
because like I said true all the pieces
are still on the board
and if if Conor doesn't find the
knockout
yeah Fry's going to get his pieces back
into the game then anything can happen
yeah Frank is slowly redeeming himself
it's now less than a one minute
Advantage for Sea Dog which it hasn't
been in a very long time
and he trades because that's
very natural move to make yeah and
actually there is this crazy Rook check
that wins the night yeah that night on
the side of the board is practically a
dead horse anyways but now it's actually
lost but if that does happen he does
have some comeback tactic ideas with
Rook takes B7 and then B8 yeah Rook B8
yeah it looks juicy like a potential pin
on The Rook but that dark squared Bishop
can always come back for some reason I
thought you're gonna say juicy like a
potato I was really hoping for that Alex
has been sitting at commentary little
too long she's getting hungry
um Connor's it's so tough to know like
what he's looking at whatever Frank
mixes his hands like that you know he's
cooking up something oh my God
it looks professional when he's done it
he's reached down
that is a huge blow to the comeback
chances yeah big blow to the ego
coming in and then maybe 94 the
checks and Rook B8 threats he really has
to craft a perfect puzzle but there is
potential mate he could he should just
smother him with all his pieces right
but he should go King back so he has to
eat Four Square for his Knight
Connor will take that is a ridiculous
shot
and that yeah Frank's just got to go
here and hear and pray basically
he's hovering his hand over the Rook it
is a free Pawn you can't get much better
than that and Connor takes the pawn
Franklin's a rook right uh not oh yes if
he sees the full variation because then
he has to play Bishop B6 and then but
yeah but then Connor has King D7 and
then the Rook guards oh true but like
it's the best he's got you know what I
mean that's not a bad move you know
Connor giving him no hope for that line
to happen King's going here it's gonna
be nice and snug and uh yeah if the king
got this way there was chances there was
ways you could lose you could also lose
like this and accidentally hang your
rook and then
but I think he has too much time to
block he's at 92 for the game
so he has really not done anything wrong
at all uh the only chance that Frank now
has again is is this and going for F7
but it's still it's hopeless uh it
really is but he's he's got to do
something you can't just resign so well
it looks like he's going to
Frank doesn't seem like a resigner yeah
I was gonna say the same thing I like
that he's a fighter even now his spirits
don't seem too down they're both
Fighters it's a good matchup it's a best
of four all right maybe you're gonna
lose this game but it's 1-1 you're tied
up yep it's not a you didn't lose and
and three
there's also like for instance if black
goes I want to trade Knights and you're
like all right I'm pinning you and then
take and then Bishop takes all of a
sudden you're getting mated
that would be kind of cool you know what
I mean it wouldn't be a first that's
yeah
I think Connor something good about him
is that in these very winning spots he's
still taking 30 40 like you know 50
seconds yeah
good and bad because he's about to be
down on time right but at least he's not
you know he's very keen to to make a
good move where there seemed to be many
good moves
but also he's now down on time right so
he he can only do this like three more
times sure before he Flags
which is crazy like he he has 10 good
just you know just make one just go what
did he do
fantastic great
and now he's gonna bring the Rook to
defend and Frank uh the way he reaches
for the piece which reminds me of when I
would play against younger kids in my
chess tournaments and I'd get really
excited like they're cooking up
something huge and then just like that
and then it's so tilting because you
also believe them sometimes you're like
oh my God that's it but there's just one
move it defends it it's over yeah
maybe bishop D4 yeah we talked about
this bishop D4 but by the time you take
and then try to get over there King's
just gonna go to a light Square
this is not a queen if it was that would
be really nice but it's great everything
he's doing is good
[Laughter]
he's laughing maniacally like he's
crushing it's honestly good mind games
though because whether it's real or not
it is very tilting and Sea Dog could go
here for example okay Rook Cafe is a
great one now Frank should just go A4
just go away four just you know he does
have an insane Pawn that nobody is near
yeah well The Rook will just swap sides
they'll hop to A3 and then goodbye
passer it is a fast piece oh is he gonna
try to chop it all down he can't he's
got to try to put okay that's a great
move now he's looking to set up this
he's good at putting trying to put Conor
into some time pressure he's continuing
to attack getting him lower on the clock
insane this is exactly what we talked
about Frank has just enough pieces for
it to not matter that Connor says two
minutes because if they traded a bunch
of pieces Conor would just play fast
because he knows Frank only has Pawns
but he's terrified he's just terrified
he's gonna blunder something
and you're saying that Frank can either
be a 400 or a 1400 he started as a 400
but now he's playing like a 1400 is it
too late no I'm getting nervous for
Connor yeah 150 on the clock he's
knocking pieces over he's sweating he's
gonna we're gonna get this and you know
Conor could lose that with the bishop
and then that in one move if Knight to
E4 is played
but now Frank is deciding to get
suspenseful here he played every move
instantly for about 10 moves and now
he's nervous for some reason he's got
nothing to lose he's just got to make a
move make a move Frank and it looks like
he's going for the check
no I think he's gonna bring it back wow
that is the best move and you got a mic
what he's hearing you no no no he
wouldn't have he would have hung the
fork yesterday
yeah I guess that's fair the thing is
he's also out of options you know what I
mean he doesn't have a lot of pieces
left so he's just putting them on free
squares and Connor finds Rook C8
uh but you know the bishop Bishop in
here Bishop in here
he just takes yeah it's not a good move
because now we're gonna get trades yep
should have kept the Press
depression very cool
yep
90 seconds Connor you just gotta make
the move it's just a train he can take
either he'll see who he takes the bishop
and Frank cheating you know hitting the
clock with the opposite hand that he's
moving the piece which a lot of Chess
enthusiasts would know is
not allowed I found out that I was
shooting because I do it all the time
that's all good this could end Fast
Frank could move his Knight and then
Rook C2 check and going to the back rank
accidental Checkmate he's probably gonna
have to come up
he was not afraid of bringing his King
up earlier so
he's thinking you should have thought
I'd move five that would have really
really prevented a lot of this from
happening now there's an m in the
evaluation only we see that mate in
seven that's a big one give us the whole
variation uh main seven starts with
check on King with the Rook yeah yep uh
uh King moves uh there then next is uh
the right Rook moves up one yeah uh then
King is forced yep yep
Ludwig predicted this Maiden 17.
this at the start of the game oh it was
an illegal move apparently
clock starts
oh during an illegal move the side that
uh creates the offense oh no gives two
minutes to the opponent so
uh
are they doing those rules here no
they're not oh they're not doing those
yeah I was gonna say we're not doing
touch move I'd be surprised if they have
the other legal movements we're not
playing sweaty here playing chill what's
just happened then why did he why did
the ref come over and what was he he's
calling him stupid I can't believe he
played that move
uh he's missed the mate in seven and
also this check here check takes the
night that's made
that he just plays A4 nice yeah now it's
made uh Rook D2 sets a Checkmate net
with rookie 2. that's uh that's a nice
little puzzle there Checkmate into here
for black is very hard Rook D2 I don't
think he's gonna play it but you never
know
he might give a check hang The Rook that
would be fun for the fans
you might just want to check until he
gets the king in the the Knight on the
same file yep yeah that's definitely the
most instinctive move and he must know
he's close hopefully that's why you got
40 seconds yeah he's just played King
did he oh my God he hung a fork oh my
God
Frank just doesn't even I mean you know
what he might promote
he certainly saw it that's
he's melting like the Wicked Witch of
the West and Frank he knows he can't say
anything like he wants to say something
Conor is 20 seconds this is insane Conor
goes to attack the the moving piece
which loses the fork yeah loses the fork
he goes to the square as if there was
still a fork oh Frank's got to keep
checking or else this is one of you know
one of these is going to be a mate at
some point I mean you're gonna get mated
somehow in the center of the board
yeah Frank's shaking his head he
definitely realizes he missed it
I'm trying to find a way like Conor
could accidentally walk himself he's
shaking oh my gosh kinda shaking
Connor does not have a lot of time nope
24 seconds is very stressful and a good
move oh my goodness okay King is safe
now Frank might guard his Pawn by
playing Rook B5 and I'm really worried
here Conor's gonna check this King into
running this way if actually Frank runs
straight he's gonna get checkmated so
big moment here for Frank Connor's very
nervous I've never seen him this nerves
before it's kind of fun yeah Rook B5 now
there's a checkout big moment here King
E4 is made in a few moves and ah oh oh
he put it back now King E4 played and
now Knight where did he he Retreats
that's free now but that's there's gonna
be a mate he takes the Free Pawn and now
Rook A4 is Checkmate in two moves does
and Conor has 30 seconds to find it
and he's found it
that is huge
and he he nods his head and I'm pretty
sure he whispered in an expletive at his
opponent who was a minor by the way it's
a British expletive yep and he looks at
his opponent going
oh wow
damn nice cherry on top
there's actually only one move you can
make yep it's the only movie
you can't go boom there are no booms he
has to interpose with his Rook or he
could execute it and run the clock out
wait so I can't move King but I'm not
into Checkmate right
[Music]
oh matters
wow game two goes to Connor one two one
smash yeah and even though Frank
just screw the pooch from the start you
know probably bad lines from his coach
but
he made a competitive he brought it down
a time and and Conor was nervous dude
you sweating he was but
20 seconds on the clock he got it
together he got the win and the good
news is Frank lost that game on move
five right so the good news is the next
time he has the white pieces there will
be a game four
he's just gonna do a little bit better
than that which Frank will show up next
hmm
well we'll see right after the break for
game three of this best of four nobody
can win on the next game but they'll
have a huge lead yep we'll see right
after the break see in a second all
right don't go anywhere see you later
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
something
oh is that you getting back here to
watch more chess.com very fun very cool
thank you for coming here welcome to pog
Champs 5 finals the championship bracket
matchup between Sea Dog VA and Frank is
here it's at one to one in Nemo's back
and I want your thoughts on what
happened
honestly I feel bad for Frank he
blundered his Rook or plundered The
Exchange I guess kind of early and it
felt like he was trying to fight back
from that the entirety of the game but
unfortunately Conor was just so solid
and was able to get that win at the end
but he looked nervous and
yeah can I ask you a question yes would
you blame because at the end of the day
these are players they do their own
stuff after the opening it's it's all up
to them but the opening is the thing
that the coach has the most control over
would you ever blame the coach if
there's a mistake in the first six moves
I
me and he is the coach for Frank I
probably should or anything oh I didn't
know that I didn't know that that's
embarrassing you know oh I didn't know
this Andrea you missed your kid
sorry
I will uh I will hold the L I saw both
the players in the hallway uh and they
look confident they look ready to go
they look kind of shell-shocked I feel
like they're coming out of a blood draw
they do seem like super nervous and pale
they're both extremely nervous like
Frank's mom is even watching like it's
was she nervous yes very nervous and
it's probably even harder for Conor to
go against a young kid and have his mom
here cheering him on and see her nervous
backstage and the mom he wants to take
on vacation yeah exactly no both sides
are very nervous which I I think is very
endearing because I like that they're
taking this seriously the prize fund
determines you know Frank's getting paid
no matter what so it's just gonna be the
quality of the vacation or maybe the
class of the ticket on the airplane that
he takes off maybe we go to stoke on
Trent maybe we go to Paris we'll find
out but first let's listen to Frank's
words before the match started and how
we felt about his opponent
[Music]
is that like a like a person that
they're the people yeah yeah the January
January just started playing chess this
year oh well I'm quite I'm quite devious
with it I'm aggressive sometimes and
defensive sometimes like most players
are probably but I I say I'm a little
more aggressive because I push pieces
out a lot I've only paid like four games
over the board probably should do more
I'm actually going to have to think I
can't speak out my thoughts so that's
gonna be difficult I kind of speak
before I think so I say a word and then
I'll think about it and then that helps
me think but just thinking
not great for me uh weaknesses I blunder
my pieces and they're just gone so I
can't use them anymore so that's
definitely a weakness my strengths I'm
actually on decent at end games but when
I'm on form that end game is mine the
whole board is mine group stages pretty
easy pretty easy obviously opponents
played well don't want to discredit them
good opponents good opponents I won two
and then just completely lost the last
one against Connor the quarterfinals
quite a hard matchup very difficult
matchup I had to fight my way through
that one went all the way to the tie
breaks but I won with seconds to spare
seconds and then on the semi-finals
played xqc he was obviously on a plane
don't know why he was on a plane but he
was and I won that one dude excuse he's
losing their time with the plain Wi-Fi
yeah
okay I'll give a check there
oh yes this is what what got me to the
finals
amazing
absolutely amazing well done Frank well
done you won that on on time and was
very happy to win that one and now I'm
gonna win the finals hopefully yeah
hopefully just to keep myself calm and
composed you know gotta not get let the
fear set in I've got a gotta look at the
chessboard gotta feel calm and that's
just how it is as long as I'm calm I'll
perform that's what it is
we are back and he's right as long as
he's calm and composed he will win and I
think that was his game one performance
is game two performance perhaps a little
over confident you know it may be a
little too quick and so hopefully this
game three he makes that adjustment uh
and we're jumping into it any
predictions on this game couch how we
feeling botez Brothers I have mixed
emotions now after that last game but I
feel like Frank is gonna learn his
lesson take the opening a little slower
I'm sure you know with this coach here
there's great prep for the next game
I think Sea Dog Connor still the
favorite here but if Frank is a little
bit more nervous a little bit less
confident maybe it's gonna be him
playing at 1400 level again Anything Can
Happen uh he also had a lot of success
with the black pieces he right he had a
really bad game with the white pieces we
see a handshake there let's see what
what similarities we're gonna see in the
opening uh same King's Pawn let's get
cooking Frank says last time Connor
moved the night out this time I think
Connor's oh he's moving the other night
out okay mixing it up which is already
potentially a bad sign because he might
take the pawn and get to the exact same
position right because as long as you
take in the center with white it's the
same exact thing so in the last game all
that was different is that Connor took
and played this move later
uh but he's already thinking right which
is which means they haven't gotten any
sneaky like bathroom prep you know no in
between someone in the bathroom yep are
they allowed to look in between games
yeah I'm sure but yeah definitely yeah I
feel like it's not as serious as like
the you know Champions chess tour where
they're and he takes and he's once again
headed for a slightly worse exchange
Carl composition yeah it's never fun at
least when I've played when you lose
that pawn in the center and they just
lose their c-file Pawn I feel like it
always sucks it makes the game harder
what about it is do you find hard to
play against uh I I find it hard to
break open the center later on
um and get my pieces in places I like
and uh it's the exact same thing like
Frank even though he did the wrong thing
in game one which is blocking in the
bishop he just goes back to it because
it worked and Frank you know we got the
night out and now he's gonna also bring
his Knights out and it's just a game of
chicken who's gonna back out from the
copycat variation first yeah Conor
played this move last time and Connor uh
Frank played here and here so
it is usually the player
or yep
yep now one of them could forget like
one of them could just go oh I want to
go you know uh and and not even realize
that they're repeating the same thing
what if this was the first game ever
that had the same exact result this is
way worse oh my gosh
I'm surprised that Frank was the one who
broke I I'm not necessarily surprise
like again I I think Frank is still a
little bit shaky in the opening that's
why you try to teach the openings right
last game when he had white what
happened was he got hit with a move he
hadn't seen that much in practice so he
just tried to play what he thought he
was supposed to play but you have to
adapt to what's on the board the good
news is
uh you know you can't really be lost yet
like it's still the opening and he can
still put his Knight on F5 and then take
out the bishop and he'll have to see it
because he wants the castle Yeah he has
to go here there you go and then you
know he's gonna play this oh not that
would be really bad but uh well he you
know he's gonna go here and then
and Connor might play this move and help
black develop by trading pieces what did
he play Knight to E5 yeah it's a big
moment already Frank has to play defense
does he does he realize that or is he
just gonna autopilot Bishop here
yeah I like this for Connor trying to
put some extra pressure on Frank
straight out of the opening knowing that
this has been his weakness so far
at least he's slowing down because the
last game when he made all those
blunders in a row it was because he was
moving too quickly looks like he's
trying to unpin his Knight yeah Bishop
here would be fine because
that Bishop's not really going to have
much of a future uh so Euro actually
okay doing this trade
we'll see if Conor grabs it taking there
would be worse because that was not
really the objective you go here to try
to secure the bishop yep benefit
s trade actually might favor Frank
because that
night in the center is a very strong
piece whereas that light squared Bishop
is a bad Bishop
uh this morning Frank and virtual were
setting this board up and train and just
playing and virtual left is night here
it got taken and then it came back
whoops it came back to take the bishop
and then he was up a piece against
virtual
so Connor could go here and go I don't
have to do anything and then
accidentally blunder
uh but we'll see I think whoa whoa whoa
whoa what is that that is real creative
it looks scary but it has no threats at
all it's not I guess if he moves his
Bishop he thinks he can take the Knight
away and attack G7 I wasn't supposed to
go to H5 Frank could take this and lose
yes Queen H5 threatens mate it's still
not a good move because simply Pawn
blocks or Knight takes Knight I mean
that's the thing Frank could lose this
game right now by taking here and giving
up this bishop that would be utterly
ridiculous but it is a free pawn and it
does look you know enticing and he took
the right way
he took the right way and now he's
threatening to win the game he's
threatening to take the Knight which
Conor already forgot about once so Queen
G4 was just not a Conor like move he's
been so safe so cautious I don't know
where this came from yeah I think one
thing that's also happening in the
players is stamina like these guys have
been here since early morning last game
of the day it's been several hours they
haven't gotten dinner yet we just ate a
little dinner yeah
yeah well these guys no food haven't
been fed so I think we're a few times
yeah it makes the competition wins the
only winner gets dinner that's what
that's why they're hungry so Carter is
freezing in there by the way hold up
queben can con oh no what was the
question I was gonna say can't Connor
take the Knight with his Bishop he can
and then take the other night because
it'll be undefended but that night can
go backwards well Frank has to find the
backwards night buff The Good the good
thing about this move for Frank is that
you don't need to be a genius to figure
out Queen takes is the best move but
then Connor still is okay because it's
hard for Frank to develop the dark Squad
Bishop with the pressure here position
is already resignable at GM level
believe it or not what yeah stop no no
it's completely resignable because black
is a pawned up uh black also has two
Center bones like you said so black is
just gonna Castle safely uh trade a few
pieces pressure here like any GM would I
don't know first of all not find
themselves here but yeah this is
borderline resignable she'll get border
chess if it's like that
right here yeah that's why we're
commentating I feel you let's not forget
the semi-finals of the Chess World Cup
starts tomorrow and Levy could you beat
Magnus if uh you had the white pieces
here the white pieces oh sorry the black
pieces yeah I was like the white piece
is probably not uh it took depends on
the format I mean I would obviously like
I would get nervous and then I would do
something stupid but I would have an
advantage for a very long time it's
really hard because white can't do
anything imagine it's not Magnus like
white has no Center Pawns uh well now
the business yeah yeah this could be
this could be this is it uh he could
take like this it's a it's a 33 chance
Frank throws away probably pod Champs
right here I think he throws card we
don't know I think he's gonna see it do
we have an aerial shot uh he is oh he
just hovered over his night yeah
oh oh my God certainly he sees a huge
move and there it is wow
you said you'd think he's gonna throw it
away that is the hate on this man I'm
not hating I like Frank he's a great guy
I just thought that that was a hard move
to see I didn't see it
yeah you did you you said it you
literally were like oh that doesn't work
because there's this move nice try I
didn't see it for a while uh rookie won
now the advantage is getting bigger and
bigger because the computer just wants
the castle but it's still losable
territory for black you could move the
bishop and lose this Pawn
you could go here allowing the Knight to
get active I think at this level
computers dumb under five points of
advantage like it's dumb in the sense
that it's not that valuable I think some
coder has to uh like adjust stockfish to
what ELO it's watching the grade curve
the grade stock fish like if stockfish
knew it was observing 900s right now the
eval would not be minus two vintage
white so then our job would just be
replaced guys oh true it can't talk
voices give it a couple weeks what is
Frank doing what oh that's not even a
bad move well night before it's a crazy
that's like a
I wouldn't do this because
his king is not castled and he's already
developed that night but it's actually
really hard to defend like they spawn
like you have to go here probably or
move the queen back but then Frank can
finally get his Bishop off f8 yeah I
don't know why the computer doesn't like
this move it's just it's not in the top
three but I don't understand why well
because after the rock what Ben what
it's over GG the Black Brook move no no
excuse me that that's E2 rookie two yeah
it's just it's just oh it brings the
queen back now now Frank's got to
realize he could go here
uh I did not really why was rookie two
so bad whatever I don't
you just look at the eval bar just just
like everybody else
it's minus 1.6 Frank has been really
really good with black and that came
with white
we'll forget about it oh my guess could
go tiebreaker
I thought Frank takes it in game four
but now I'm not so sure after seeing
that game with white so he's gonna the
thing is again Frank when he was playing
white thinks I gotta do it this way
because that's what Levy said I I didn't
say he had to lose a rook in you know
eight or nine moves that's not what I
said I like that you're taking care of
your liability yeah I was uh not in the
you know not in the agreement it won't
be in the book right it will not be in
the book when's the book coming out
October 24th heck yeah uh soon I will be
contacting influencers to send them one
you want one I'll take one yeah
we might pick up a few things I I don't
know about that but it's uh it's
definitely for for the Franks of the
world actually Frank's already at like
the 80th percentile probably there's
that move here I'm curious yeah Frank's
kind of a wild Dynamite he might just go
crazy push this Pawn try to continue
attacking or play solid develop the
bishop finish his castling in his
development what do you think he's gonna
go for me Oh I thought he already put D4
in he did he did but there's D3 I think
Frank is gonna go here take take with
the Knight get pinned and maybe lose
um
this is actually what I'm worried about
because that pin does look scary I'm a
commentator right I got to be biased but
I got to be unbiased he just attacked
the Knight his very next Pawn push
attacks wait it'll be a moment of
maturity if he doesn't and instead play
something like Rook C8 yep and this is
exactly what I was going to say is the
difference between the eval bar the
stockfish computer and our lovely Pock
Champs or POG champers because
completely winning for black if you play
practical and you develop but if you're
a 900 you get distracted you push a
couple bonds that eval bar is oh my God
he did it he played Rook C8 wow that's a
that's a huge moment and nice Connor
might go here and then Frank has an
attack on the queen and an anchor into
the fork that that lights out you win a
rook you get a pass pawn two squares
from queening
and that's game over and and Connor is
staring at a two to one deficit if he
plays this move I don't know what else
he can play because the Pawn's hanging
right it's a very human movie he has to
realize he has to sacrifice the pawn
yeah the best move for for white is to
play Rook B1 to lose the pawn without so
ugly without a fork yeah chess can be
painful I think Conor is going to lose a
lot of time on this one and that might
be that's okay though rather him take
his time than throw on this move and he
does take his time but then he gets into
serious time pressure and he's in Zig
zwang guys nice we didn't get an end
person I was hoping that would be the
downfall okay
64 right here
yeah and and I I don't know if Frank can
find D3 Knight C2 that's a very tough
thing to find he might go my Knights
hanging the pawn take easy I think if he
finds D3 he'll find Knight C2 so it's
just yeah he finds D3 yeah yeah I look
for your forcing moves yeah D3 is uh the
second most forcing move in the position
because taking the pawn is the most
forcing move and then this attacks the
max that you can attack wait oh he's
thinking he's touching it oh my God
that's your guy that is your guy and
yeah the blue blue X clamp does not give
this move enough credit damn look at him
nodding himself approvingly
when Frank is proud of his own chest
like earlier he was just hyping himself
watching his own reel this is it's great
this is just I I mean it's I mean it's
over from the exaggerated stand but it's
definitely not overexpect the blacks
also get castle if he gets castled
he can actually win this game pretty
easily but Conor's realizing it's
sinking in like what the hell is going
on when I'm playing white so I taught we
that's why we learned the Karo Khan
Frank did not play the Karo Khan until
game one really he played it like for a
week for like four days practice this is
a a new technique this is a new opening
and it's good yeah so it's but you know
you see the variants when he played with
white right new tools exploded the wood
shop
so what about Connor here what are his
best chances
No rookie one would be an exotic way to
get back rank checkmated
rootsie won would
have no vision like me you don't
understand the game I I really don't
though that's the me and Tyler won were
Reinventing the sport uh he retired he
actually played e-rob right after the
show
they did a rematch directly after and
then he started grinding games that
sounds like me and Andrea Andrea
she never lets me gamble I've got a
close friend who's probably watching the
show uh shout out to the best chess
coach in New York City Alex ostrovsky so
he he is the master of trash dog despite
losing 90 of the time like we could be
playing
anything and if he's five in a row he's
still talking like it's zero zero
he's talking like he's up five you
got to keep the same energy you know you
can't just talk when you're up you gotta
keep the energy you know it's a bad look
if you don't yep everybody likes talk
when they're up but uh who said that
Lucas goat yeah speaking of changing
energies Frank started the last game
very talkative this game has been very
silent I think they're starting to feel
the pressure uh that's it oh oh you see
that that was a really bad move that's
what Connor didn't let go he didn't let
go it's not touch peace what is it
called it's not touch move it's not
touch move it's drop move
technically clock move but close Ludwig
yeah that would walk into a gigafork uh
this is still a fork it's not a gigafort
that would have been a gigafort it was a
nice save on Conor's part
I knew
[Laughter]
messed up pretty badly
uh I'm joking by the way I didn't
actually
[Laughter]
this is so brutal because Frank is so
innocent he's not doing this maliciously
no he's like he doesn't realize how
absolutely heinous this trash is can I
tell you my vision right now Bishop H6
for white yeah if captures yep yep yep
Fork
that's a nice try yeah the fact that you
even see that is impressive she sees the
cheeses yeah no I mean that's now make
no mistake this move does nothing no no
because it also allows you to recapture
the night
oh
my God that's why I'm the best baby
my vision is insane no again it's minus
seven okay
it just needs to feel something Levy it
is literally only a good move if he
takes and I think he's gonna take it oh
my God
oh my God wait
bro look at me no
dishwater let's go
wait I
um Frank even oh it was too good
wow you guys don't understand chess is
an easy game we've been
Reinventing it since POG Champs won
that was one of the greatest calls of
all time and I I can't believe he took I
am this is insane it's literally game
over the night as well yeah because
queen queen
oh my God it's g g on the greatest read
of all time that that was insane that is
so sick I like that just Frank has no
questions Connor just put his Bishop
there yeah
what happens when you trust your
opponent why did he do that so I don't
even know what to say what's funny is
what Frank said right after I knew it
was too good to be true he's not even
upset he's just like I fell for a
classic who done it
he just made a move with no threat that
was like if you take the bishop You're
Gonna Lose the queen whatever a higher
rated opponent is giving you a very
obvious free piece ask yourself why
respect him enough
Frank respected him too much I feel like
maybe yeah that's what you were saying
you didn't respect the thread but
I don't know Frank is that
and this game is I mean just about
curtains
yeah yeah Sea Dog will finish this off
because he's got a
like a a night he can take at the bottom
it could always be worse is what Frank
says that is sweet and it makes me sad
that this is happening
very soon well
well but
wow
that was
incredible I was sick Connor almost
feels bad like he apologized as he did
it I mean it was grimy as it was
like I respect it
you got to do Desperados is that what
they're called yep Desperado attack or
attempt right it's just like a Hail Mary
basically it's doing something you know
is wrong for the slight chance of
winning when you're in a worse position
which is a great strategy from for the
completely losing game
it's not the Desperado wait this part
was like you're gonna lose a piece like
for example uh the night in the corner
like he's gonna lose it right but if if
there's a way to sacrifice it for a pawn
just like in spite on the way out oh
it's just like taking it it's like a
martyrdom
it applied in different situations as
well I think I think it's just yeah I
mean it's like a desperate
move uh but uh that's linguistics
okay crazy
yeah yeah
Frank is not even he's not even budging
just does not realize what he lost what
I'm worried about because I want this to
go to a tiebreaker I like Frank it's one
of the formality you know I just didn't
want to risk it I am worried about his
opening on the fourth game
because this went exactly like you
called it Levy he is not really he being
Connor good with the white pieces his
opening is pretty flawed oh that's now
that's a way to get yourself mated
almost
um
uh everything is falling apart
yeah not even keeping the Rook on the
board's a bit tough because there was a
back rank prayer
there's only one legal move
Connor looking for the uh the battery
unfortunately a bishop cannot defeat a
queen in a rook Queen G8 right yep and
now Frank said refined mood was King and
right there
there's a way that's
also just saying you're planned loudly
perhaps these pawns on the right side
will work maybe it'll just take
backwards that would be that would be
kind of nice still be losing probably
porn
he doesn't give up at least no
his tenacity is one of his most
admirable traits King F6 Queen G7 is
mate
and Checkmate yeah what is the checkmate
wow wow
oh that was just bad
the bishop you I wasn't thinking it was
a huge debate uh I've really shocked you
out for it
we are all shots
I was I I did not see that at all I was
not looking that was I mean that was a
good game up until that point then that
was and then you missed the rook in
there yeah oh my god dude give me a
heart attack
Jesus wow yeah I mean you're playing
great though nice camaraderie between
the two and Connor is not uh salad and
short he was completely losing the
entire game his opening is horseshit
with white uh and Frank Frank's opening
is just really good with black I think
that's what it is Perhaps Perhaps to
make sure both uh but one Hail Mary
bishop move that only
GM savants of the game would find you
know the Fishers the the Carlsons of the
world yeah uh was he was able to make it
happen
exciting that was exciting yeah I can't
believe you literally just predicted
Bishop to H6 what were you during
Cutie's game why weren't you working
your magic I know because I'm in the
chair for a reason you know what it is
this is why I'm not playing everyone
Champs it's like come on I can't it'd be
it'd be uh it'd be a show you know
be over in seconds Frank Back Against
The Wall gotta win with the white pieces
wasn't looking too sharp in game two
hopefully this sounds a little different
yeah maybe get his ear for a second give
me some advice after after Bishop two H6
I don't know I don't get in his ear will
help but he's got to turn it around
we'll see any believers in chapter Frank
we'll see you right after the break for
our final perhaps game of POG Champs
we'll see
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello everybody and welcome back for the
final time to pogchamps five we have our
uh well actually no there could be one
again yeah yeah what no no sorry it's
crazy I'm not lying I'm not lying we do
not take a break in between tiebreaker
oh it's a tiebreaker we go straight to
it so I didn't lie you didn't lie it's
nice I saw somebody your child's look at
that chat because I was feeling myself I
made it the best call I'll ever make
till I die and someone goes games
obviously scripted no way at Ludwig
would call the bishop move I'm just good
I don't know what to say I don't know
your proposition if you're feeling very
confident Ludwig yeah I think we all
take side bets a hundred Subs on the
line on who wins this one yep can I pick
the side no Andrea this is why I don't
let you this is
bet I would like to make this bet and I
will take Connor dog voice actor wait
let me consult with my um counselor
don't take the weaker player when he's
down one point for the even odds I
believe in him he's down three points if
you're taking him you should ask for 500
Subs they've played five games
he's kind of being nice you know but I
think he's I think he's feeling more and
more confident I think having the lead
now oh yeah for sure is Big because not
only does Conor win if he wins this game
he wins if he draws this game yep
complaining that he's
twenty thousand dollars apparently yeah
he's also a free flight yeah make it pay
for it I might this is my business class
that son of a yes but who wouldn't
you know before I come from Japan he
didn't ask exactly
but God bless Frank thank you so much
Frank's mom listening yeah yes
oh here we go final game maybe
potentially potentially final game yeah
as the coach I am I am petrified talk us
through the opening because the opening
was the biggest fail point last time is
the elephant Sicilian now one of two
things could happen right Frank that's
my thing that's what I do that's my
thing Frank could play the elephant
again and try to improve right he could
get to the same spot so he's doing that
that's what Connor tried to do but
failed at well well all of this happened
like Frank lost the pawn and then lost
The Rook uh at some point Frank's gotta
go maybe I shouldn't lose the pawn and
if he somehow loses the pawn again which
would be just
I don't even have a word for it uh then
he has to not lose the Rook so he's
probably gonna play D4 which is what did
he play
he's improvising all right who's
protecting the C2 Square Levy how can
you not see I know I'm the great
predictor give it a thousand years a
sneaky made on C7 I would never have
thought of that move
I don't know what that move is I I don't
know why he did that that was not in the
preparations
oh actually yes the defend his E4 Pawn
First
and and and he's lost it he lost a pawn
again because Knight can take on e4 yes
and Connor didn't do that
but I think Connor will get there I I am
I I'm very stuck right now between coach
and commentator and I'm speechless as a
coach but I have to keep talking because
that's what I'm paid to do
um now okay there's still for example D5
Knight E5 Queen to D4 is a fork
and white is winning because you fought
the knights uh
I don't Maybe
yeah I would assume Conor would go to B4
that's same Fork wait a second but what
about Queen A5 check after then you have
to find B4 oh you're right I almost both
as gamma to take it on A3 no no then you
know there's a there's a lot of
things that have to happen for this to
go right
but there's there's something you know
hope is good Frank if anything's our
most optimistic competitor well to
Frank's credit after losing The Rook
last game in the same sort of opening he
uh he fought valiantly and uh and
brought it back a bit in terms of time
crunch he's not nearly as down now as he
was it's not as bad yeah and now now
this is a freestyle game
um this is just you know every man for
himself there's a Pawn on F3 for some
reason he's down upon and he's got a
knight on the edge of the board
you might end up having two nights on
the edge of the board because now he
took away one of the squares his night
usually develops he's inventing his own
opening the Frank he's gonna go here and
you know what they say about the night
on the rim
yep I do ain't good ain't good night on
the rim is a dog water that's what they
say
night on the rim is dim we gotta put the
rhyme in yeah yeah Connor is at 1001 on
the clock the live odds are plus seven
thousand for Frank we can still make
some bets potentially place your bets
everybody uh Andrea had a big bet she
wanted to place I don't know you want to
do that betzel uh
you never know what to
OK right
well Connor has made as many egregious
blunders as Frank this series so I
wouldn't put it past them to lose this
tiny lead now E6 is great just getting
the bishop out also he can take
damage the spawns get in here with the
queen I think he will do that he has to
punish those open dark squares around
the king and Frank just continues making
holes around the king yeah very
dangerous stuff going on here I mean I
kind of like that he can now put his
Knight on F3 at least so he's almost
fixing one of his worst moves
but Conor's gonna do that exact Bishop
movie talked about he's either gonna
yeah any takes and uh well does he see
Queen take the queen to A5 right that's
the big question that's why it's good
Frank is like this is not the moment to
uh to to act like you don't really I
think maybe this is the moment where he
realizes his position is bad but if this
is the moment that's a problem I think
he was laughing at himself not his
opponent
oh Queen instantly sees it wow that's
great move and uh
there there is still some very limited
hope here if he moves his king or
something but
why is moving the king best I just think
if you trade the Queens it's it's gonna
get hopeless pretty fast I was thinking
Bishop back one yeah Bishop Bishop back
is okay but then you know you disconnect
this I also think if Queen D2 Conor
might just take the A3 pawn and then he
can continue developing yeah and then
he's gonna come in here and yeah those
nice baby Bishop D3 I played against
Connor and the one thing I kept making
him do is stack pawns and he got so mad
at that that I think the moment he saw
There's an opportunity to do to do that
to Frank he bit it
I don't think the move Knight to A3 has
literally ever been played on the third
move of this game I think Frank might
have just developed a novelty as the
chess professionals gonna go in the
opening book now what can I say it's
gonna be the Frank Frank Tyler and I we
reinvent this game from the ground up
it'll be more popular than ever what
about Connor yeah he's playing like
classical Styles Lane okay we won't add
him to our to our repertoire did he move
the king oh he moved the queen right
then that makes sense Connor takes Pawn
Shirley
he might just leave it there as like a
permanent splinter in the white position
it does feel like two pawns on the
a-file are terrible and there's no
reason to take them they are absolutely
terrible yep much rather take the queen
and take the pawn in the center the D4
pawns way stronger than the A3 one
it's with the King yes physics with the
King that would be that would be to his
benefit
Connor
got a free Pawn right there he's
thinking about it if he doesn't take the
pawn I think he's leveled up in a way
that I I have never he's retrieving GM
wow trades the queen taking the pawn was
the best move right taking the queen I
mean Frank now has to take with the King
Frank might just think like I I can't
take with the King because then I can't
Castle but superseding things matter
right like you can't lose another Center
punt right and what two is credit he was
very comfortable moving his King out in
earlier games yeah I have a feeling he's
gonna walk his King up to D3
your prediction is the King on D3 yep I
think he's gonna go King takes Knight
check King D3 yeah that seems but that's
not bad for black because then you have
D5
well it's it's it's definitely not bad
it wasn't bad for black after the third
move that white maybe yeah which is good
for black people three minutes of
Advantage if this was King of the Hill
it'd be a different story for Frank but
this is not something you need to spend
time on I mean is Frank really going to
lose this pawn and get the same Fork on
the board he seems like he's taking with
the King there he goes there it is he's
not he's not shy he'll use that King get
the king to work
first game we've seen Frank have such a
Time disadvantage too he's down three
whole minutes already within 10 moves
too yeah it's hard to come back from
Connor oh looks like Connor's giving a
check which is yeah it's hard to
understand is Andrea wizard D3 yeah I'm
learning from the best Ludwig ah do what
I can you know D3 seems crazy though
because you just you just play like Pawn
F5 right or yeah
solidify that Knight in the center and
and now you really regret I'm not a
wizard that's not the best movie because
of this
um
and now this Pawn actually really
matters because it covers the B4 Square
so the Knight can't get it I would like
to see some sneaky B6 oh my goodness
there we go now we're playing this is a
nice tricky move
although it doesn't really threaten
anything scary because he won't lose the
bishop but it's a nice move for him to
develop yeah it's a nice threat Knight
F3 is fine
now Bishop A6 is just the trade I mean
it's just the trade of pieces
I don't know why I got excited I just
okay this is why I got excited that
light skirt Bishop had literally nowhere
to go and it was just kind of a waste of
a piece but now he's bringing it in well
he's creating it for another piece that
hasn't moved but he is developing
man he does I think he's played it
the good news for Frank is there was no
way to blunder uh the uh the bishop you
could go here and The Rook is defending
uh it's actually kind of easy to make an
illegal move
because you forget tonight but there
will be no penalties
no penalties at bar we don't believe in
that we should have a creative penalty
yeah next time we should pillow yeah you
eat the one Hot Chip yeah
let's just keep a hot chip on the table
next time at all times just to let them
know
what was that challenge was it the hot
chip challenge yeah
you have to say it was a beautiful
bishop move but kind of an
anti-climactic line because you just
trade two dead Bishops but Conor is up
so he wants to trade
he's up what right now upon yes just one
right
exactly those double pawns technically
count as less but again a pawn at 1000
ELO is no biggie anything can happen
here take with the Rook yeah
take with the rook and then do that two
move King yeah he could he could take
with the Rook or take with the King
because the Rook wouldn't want to be on
F1 probably wants a different Square
yeah regardless he'll have to bring the
king to the second rank just to free his
pieces so it's gonna happen anyways and
that Knight sucks yeah Connor should go
here and move the night out if if those
are his next two moves maybe with the
exception of also castling
he's in good position to win this end
game but it it really is only a pawn and
he does Castle and now Frank has to go
here like this is where the battle is
gonna happen or not uh they they they
could that's it I'm not trying to click
anything there
um yeah I feel like when teaching
beginners middle games Rooks to open
file oh one off close yeah that there's
nothing closed file there are two pawns
this is not where we want to put well
here's what I'm thinking and this might
be what Frank is thinking oh D5 you go
to no you don't do D5 you go Knight to
D2
you trade out take with your Bishop uh
or I guess now take with your Rook so
that the uh you can't lose your Pawn to
the to the night on C6
because if you you know what I mean yeah
there we go some of those lines are
right yeah yeah no so following though
that's a good one the other problem with
doing the the like Frank's gonna go here
no he's gonna move his Knight he wants
to get rid of that Knight that Knight's
annoying him so he's gonna offer the
trade he might also go here uh you don't
know Frank like I do oh oh there it is
oh my God you know Frank's so much
better than me
uh this Fork looks good for black but
then that pawn takes Knight and then you
get the second Knight here and that
could be game on
uh but Connor what
I don't even know I didn't even know
Knights could go backwards they patch
that
D6 look at this but now now you've
rotate out this way or there oh God he's
just now those Knights are really living
yes
very well could be the last game of this
tournament uh everything is under Fire
Conor went to the right file
Frank's also down three minutes thumbs
down three minutes he's probably hungry
I mean I got to eat like four pieces of
pasta in the last break yeah he's eating
none hey Connor's probably hungry too
and I think but he's eating whoa that's
whoa the bishop just dies and yeah I
mean he can even take the Knight first
because that doesn't even matter what he
takes he's taking something yeah and he
has taken
all right guy takes knife Knight takes
night
so it's like what a night in a bishop or
excuse me two nights for a bishop and a
rook
where where is the bishop he just lost
it right no Oh you mean at the end at
the end yeah yeah uh it is so he's going
to the end result is going to be the
black is up a rook for a night yeah so
I was like man I don't see a bishop on
the board it's been a long day
yeah now by the way Connor doesn't have
to take anything
the fork exists whether you take or not
yeah he could just play a rook C2 and
get real Annoying yeah Rook C2 is a
scumbag move and then
oh my God
no oh my God you all have eyeballs that
I will never have he's he left that's so
disrespectful yeah this is a nice move
too
you don't have to take that as
yep Connor's feeling himself yeah he is
so Ludovic you never told us who is
winning the games between you and Connor
last night was it Connor we went uh one
and a half to a half and I uh and I I
took the last one so you know everyone
says why didn't you keep competing bog
Champs because the people that I
hand-picked for POG Champs I all picked
the people that were worse with me
uh which I think made for a good show
this year
uh a lot of improvement I'm I'm really
worried Conor might go to the second
rank
will move his Knight and then Knight
takes G2 is literally Checkmate that'd
be so swag that would be it would be a
beautiful end why would he move his
Knight though you can't move oh my
goodness I keep right right clicking uh
you can't move much else that's the uh
that's the problem sure
he could go here too I assume he'll go
um
see I guess oh there's the Conor
thinking noise up up a game three
minutes and basically a rook of
Advantage but I like it who breaks
character he always takes it seriously
Until the End yep I mean the dude
brought a solaro Italian suit
against a 17 year old
yeah it's a suit every Italian boy must
own oh I see is he he's not Italian
though nobody went through a vacation so
close
I went I went to Italy recently my
Italian
on your way I'll give you that all right
a bit more pesto pasta and you're there
yeah I got like six pieces down there
I'll eat them on the uh well the show
might be over after this but hopefully
not hopefully we get a tie break so oh
wow see dogs shaking
so nervous
I want to see Rook C2 it just would be
such a nice smooth down to the second oh
my gosh if Frank moves the night night
takes Pawn is Checkmate what a sick
Checkmate that would be for the finals
of POG Champs and nightmate
Frank's got three and a half minutes
to figure out what to do here
it's not easy
Conor's hair looks like how they carve
Greek marble statues yep yep yep or
Italian ones you know and they have
Vatican they got the
you know Italy's
younger than America
as a country yeah yeah yeah yeah I did
not know that yeah Italy didn't exactly
that's why every every region and big
city has its own dialect and its own
culture and
yeah they can all tell the differences
we can't we're just like it's 8 30.
[Laughter]
is it really what you want to hear
dude Frank is so sick he's needling
Connor while getting crushed this is
good
does Franco it's his move
you know certainly we're in a game huh
you want a game
do you want the game says Frank
potentially moments away from wondering
you gotta appreciate this confidence I
hope he doesn't play something like
Rogue F3
for another two minutes
I would take the two minutes to give
Conor a Stern talking to you and then
resign
how dare you there you go
all right now Conor's gonna remember
what the plan was before the needling
began he's gotta take the only other
rookie is now eligible to capture
I don't really know what he's thinking
about but I suppose that's what he does
he thinks when thinking is not required
yep
it's time for him to start cleaning up
take the Rook take the pawn the knights
pinned bring the other rook and he does
have to take the Rook now because the
fork is not there anymore yeah that's so
I'm curious why he's thinking so long
but Frank's needling could have paid off
Connor's maybe I'll just be the changing
point in the game I I that would be
really impressive this is more
impressive if sea dog does not win than
if Frank wins yeah this is a very bad
position what's the opposite of a Hail
Mary here of the opposite of his Bishop
Jesus yeah or whatever he believes in
you know sure nothing yeah
this is a tough moment silence in the
playing hall both players slowly
realizing their fate
it's a rare moment this is a we have
never seen Frank not speak for this long
no but he cannot it's gonna break so
he's definitely cooking something up
he's gonna say some crazy he's gonna
look at the Sea Dog and be like you
smell good I hope so oh Connor didn't oh
what he didn't take the Rook Frank can't
believe he was confused too
so where do you move B1 A1 I guess it's
here right yeah you get one you got it
if if Franco's here he really hates
Rooks
I mean yeah I mean you might think
that is true that is true that would be
logical from his point of view and
Connor there's two things Connor could
still do here get mated right get mated
um or win this Pawn Loki he wins that
pawn Frank
all of a sudden kind of cooking
and he's played Rook B1 wow
which is not the best move because now
as Alexandra was pointing out this Pawn
is not protected so just simply going
here is
nice but there there's ways you I mean
there's ways to lose you know Connor
might go for a check
yeah he could go check which is actually
not good King gets out everybody gets
out and then you know that that's not a
narrow that's legal but you know we get
the Rook on the C file maybe I think if
he checks but it almost looks like he's
preparing for a check
I think he's going to check it I think
Frank's gonna take
it going in an end game only up a pawn
versus a rook and a knight looks very
dryish but I don't know which player is
stronger in the end game well Conor with
double the time for sure
also yeah I mean he he's the favorite in
in all the phases of the game I think
but just slightly but that's the worst
type of opponent right like imagine you
play somebody who's slightly better than
you at every phase
that's why game one was so impressive
because Frank fought for so long and
then even then CDOT could have won the
game on in one move
and we wouldn't even be commentating
this game right now so that goes to show
you how close it's been but Sea Dogs
just been a little bit more accurate but
here he is tanking again and
like he shouldn't be frustrated at all I
mean he is completely winning it is not
even I think he's frustrated because he
realized he can't take a win in exchange
yeah you missed that rook and now he's
hovering and he's going
Frank is bring breaking the stoic man I
mean it's really frustrating when you
realize you made a mistake it can
definitely shake you Knight C4 is is a
move he's making like the most passive
moves possible it's very confusing yeah
he's going back but Knight super is very
confrontational because the knights see
each other and if Frank moves his Knight
Rook takes Rook well that's fine right
nice face tonight King takes
yeah and then there's this and then
Frank's King gets out and like I said if
Conor starts going for these pawns and
not that one
all right the trades are coming whoa his
clock just jumped wait they don't have
30 second increments
he has to move faster though yeah
that's not great because now his King is
yeah trapped behind that line of fire
himself up the worst nightmare scenario
for Frank 51 Rook C1 yeah
that's great that's great and Rook A2
would be a huge
that's the best move Rook C1 is is
definitely stronger in the end game
wow that was a very nice Rook move Frank
just got an apartment for his Rook that
has like no windows he's living in New
York rent's expensive okay yeah it's not
it's even expensive with no windows it's
illegally not even a bedroom just slowly
bring up his King he doesn't have to do
anything literally uh if Connor plays H6
he's the POG Champs Champion like if he
just doesn't get mated
um and he won't I think there's the same
idea and and now rookie Rook this
guarantees a rook trade by the way
rotating The Rook his hand is shaking
and
that's likely it they're giggling
they're giggling but
well Frank's giggling because it's 12K
regardless it wasn't a winner takes all
situation and and that's just it that's
it
goodness a great find from Connor to not
take the pawn as well and even a
stalemate wins him pop Champs until
I want to get the prediction correct but
it has to be a stalemate it does have to
be a stalemate which again would still
make Conor the champion yes
uh I don't know of any potential wins
for Frank here
no yeah me me neither
the pawns cannot break through the other
Pawns
can take them all
make them all
right wait okay good Frank is maybe
trying for salmon Frank if he's gonna
lose he's going to lose the most points
possible
okay
foreign
ER is finally smiling a little because
he knows you
his fate is all but done
oh
so it would have been nice
Ian try bringing his King into h8 and
hoping for the best
there you go well you have that little
background
yeah I like it comfy gorgeous I'm not
Monday
yeah why no draw I win right yeah
just oh when I just go out with dignity
if you draw so
Frank calls it like we all see it
um
is he gonna accept the drama
I kind of want to win this I'm sorry
I don't want you to I don't want you to
I just wanna I wanna make sure I can get
this without choking my entire he's so
competitive
old you can't can't make a draw here
I'll keep it a stack it would be
embarrassing if Connor Drew after doing
this what are you doing here what are
you doing oh it's made on the board wait
wait
so did I uh I think so right yeah
on the board
I like the official in the back is that
Michael yeah that's me that's great yeah
man that was yeah wow wedding in so many
of those games dude congrats to Sea Dog
oh my God and there it is our POG Champs
five Champion Sea Dog VA takes down
Frank three games to one all right well
uh and that was that was I think all off
the momentum of game three yeah
definitely game three game two was an
equalizer game three was right back to
where we started in game one and Bishop
to age six the call of the Gods
that was almost
like zero adaptation because they were
both so incredibly weak at their
individual like openings
uh when they had white when they had
white yeah they're just bad at White I
don't know yeah that was just surprising
It's usually the opposite yeah but they
were both rough starting out and uh that
was a that was a massive massive
turnaround because if he won game three
Frank we would have been sitting here
talking about I don't even know who
would have white in a tie break it would
be the higher accuracy the higher cap
score probably Conor but also I mean
Connor had an incredible performance
throughout POG Champs he beat Frank 2-0
in the previous bracket so I think he
was the most deserving
yeah I I'm still you know Frank Nation
morons today because Frank had insane
improvements but yeah both our players
are walking on set right now come have a
seat
[Music]
[Applause]
trophy
POG champ five there it is it is our
first ever
the physical trophy will this goes
through carry-on luggage uh it will but
you will have to claim it as a sex item
I think they're gonna crack it open this
looks like you would stole something
yeah right it really does hey chest
trophy I do not get drugs uh there's a
video of the making it's actually insane
there's like one piece it's a really
beautiful piece I can't believe that one
what the I can't either because
Frank deserved to win game three Frank
you played so well dude thanks how do
you feel
um feel good
well I think you're a dominable spirit
capture the hearts of many your refusal
to ever quit even in the worst of
circumstances in your positivity uh it
was a pleasure to watch you play uh are
you happy you made it this far yeah I'm
chilling yeah you still get 12 000. oh
yeah I mean that's still a holiday yeah
you know maybe you just go to stoke on
track and save some money Stoke on the
trend that's a good holiday place I love
Stoke in England yeah he went to stoke
on Trent it was a mistake 12 Grand
12 Grand is still kind of drink goes a
long way it goes a long way like a horse
carriage from London it's very expensive
uh well I guess let's talk about the
most pivotal game because you both I
think we can say it we're pretty bad
with white yeah yeah I think we have a
terrible one I think that's fair oh yes
and why do you think that is
I just I don't know I just didn't want
to be better and why it just kind of
feels weird yeah I just wanted to make
it equal oh sure yeah
what do you want from me
What About You Frank oh I just didn't I
just I don't know I just played bad was
it a bit of nerves because you're you're
playing when you were playing with black
was phenomenal I mean it was like it was
really tight outside of the one bait
move which I guess we have to talk about
no do you know while you were doing it
live I called it out well you know and
over there we could hear you guys
screaming no so when I played them away
I had got them go
really
give it away and that didn't rattle you
you weren't like oh this is terrible for
me well I just full
um oh they're screaming
I was like what are you doing don't
scream
how is it not sound oh my God
no I just think that he used to summoned
the same energy you say whenever a rook
is sacrificed I think that would have
gone through but you you were here
because he was going you know how about
this Play Bishop here and then we were
like that's actually the really creative
ideas right I mean I was in Hail Mary
because I was I was done so I was I was
ribos yeah you were getting destroyed
that match careful it was I yeah did you
sense that you were winning game three
yep and then I saw that bishop and then
there was but why did you take it
like he didn't have a threat so you just
thought he was just giving you a bishop
because he's trying to coach harassed
you right now
I was hoping he thought that I was like
resigning just take it definitely no
baits here why didn't you act it a
little bit like yeah
[Laughter]
knowing something bad would happen
he wanted to find out
ever again I think that'll be like this
whenever a bishop moves there I think
you'll have horrible champ six Park
champ six prick I think you are one of
the most improved players over the
course of POG champs this is a different
prank from when I played this is the
first week I played Frank was totally
different oh we suck on it we saw you
going out for a move like this I was
like what the I was like because
everyone had such low time I was
freaking out 20 seconds with your win I
I had that I felt like I had that game
too but I didn't I didn't I lost it
because that's not what it means when
you have a game uh well it was an
absolute pleasure watching you both play
I have an important question
what is the future of relationship of
you and chess Frank I'll start with you
um
so that's my but you're keeping at it
yeah
no plans to slow down until your GM uh
well I'll try GM apparently I might get
old and depressed before that happens
what are you telling your students that
wasn't me that was
[Music]
uh Connor what about you what's your
relationship with chess you're gonna
keep playing you didn't play too much
going into this but you played probably
more tests than you ever have over the
past month I mean it's just so stressful
and it really like ruined my month like
I can't do anything when you're in pork
chops it ruins your life
oh I got twenty thousand dollars and
flown out to L.A just go gamble and I'll
get quadruple
all right what the heck
let me know seriously uh I I've got to
do chess again I don't wanna I don't
wanna study I'll probably be hard stock
1100. yeah I think if Frank had another
week I'm cooked like next time me and
Frank play I'm done like he's crushes I
believe that yeah this is the only time
I could ever beat you again like I don't
think I'll ever be able to beat you
again yeah and I'm obviously not gonna
go gamble my money that's smart that's
smart that's smart
it's actually
I just don't gamble that's mine
well Frank uh we watched you play we had
a great time doing it you get twelve
thousand dollars hopefully that's a nice
holiday for you your mom your family uh
Connor 20 000 which I don't know what
you do buy another Italian suit I guess
you probably goes to another video idea
that will make money so it's you know it
bounces out eventually it all bounces
out but you get the nice trophy in the
background I'm sure your stream will be
very proud and I'm sure we'll see it in
a YouTube video in a couple of weeks uh
but for everyone at home thank you so
much for watching pogchamps five
congratulations to Connor again in our
runner-up Frank congratulations to e-rob
the winner of our salty sweet match
against tyler1 and congratulations to
Virtual the winner of our constellation
bracket uh that's it for POG Champs five
there will be a lot more chess happening
this year but that's to talk about
another day thank you all for watching
Everybody all right goodbye we're all
gonna go uh hang out and into the sunset
we always hang out when you're not
watching Levy join the waving I just I
just did I was a woman
continuing we love you we all love you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
who is going forward yes
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign